GOOD MORNING I SHOULD SAY.
THE AFTERNOON WILL BE HERE
MOMENTARILY --
I WANT TO WELCOME EVERYBODY HERE
TO THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE ON
S. B..
NINE OH ONE I REALLY APPRECIATE
--
MY SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY FOR
TAKING.
TIME ON THIS VERY VERY CRITICAL
WORK.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE
HERE.
OR WHO ARE TURN IT TUNING IN AND
PUBLIC REVIEW IN INPUT.
IS A SATCHEL IN THE PUBLIC
PROCESS.
BEFORE WE KICK OFF THIS FIRST
HEARING.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ME IS CO CHAIR
THEY CLEARLY EXPLAIN MY GOALS
TODAY.
AND OVER THE NEXT MONTH.
THESE GOALS ARE VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD FIRST AND
FOREMOST.
YOU FIGHT FOR THOSE DEVASTATE IN
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
FIRES.
TO PREVENT FUTURE WILDFIRES FROM
CLAIMING [inaudible]
NEW VICTIMS [inaudible]
SECOND PREVENTING RATEPAYERS AND
TAXPAYERS FROM BEARING UNDUE
COST.
WE'VE SEEN UNPRECEDENTED
WILDFIRES ACROSS THE ENTIRE
STATE IN RECENT YEARS.
MY COMMUNITY WAS DEEPLY IMPACTED
BY THESE WILDFIRES LAST YEAR AND
I'VE ALREADY HAD NINETY THOUSAND
ACRES.
BURN IN MY DISTRICT ALONE THIS
YEAR.
WE CAN'T GO BACK IN TIME AND
CHANGE THE PAST TRAGEDIES.
BUT WE CANNOT FORGET ABOUT THE
VICTIMS.
AS A STATE WE MUST SUPPORT THEM
WEREN'T FROM THE STAKES IN THE
PAST.
IT ENSURED THAT WE WORK TO
PREVENT FUTURE WILDFIRES.
IN IMPLEMENTED BEST PRACTICES
GOING FORWARD.
IN ELKS OF PREVENTION IS WORTH A
POUND OF CURE.
WE NO DOWN POWER LINES OF
BECAUSE MANY OF THE DEVASTATING
FIRES IN THE PAST.
HELLFIRE IS COMPLETED
INVESTIGATIONS IT JUST SIXTEEN
OF LAST YEAR'S FIRES IN ITS FOR
ELEVEN CASES.
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S BECAUSE
THEY FOUND EVIDENCE OF CRIMINAL
VIOLATIONS MAINLY DEALING WITH
TREE CLEARANCES.
FRANKLY PGM A VIOLATED OUR TRUST
INVEST BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
CLEARLY THE UTILITIES IN THE
CPUC NEED TO BE FORCED TO STEP
UP.
IT SURE THEY'RE MEETING OUR
SAFETY NEEDS.
BEFORE DISASTER STRIKES.
IT'S ALSO ABSOLUTELY INEXCUSABLE
AND IT CAN'T BE ALLOWED TO
HAPPEN AGAIN.
IF THE LEGISLATURE FAILS TO ACT.
AVOIDABLE FIRES WILL CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT SPECIAL
INTEREST.
THEY'RE NOT OUR CONCERN RIGHT
NOW.
AGAIN THIS IS ABOUT COMMUNITIES.
VICTIMS AND RATEPAYERS
[inaudible]
PAST PRESENT AND FUTURE.
AND ULTIMATELY.
WHAT'S BEST FOR THEM.
I BEEN ON A MISSION OF WILDFIRE
RECOVERY PREVENTION AND
MITIGATION ALL YOUR LONG.
THE LAST FIRE SEASON UNDERSCORED
THE NEED TO THINK INNOVATIVELY
AND PRO ACTIVELY.
WE CAN ALL AGREE THE BUSINESS AS
USUAL IN A WORD [inaudible]
IS UNACCEPTABLE.
IT WE ALL AGREE THAT WE SHOULD
DO A BETTER JOB OF MANAGING OUR
ELECTRICAL SYSTEM.
SO POWER LINES DON'T START HUGE
FIRES.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE STRENGTHENING
FIRE PREVENTION ACTIVITIES SUCH
AS VEGETATION REMOVAL.
IF FOR STRUCTURE MAINTENANCE
UTILITY COMPANY INSPECTIONS
INTEMPERATE SHUT OFF OF POWER.
DURING EXTREME WEATHER
CONDITIONS.
MORE EXPANSIVE A DETAILED
WILDFIRE EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
PLANTS.
AND THAT MEANS BETTER UTILITY
PLANNING A GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THOSE WHO
OPERATE THE GRID.
INCLUDING CHECKING COMPLIANCE.
BEFORE A FIRE.
THAT'S AN AREA WHERE THE CPUC
HAS DONE QUITE POORLY REGULATED
UTILITIES IN ENSURING PUBLIC
SAFETY.
BUT WE ALL KNOW.
THERE'S NO SILVER BULLET FOR
PREVENTING.
SUCH DEVASTATING WILDFIRES WE
NEED TO TAKE A THOUGHTFUL
[inaudible]
HOLISTIC APPROACH.
THIS IS GOING TO BE AN OPEN
TRANSPARENT AND DELIBERATIVE
PROCESS.
TODAY WE ARE STARTING WITH AN
OVERVIEW.
AND WILL EXPLORE MORE ISSUES IN
DEPTH AND SUBSEQUENT HEARINGS.
AS A COMMITTEE WE WILL BE
TARGETED OUR SCOPE.
BUT LET ME MAKE THIS STATEMENT.
THIS IS NOT A CHRISTMAS TREE TO
ADD ON RELATED ISSUES.
WORKING TOGETHER BUILDING UPON
OUR WORK OVER THE LAST YEAR I
TRULY BELIEVE WE CAN MAKE REAL
PROGRESS THAT WILL MAKE OUR
STATE.
A SAFER PLACE.
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND FOR BEING HERE TODAY I WANT
TO TURN IT OVER TO THE CO CHAIR
OF THIS.
COMMITTEE CHRIS HOLDEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHRIS HOLDEN.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD AND I
JOIN WITH YOU AND YOUR ASSOCIATE
WITH YOUR COMMENTS.
OF OUR PURPOSE HERE IN THESE
CLOSING WEEKS.
SESSION IS TO BRING TO FRUITION
MONTHS.
OF RESEARCH AND DISCUSSION AND
HEARINGS CONCERNING WILDFIRES.
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND YOU LOOK
UTILITY IMPACTS.
AS WE HAVE SEEN THE GROWING
CHANGE IN OUR WEATHER PATTERNS
AND A RESULTING RESULTING
GROWING THREAT OF CATASTROPHIC
FIRES IN OUR STATE.
WE MUST CHANGE HOW WE THINK
ABOUT AND MANAGE THAT THREAT.
THAT STARTS WITH ENSURING A SAFE
AND RELIABLE ELECTRIC GRID.
WE MUST PREVENT THE FIRES THAT
FROM OCCURRING. TO THE DEGREE
POSSIBLE AND THAT THE ELECTRIC
UTILITIES HAVE A CLEAR AND HIGH
STANDARD OF CARE TO ENSURE
PREVENTION AND SAFETY.
WHEN THESE TRAGEDIES DO OCCUR?
UTILITIES MUST BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE IF THEY DO NOT MEET
THAT STANDARD.
BUT WE ALSO NEED OUR ELECTRIC
UTILITIES.
THERE ARE THE BACKBONE OF OUR
DAILY EXISTENCE AND OUR ECONOMY.
THEREFORE WE MUST CONSIDER WAYS
THAT THE UTILITIES CAN MANAGE
THE COSTS WITHOUT DISRUPTING
SERVICE TO CUSTOMERS.
OR TRIGGERING EXCESSIVE REPAIR
IMPACTS.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE GOVERNOR
BROWN'S LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE.
I'M PLEASED TO ASSIST THE SEE
THAT HE IS FULLY ENGAGED IN THIS
IMPORTANT TIMELY ISSUE.
WE WILL REVIEW AND CONSIDER HIS
SUGGESTIONS AS PART OF THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HIM.
AND AS SUCH I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR AGREEING TO SERVE.
AND TAKING THEIR TIME TO BE A
PART OF HELPING TO CRAFT WHAT WE
THINK IS A VERY IMPORTANT --
CONCLUSION TO SOME IMPORTANT
ISSUES.
THANK YOU CENTER GREAT.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER [inaudible]
FIRST.
BEFORE OFFER ANY STATEMENT
REGARDING THE ROLE OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE COMPLEX ISSUES
THAT WE MUST FACE.
I'D LIKE TO START WITH CONVEYING
MY HEARTFELT CONDOLENCES TO THE
VICTIMS AND THEIR FAMILIES IN
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WILDFIRES.
IN THE DISCUSSION OF THE POLICY
AND IN THE BATTLE OVER THE
POLITICS I DON'T WANT US TO LOSE
SIGHT OF THE DEVASTATING.
OF THE DEVASTATION FACED BY
COMMUNITIES IN THIS STATE
WILDFIRES.
DEVASTATION THAT IS DISPLACED
THE LIVES OF ENTIRE COMMUNITIES.
ERASED DREAMS AND MEMORIES AND
THAT IS ULTIMATELY COST LIVES.
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE SUFFERED WE
OWE IT TO THEM TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA IS READY TO DEAL WITH
THE GROWING.
FIRE DEBT DANGER.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO EXTEND THE
GRATITUDE OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
THE FIRST RESPONDERS.
FIRST RESPONDERS WHO OF BATTLED
OF THESE FIRES ARE CURRENTLY
SUPPRESSING FIRES UP AND DOWN
THE STATE.
WORKING THE FIRE LINES MAYBE
YOUR PROFESSION.
BUT WE ARE AND ALL OF YOUR
BRAVERY AND SACRIFICE AND THAT
OF YOUR FAMILY'S WHILE YOU ARE
IN HARM'S WAY.
WE KNOW THAT THE DESTRUCTIVENESS
OF WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA IS
INCREASING DUE TO A VARIETY OF
FACTORS.
INCLUDING MULTI YEAR DROUGHT THE
AFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
IT IS CLEAR THAT.
IT IS A CLEAR THREAT THAT WE
CANNOT IGNORE.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THEIR ARE
MEASURES THAT CAN TAKE CAN AND
MUST BE TAKEN TO REDUCE THE RISK
OF WILDFIRES.
ADDITIONALLY THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
FOUND RESPONSIBLE FOR THE WILD
FIRES WE'VE ALREADY SUFFERED.
MUST BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
SOME STUDIES HAVE FOUND THAT 50%
OF CALIFORNIA'S HOMES FACE.
SEVERE WILDFIRE RISKS.
NO ONE IS INSULATED FROM THIS
DANGER.
THE RESULTING DESTRUCTION COSTS
COST ALL OF US.
INCREASED RATES OF INSURANCE
PREMIUMS UTILITY CHARGES AND
COST AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
LAST YEAR THE COST TO CALIFORNIA
ALONE WAS OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
THE POINT IS THAT WE ALL PAY IN
SOME FORM.
THERE IS THIS IS NOT SOMEONE
ELSE'S PROBLEM.
WE MUST USE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
GET A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
DANGER THE RISKS AND OUR POLICY
OPTIONS.
THE NIGHT THE DANGER MAY BE
INCREASED BUT WE SHOULD NOT
ACCEPT THESE RESULTS AS THE NEW
NORMAL.
AS THE HOOVER INSTITUTION STATED
IN A POLICY BRIEF ON
CALIFORNIA'S FIRE DANGER.
AND I QUOTE.
DEVASTATING FIRES ARE NOTHING
NEW IN CALIFORNIA STATE HISTORY
AND FROM EVERYTHING WE KNOW THEY
WILL REMAIN A CONSTANT FORCE.
HOWEVER A FUTURE FILLED WITH
MORE AND MORE DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES.
EACH OUTDOING THE LAST IS NOT
INEVITABLE.
THE STATE CAN MAKE CHOICES NO
THERE WILL HELP KEEP IT SAFE FOR
IN THE FUTURE.
WE'VE BEEN TASKED WITH REVIEWING
EVIDENCE HEARING TESTIMONY AND
WEIGHING THE INTEREST OF ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO PROVIDE
COMMITTEE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
PROPOSALS.
THERE WILL BE.
IN THE FINAL CONFERENCE REPORT.
TODAY'S HEARING IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT TO LAY THE FOUNDATION
STATE THE FACTS AND FRAME THE
ISSUES.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
MY COLLEAGUES ON AN ISSUE THAT
REQUIRES EXTRAORDINARY ATTENTION
AND A COMMITMENT TO DO WHAT'S
BEST FOR THOSE MOST AFFECTED.
AND TO TAKE MEASURES THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY REDUCE THE RISK AND
DANGER A FUTURE WILDFIRES.
SO THERE HUESO.
I JUST SIMPLY WANTED TO CONCUR
WITH THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MISTER.
AND MISTER CHAIRMAN.
OF AND AND CONCUR WITH THE
COMMON SORT OF MADE BUT SIMPLY
TO STATE.
THAT OF I BELIEVE.
THAT.
THE TIME HAS COME FOR US TO
REALLY STEP UP AND MAKE.
SOME POLICY CHANGES SETTING
CALIFORNIA TO ADDRESS.
THE CHANGES THAT ARE HAPPENING
OUR STATE IS UNDERGOING.
AN ENORMOUS CHANGE.
I MEAN IF IF PEOPLE.
NOW I BE NOT ONE THING I HAVEN'T
HEARD IS THAT THE CLIMATE CHANGE
DENIERS HAVE BEEN VERY QUIET
LATELY.
AND ONE THING IS VERY OBVIOUS --
EVEN EVEN THE ANIMALS ARE
MIGRATING NORTH.
SENDING US A MESSAGE SOMETHING
IS HAPPENING WITHOUT A CHANGE
OUR POLICY. TO ADDRESS THAT.
AND AND IT SADDENS ME TO SEE.
YOU KNOW AS WE SPEAK NOW.
FIRES APPROACH YOSEMITE.
THEIR FIRES BURNING CURRENTLY IN
OUR STATE CAUSING ENORMOUS HARM.
AND IN ITS ANNUAL COUNTY THERE
BEEN JUST DEVASTATING FIRES JUST
LIKE IN ANY OTHER COUNTY.
BUT IT'S AN EAGLE COUNTY WE HAVE
TAKEN.
ALREADY SOME --
ENORMOUS MEASURES --
TO PREVENT.
AND UNLESS IN THOSE FIRES AND
I'M VERY PROUD OF THE WORK WE'VE
DONE IN SAN DIEGO.
AND ENSURE SERVES AS A MODEL OF
WHAT WE CAN DO IN THE STATE.
THEIR POLICIES AND SAN DIEGO
THAT APPLY ONLY TO SAN DIEGO.
AND THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
BECAUSE FIRES ARE AFFECTED EVERY
PART OF THE STATE NOW AND START
FIRST WE NEED TO START LOOKING
AT HOW.
THAT'S WORKING FOR US IN HOW CAN
HELP THE RISK STATES THANK YOU
TAKE SENATOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DOLLY.
THANK YOU --
CHAIRS ALSO WANTED JUST TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY THINK THE
GOVERNOR THE PROTIV IN THE
SPEAKER.
OF FOR CALLING THIS HEARING IS
SO THAT WE CAN.
A PROCESS THAT I THINK THE
VICTIMS DESERVE I THINK THAT THE
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT TOM.
YOU KNOW WHO'S LIABLE IT THERE
IS LIABILITY OUT THAT WE NEED TO
TAKE CARE OF A BUT I WANT TO
SHARE THAT --
FOR THE SIX YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE
I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT FIRES
AND YOU KNOW REPRESENTING A
FORCED TO DISTRICT AND OUR
WATERSHEDS --
YOU KNOW WE PUT OURSELVES IN
THIS POSITION --
WE'VE GOT A HUNDRED YEARS ALMOST
A HUNDRED YEARS OF FIRE
SUPPRESSION IN CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE SUPPRESSED WILDFIRE AND
ALLOW THE VEGETATION --
TO GROW AND WITHOUT ADDRESSING
--
THINNING ARE FORCED ALLOWING
FIRE TO DO IT WAS NORMALLY
SUPPOSED TO DO WHICH WAS THEN
THE FOREST --
THAT'S GOTTA BE PARTICIPATION
THAT WE NEED TO BE PROACTIVE
MOVING FORWARD ON HOW WE MANAGE
OUR FOREST.
ADDED A PATIENTS GO WHERE WE CAN
--
MAKE IT SAFER FIRE TO BE BACK
INTO OUR ECOSYSTEM SO --
I APPLAUD THIS COMMITTEE FOR
COME TOGETHER I APPLAUD THE
SPEAKER THE GOVERNOR THE PROTIUM
UP USES NECESSARY THERE ARE A
LOT OF MOVING PIECES.
OF THIS WON'T BE EASY BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY WE NEED.
TO LAY OUT A PLAN FOR THE FUTURE
--
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE LAST FOUR
YEARS WE'VE HAD. FIVE OF THE
STATE'S LARGEST FIRES AND
THEY'RE NOT --
MANY DISTRICTS ARE AND THAT WE
HAVE A VEGETATION AND FUEL
LOADING PROBLEM THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS.
ALONG WITH A MANAGING OUR GRID
IN A WAY THAT TIME MINIMIZES --
WILDFIRE SO AGAIN I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE I'M LOOKING FORWARD.
TO AN OPEN AND TRANSPARENT --
MEETINGS WHERE WE ACTUALLY HEAR
FROM ALL SIDES IN THAT WE CAN
DETERMINE WHAT'S THE BETH PASSED
--
FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHAT.
THINKCENTRE DOT AND I ONE THING
--
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY FOR THOSE
COMMENTS WE'VE BEEN PREACHING
THE SAME MESSAGE FOR YEARS NOW
AT I REMEMBER.
DISTINCTLY THE LAST NIGHT OF
SESSION TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN HE
SPOKE ABOUT THIS ON THE FLOOR
AND THE VERY NEXT DAY A MAJOR
FIRE BROKE OUT IN LATE COUNTY.
AND HERE WE ARE THREE YEARS
LATER WE'RE STILL WE'RE STILL
NOT CLOSER TO RESOLVING SOME
THESE CRITICAL CRITICAL ISSUE SO
I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH YOUR
COMMENTS AND AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU ON THAT.
LIKE SENATOR DIED --
MY DISTRICT WAS DEVASTATED BY
THE FIRES --
PEOPLE DIED.
THAT HASN'T COME UP YET. FORTY
FOUR PEOPLE DIED AS A RESULT OF
THESE FIRES.
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES LOST THEIR
HOMES EVERYTHING THEY OWNED IN
ONE NIGHT.
TODAY MIGHT MANY OF THOSE
FAMILIES A LOT OF THIS CANCERS
ARE LIVING WITH FRIENDS SUMMER
STILL LIVING IN MOTELS.
SUMMER LIVING IN RENTALS THAT
HAVE SKYROCKETING COST ALBEIT
WALLPAPER BY INSURANCE MOST OF
THEM.
GOOD TAKE AS MANY YEARS TO
REBUILD THE HOMES THE BUSINESSES
THAT WERE LOST AND IN THE END MY
COMMUNITY WILL NEVER BE THE
SAME.
THESE PEOPLE ARE MY PRIORITY.
HOW TO PREVENT AND PAY FOR
WILDFIRES IS DOMINATED MY MY MY
THOUGHTS EVERYDAY SINCE OCTOBER
OF LAST YEAR?
IT'S A COMPLICATED EMOTIONAL
PROBLEM HOUSE OF THESE FOLKS BE
MADE WHOLE.
HOUSE WE BETTER MANAGE OUR FOR
SOME WILD LANDS IN THIS NEW
NORMAL.
WHICH THE NEW WE SHOULD JUST
TAKE IT OFF QUIZ THAT ENOUGH
TIMES PASS I DON'T THINK IT'S
NEW ANYMORE --
AND HOW CAN WE ENSURE THE
VITALITY OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
A MEAGER TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A SAFE FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND A FAIR SYSTEM
TO HOLD RESPONSIBLE PARTIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR FOR THEIR FOR
THE DAMAGES.
BUT LET ME BE CLEAR.
I WILL VIEW EACH PROPOSAL FIRST
AND FOREMOST DO THE LANDS.
OF HOW IT WILL IMPACT THE
SURVIVORS.
NOT JUST IN MY DISTRICT BUT
EVERY CALIFORNIAN WHO HAS
SUFFERED THE TRAGEDY OF THESE
FIRES.
AND WHAT WILL IT MEAN FOR THE
FAMILIES AND BUSINESS OWNERS WHO
ARE TRYING TO BUILD THEIR
REBUILD THEIR HOMES AND REBUILD
THEIR LIVES.
I SPENT MOST OF MY TIME THIS
PAST YEAR THINKING AND TALKING
ABOUT THE ISSUE AND I THINK
THERE ARE SOME GOOD SOLUTIONS
OUT THERE I'M I'M EXCITED TO
WORK ON THIS COMMITTEE.
AND I HOPE WE CAN COMEUP WITH
SOME OF THOSE AND PUT THOSE INTO
MOTION.
BUT IF OVER STRONGLY THERE WAS A
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE MISSING.
AND I'M CONCERNED WITHOUT
KNOWING THE CIRCUMSTANCES
SURROUNDING THE TUBS FIRE.
THE CONVERSATION MAY BE
PREMATURE.
I'M WAITING FOR THAT REPORT.
HOW CAN WE COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION WE DON'T HAVE THE
BECAUSE OF ONE OF THE MAJOR
PROBLEMS THE MOST EXPENSIVE FIRE
IN THE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR THE
REPORT ON THAT?
I WANNA THANK THE CHAIRS IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING.
THROUGH THE RECESS TO GET
UNDERWAY HERE ON THANK THE
PANELISTS FOR COMING TODAY AND I
LOOK FOR TODAY'S CONVERSATION.
SO HER STOMACH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COLLEAGUES OF FIRST OF ALL --
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANDRA
DINO LIKE.
TO THANK OUR FIRST RESPONDERS --
THAT HAVE DONE A YEOMAN'S JOB OF
OF PUTTING THEIR LIVES ON THE
LINE AND AND TRYING TO SAVE
STRUCTURES AND PREVENT ME FOR
THE LOSS OF LIFE THAN THE FORTY
FOUR OF VICTIMS OF WE SAW HERE
IN.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND INTO THE INTO THE VICTIMS
AND THEIR FAMILIES --
WE COME TOGETHER HERE TODAY TO
TRY TO FIND SOLUTIONS THAT THE
FIGHT WITH EACH OTHER BUT TO
ENSURE THAT WE DO THE BEST WE
CAN -- TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC AND IS OUR
NUMBER ONE RESPONSIBILITY AND I
WANNA THANK --
ARE PRO TEM --
ATKINS --
FOR HAVING THE CONFIDENCE IN
CHOOSING ME AND MY MY DEAR
FRIEND US SENATOR CANNELLA. TO
WORK WITH THIS VERY ESTEEMED
BODY -- TO
COME UP SOME BLISS WAS SOLUTIONS
AND THAT AND FIGURE --
A LOT OF VARIABLES OUT THAT
REGIS.
DON'T KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT IT.
I LIKE TO TRANSPARENCY THE
COMMITTEE.
BUT I JUST WANT TO MENTION A FEW
THINGS AND I THINK WE ALSO NEED
TO OUGHT TO FOCUS ON DURING OUR
OUR DELIBERATIONS --
I CAME INTO THROUGH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO GET TO THE STATE
SENATE THAT WORKED --
AT THE COUNTY RIVERSIDE AND WELL
WE DON'T HAVE THE THE VAST
FOREST THAT YOU HAVE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA --
THE WE DO HAVE THE THE IDYLLWILD
AREA MOUNT SAINT ACENTO SO WE DO
HAVE SOME FORESTED AREAS AND I
QUICKLY LEARNED WHEN I FIRST GOT
ELECTED TO THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THE IMPORTANT OF THE
CALIFORNIA HERE TAX.
BASE THAT WE HAD IN OUR
LOCALITY.
THE SUPERVISOR THAT I DEFEATED
WANTED TO MOVE THAT YOUR TAX
BASE FROM HAMMER RYAN AIRPORT
WHICH WAS VERY CLOSE TO THE
MOUNTAIN COMMUNITIES TO MARCH
AIR FORCE BASE.
WHICH MEANT THAT THE CAL FIRE
AIR APPARATUS I WOULD HAVE TO OF
GONE WITH THE FEDERAL FLIGHT
PLANS TO GET TO THEIR
DESTINATION WHICH MEANT IT COULD
BE FORTY FIVE MINUTE DELAY. TO
GET TO A FIRE IN OUR FIRE CHIEF
OF MANY YEARS WHO WAS WITH
HELLFIRE FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS
CHIEF HAWKINS EXPLAINED TO ME
HASN'T.
A YOUNG A SUPERVISOR THAT YOU
WANT TO PREVENT THESE FIRES IN
GOING BEYOND TWENTY ACRES OF THE
WISE YOU NOW HAVE A WILDFIRE
THAT COULD BE MUCH MORE MORE
MORE DEVASTATING.
SO I HOPE THAT WE ALSO THAT
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT WHERE WE
HAVE OUR STRATEGIC AIR BASES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND DO WE HAVE AN APPROPRIATE
RESPONSE TIMES TO THE MOST
VULNERABLE.
AREAS A OF THE STATE.
AND THEN CERTAINLY IT YOU KNOW
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL --
AS WE LOOK AT PLANNING
APPLICATIONS SO I THINK WE NEED
TO FURTHER SCRUTINIZE NOW WHEN
PEOPLE WANT TO BUILD AN
EXTREMELY FIRE PRONE AREAS AND
AND AND START TALKING ABOUT AYE
KNOW THE BUILDING INDUSTRY TO
SOMEONE HERE ABOUT OTHER
MANDATES BUT WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW EXTERNAL SPRINKLERS
ATION IN THESE AREAS ARE RICH
EVEN DIFFICULT TO FIND.
OF FIRE INSURANCE.
I NOTHING TO WE NEED TO DO IS WE
HAVE TO GET PAST SOME OF THE
EXTREME POLICIES OF THE STATE
WHEN IT COMES.
TO THINNING OUR FORESTS THAT
HAVE DEAD TREES I MEAN WE HAVE
THE G. S. O. B. GOLD SUPPORTERS
THE GOLD SPOTTED.
ARE OPEN BORE IN OUR COUNTY THAT
WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF DEAD TREES
AND YET.
WE CANNOT GET IN THERE TO REMOVE
THEM AND THE FIRE HAZARDS --
THAT THEY THE THEY CREATE --
ALSO IF WE AS WERE ASSESSING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS FIRE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
IN MANY WAYS IT'S GOING TO BE.
EXTREMELY IMPACTFUL --
TO ARE INSURANCE COMPANIES CAN
BE IMPACTFUL TO POTENTIALLY --
UTILITIES AND WE NEED TO HAVE A
AN EMERGENCY FIRE RESERVE FUND
THAT IS SOMEWHAT SUSTAINING SO
THAT WHEN WE HAVE A DEVASTATING
YEAR WHICH WE HOPE WE DON'T HAVE
TOO MANY OF THESE THAT WE HAVE.
THE APPROPRIATE FUNDING AND
RESERVE READY TO GO TO MAKE
SURE.
THAT WE CAN DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO REBUILD AND AND RESTORE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE THAT.
OUR CITIZENS OF HAD TWO INDOOR
WHAT THE LOST OF THEIR HOMES
OTHER POSSESSIONS.
AND AND I HEARD FROM MY
COLLEAGUE GOD THAT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS A CLIMATE CHANGE
WHETHER%
WE SEE CLIMATE CHANGE AS A
RESULT OF MANMADE CAUSES OR
WHETHER IT'S JUST A CYCLE CHANGE
IN THE ENVIRONMENT I THINK THAT
THERE'S NO --
NO ARGUMENT THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING ODD GOING ON YET --
THE INSURANCE --
REGULATIONS OF THE STATE FOR
BED.
OUR OUR INSURANCE COMPANIES FROM
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH OUR A CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND THAT AND THEN LASTLY  WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT.
ALL OF OUR UTILITIES THAT HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT GOES IN AND
THROUGH --
AREAS WHICH ARE EXTREMELY FIRE
PRONE.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
DOING THE APPROPRIATE MEDICATION
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
APPROPRIATE WE TO PAYMENT AND
AROUND THEIR LINES WITHIN A
RADIUS OF THAT.
LINE COMING DOWN AND MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE LINES HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH
THAT IF THERE.
ARE BLOWN DOWN THAT THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO SPARK AND CONTINUE A
FIRE THAT EXISTING OR BECOME THE
NIDUS OF AND IV.
OF A FIRE IN BOTTOM LINE IS WE
NEED TO INCREASE OUR STANDARDS
--
FOR FOR MITIGATING --
THESE BUT I APPRECIATE US
SERVING WITH ALL OF YOU LOOK
FORWARD TO COMING UP WITH SOME
GOOD SOLUTIONS NOT ONLY. TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FIRES IN
THE BEST WAY --
TO SOLVE THOSE ISSUES BUT TO
PROSPECTIVELY COME UP WITH
POLICIES AND POTENTIALLY LAWS
THAT ARE GOING TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC --
FROM THE LOSS OF LIFE THAT WE
CERTAINLY SEE AND THE LOSS OF
PROPERTY --
AND THE IN THE DANGER MEANT OF
THE PUBLIC SAFETY LIES CENTER
THERE EVERYDAY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WERE PROTECTED.
THANK YOU SENATOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RACE YOU HAVE A STATEMENT
FROM --
SENATOR JACKSON.
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
OF THE STATEMENT FROM SENATOR
HANNAH BETH JACKSON READS AS
FOLLOWS THANK YOU SENATOR DOG IN
SOME REMEMBER HOLDEN FOR
ORGANIZING TODAY'S HEARING.
I REGRET THAT I AM UNABLE TO
JOIN BUT IS A CHAIR THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT THE
SUBSTANCE OF TODAY'S HEARING IS
OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE TO ME.
THE JOINT COMMITTEE IS HAVE HELD
AT NO LESS THAN SIX HEARINGS ON
WILDFIRE IN CALIFORNIA SINCE
LAST OCTOBER'S.
DEVASTATING NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
FIRES.
OUR COURAGE MY COLLEAGUES ON
THIS COMMITTEE TO REVIEW
TESTIMONY FROM THOSE HEARINGS AS
THEY CONSIDER PROPOSALS
DISCUSSED TODAY. FOR ME THIS IS
CENTER JACKSON.
THIS ISSUE IS PERSONAL.
EVERY EMBER OF LAST WINTER'S
THOMAS FIRE THE LARGEST IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY BURNED IN
MY DISTRICT. FOR FORTY DAYS
FIREFIGHTERS CAME FROM ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND INTERNATIONALLY
TO HELP US BATTLE A BLAZE THAT
ULTIMATELY BURNED.
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND ACRES DESTROYED MORE
THAN ONE THOUSAND BUILDINGS AND
CLAIMED TWO LIVES.
AND HARDLY A MONTH FROM THE
START THE FIRE UNPRECEDENTED
REIGNS IN THE HILLS ABOVE
MODESTY THOUGH UNLEASHED A FIRE
CAUSED DEBRIS FLOW.
THAT UP IN THE TREES SWEPT AWAY
CARS LEVELED HOMES BURIED.
HIGHWAY ONE A ONE UNDER TWELVE
FEET OF MUD AND KILLED TWENTY
THREE OF MY NEIGHBORS.
THE PEOPLE OF SET SENATOR
JACKSON'S DISTRICT CONTINUE TO
LIVE WITH THIS DISASTER FOR
EIGHT MONTHS NOW AND EVERY DAY
FACE THE PROSPECT OF NEW FIRES
ERUPTING IN THE DROUGHT PARCHED
LANDSCAPE OF THE CENTRAL COAST.
SENATOR JACKSON CONTINUES WE
NEED TO FIND WAYS TO GET AHEAD
OF THESE INCIDENTS AND HELP OUR
LANDSCAPES BECOME MORE
RESILIENT.
WHILE ALSO DOING ALL WE CAN TO
STOP WILD FIRES FROM BREAKING
OUT IN THE FIRST PLACE.
OUR GOAL MUST BE AN ACQUITTAL
UNEQUIVOCAL AND OUR STRATEGY
CLEAR WE NEED TO REDUCE WILD
FIRES IN CALIFORNIA.
SO FOR EVERY PROPOSAL WE
CONSIDER IN THIS COMMITTEE WE
SHOULD ASK WILL THIS POLICY
REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD AND SIZE
OF WILDFLOWERS.
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA IF THE
ANSWER IS NO THEN WE NEED TO
KEEP SEARCHING.
SENATOR JACKSON ENDS BY SAYING
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR ORGANIZING
TODAY'S HEARING AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO JOINING IN PERSON FOR
FUTURE HEARINGS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SO AT THIS TIME --
WE'RE GONNA.
HAVE OUR FIRST --
SPEAKER PANEL BOB ARE UTILITIES
A CLIMATE CHANGE MICHAEL JUARA.
IS A RESEARCH FELLOW AT THE
STATE'S DIRE TAYLOR CENTER FOR
ENERGY POLICY IN FINANCE.
THE STANFORD WOODS INSTITUTE FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT [inaudible]
WHAT UP?
I DO WANT --
EVERYBODY TO KNOW THAT WE'RE
GONNA PUBLIC A COMMENT AT THE
END OF ALL THE PANELS. ONE
COMMENT I PERIOD ALTHOUGH
MEMBERS.
OBVIOUSLY WILL BE ALLOWED TO ASK
QUESTIONS AND HAVE DISCUSSION ON
THESE IMPORTANT TOPICS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THAT'S IF A MIKE THERE ABOUT
NOW.
THERE WE GO MUCH BETTER.
SENATOR DODD ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR INVITING
ME TO COME TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY -- I
AM GONNA TALK ABOUT
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTIONS TO
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA.
I VIEW WILDFIRES.
AS A SPECIES OF CATASTROPHIC
RISK. TO HURRICANES IN THE
SOUTHEASTERN UNITED STATES FOR
FLOOD RISK IN MANY PLACES
[inaudible]
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM.
WE CONFRONT AS A STATE AND YOU
CONFRONT AS A COMMITTEE IS THAT
THE CURRENT SYSTEM FOR
ALLOCATING IN MANAGING THE RISK
OF WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA.
IS UNSUSTAINABLE. FOR MULTIPLE
REASONS. ONE IS THAT.
THE SITUATION IS UNSAFE AS I
HEARD YOU ELOQUENTLY SPEAK ABOUT
THIS MORNING. TOO MANY PEOPLE
ARE BEING KILLED [inaudible]
AND HURT.
AND THEIR LIVES DESTROYED BY
WILDFIRES IN THE STATE.
PART OF THE REASON FOR THAT ARE
SIGNIFICANT PART A RISK THAT IS
THAT ALL SIDES OF THE PROBLEM
ARE NOT BEING WORKED
EFFECTIVELY.
SUMMER BEING WORKED LESS THAN
THEY SHOULD.
SOME ARE NOT EVEN ADDRESSED
[inaudible]
IN ADDITION [inaudible]
IMPORTANTLY.
WILDFIRES AFFECT EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THEIR IMPACTS
ON THE FINANCES OF EVERYONE
CALIFORNIA EITHER AS IN
ELECTRICITY CUSTOMER.
OR AS A TAXPAYER.
RATE PAYER IMPACTS IF IT TURNS
OUT THAT RATEPAYERS ARE
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR THE FIRE THAT
WE KNOW THE LEAST ABOUT TUBBS
FIRE [inaudible]
COULD BE.
ANYWHERE --
FROM TWENTY TO FORTY DOLLARS PER
MONTH. FOR EVERYONE IN THE P. G.
SERVICE TERRITORY.
WE DON'T KNOW WITH THE OUTCOMES
IN THE THERE BUT THAT RISK IS
THERE FOR TUBS AND FOR A FUTURE
FIRED THAT MIGHT OCCUR IF P.
JEANNIE.
BEHAVES PRUDENTLY WHICH
HOPEFULLY THEY DO --
FINALLY.
BECAUSE OF THE THREATS TO THE
FINANCES OF THE ELECTRIC
UTILITIES [inaudible]
WILDFIRE.
FUNDAMENTALLY THREATENS THE
CLIMATE AND CLEAN ENERGY GOALS
OF THE STATE.
UTILITY RISKS WILL WILL AND
ALREADY ARE INCREASING THE
EXPECTATION FOR RETURN ON EQUITY
OF THE FOLKS THAT OWN P. JEANNIE
SHARES.
THAT'S GONNA RAISE THE COST FOR
EVERYTHING THAT YOU AND MANY OF
THE MEMBERS --
WOULD LIKE TO ACCOMPLISH OVER
THE NEXT DECADE.
POTENTIALLY TO LEVELS THAT RULE
OUT.
ACHIEVING THE CLIMATE TARGETS --
AND SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO BEAR IN
MIND THAT ALL OF THIS IS
CONNECTED.
AND IT MANAGING THIS RISK
AFFECTIVELY.
SHRINKING THE RISK IS GONNA
HELP.
MAKE OTHER GOALS ACHIEVABLE.
A SOLUTION TO WILDFIRE RISK IT'S
AN ADDRESS ALL THE DIMENSIONS OF
THE RISK WILDFIRE RISK IS NOT
JUST A UTILITY ISSUE I WOULD
ARGUE THAT IT IS NOT EVEN MOSTLY
A UTILITY ISSUE.
THERE ISSUES AROUND A POLICY
SOLUTIONS GONNA REQUIRE THINKING
ABOUT THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
LIABILITY.
THAT ALREADY IS EXIT EXISTING.
FOLKS NEED TO BE MADE WHOLE PUT
BACK IN THEIR HOUSES AS
EXPEDITIOUSLY AS POSSIBLE.
THEY'RE IMPORTANT ISSUES AROUND
INVERSE CONDEMNATION UTILITY
WILDFIRE PLANNING ACCOUNTABILITY
AND ULTIMATELY COST RECOVERY.
HOMEOWNERS PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURANCE AND REINSURANCE
THERE'S A BREWING.
INSURANCE CRISIS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF THIS RISK
AND THE LACK OF MANAGEMENT
THAT'S OCCURRING WE NEED TO LOOK
AT THAT.
A HARD PROBLEM.
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WHERE
PEOPLE ACTUALLY LIVE CONTROLLED
BURNS ARE IMPORTANT.
BUT WHERE THE VALUE AT RISK AND
THE LIVES AT RISK ARE MOST
CONCENTRATED CONTROLLED BURNS
ARE VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
ACCOMPLISH OTHER SOLUTIONS TO
TAKE ACCOUNT OF THE DIVERSITY OF
PROPERTY OWNERSHIP IN THE SMALL
PARCELS ARE GONNA BE REQUIRED.
LAND USE PLANNING AS WAS
MENTIONED IS GOING TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT AND BUILDING CODES
ESPECIALLY FOR OLDER BUILDINGS.
CURRENT FIRE SAFE BUILDING CODES
APPLY ONLY TO BUILDINGS THAT ARE
NEW SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT OR
SUBSTANTIALLY REBUILT SINCE
[inaudible]
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT SO.
EFFECTIVE RISK MANAGEMENT IT'S
GONNA APPORTION THE RISK TO
THOSE WHO CAN MANAGE IT MOST
EFFICIENTLY AND THAT MEANS
CARVING UP.
RIGHT NOW AT LEAST FOR UTILITY
COSTS WILDFIRES.
MOST OF THE RISK RESTS WITH
UTILITY RATE PAYERS BY INVERSE
CONDEMNATION AND EXPENSES
ALLOWED IN RATES IF THE UTILITY
WAS PRUDENT.
OR WITH UTILITY SHAREHOLDERS BY
INVERSE CONDEMNATION OR THE AND
DISALLOWANCE IF THE UTILITY WAS
NOT PRUDENT [inaudible]
SIGNIFICANTLY HOMEOWNERS AND
THEIR INSURANCE COMPANIES DON'T
BEAR A LOT OF THAT RISK BECAUSE
THEY CAN SUBJUGATE AGAINST THE
UTILITY.
WE SHOULD BE ASKING WHETHER THAT
IS APPROPRIATE NOT BECAUSE
SOMEONE SHOULD OR SHOULD NOT
PAY.
BUT BECAUSE ALL ASPECTS OF THE
PROBLEM NEED TO BE WORKED
DEFENSIBLE SPACE IS IMPORTANT.
INSURANCE AND THE INCENTIVES
THAT CREATES ARE SOME OF THE
STRONGEST.
METHODS FOR GETTING TO THE
PARCEL LEVEL AND HELPING PEOPLE.
TO MOBY MOTIVATED AND CONCERNED
WITH CREATING THAT SPACE.
BUT I THINK THE FIRST STEP IS TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE TO KIND OF
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEMS ONE IS
EXISTING LIABILITIES AND THE
OTHER IS TO GO FORWARD PROBLEM
THE FUTURE LIABILITIES THAT
MIGHT BE CREATED AND AND IT'S
IMPORTANT.
TO ADDRESS THE EXISTING
LIABILITIES FIRST IN MY VIEW
BOTH BECAUSE THEY ARE REAL
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN HARMED AND
OUR VICTIMS AND NEED TO BE MADE
WHOLE.
AND BECAUSE IT SIMPLIFIES.
POLITICAL THE POLITICAL ECONOMY
OF ADDRESSING THE GO FORWARD
PROBLEM WHICH IS IN FACT I THINK
CRITICAL TO THE FUTURE OF THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES --
ONE PROPOSAL FOR THE EARLIER THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND POTENTIALLY
EARLIER LIABILITY IS
SECURITIZATION AND WE'VE SEEN AB
THIRTY THREE INTRODUCED OR
AMENDED BY --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK --
I THINK IT'S A PROMISING
PROPOSAL THAT HAS A NUMBER OF
KEY ON ANSWER QUESTIONS ONE IS.
WHAT'S THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT
SECURITIZED HOW MUCH OUR
RATEPAYERS GOING TO BE ON THE
HOOK FOR WHAT IS THE MAXIMUM
LEVEL THAT'S A BLANK SPOT IN THE
BILL.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT QUESTION IS
THE PROCESS FOR CREDITING RATE
PAYERS IF UTILITIES AT FAULT.
AND SOME GUIDANCE FROM THE
COMMITTEE IN THE LEGISLATURE ON
THE PROCESS IF A DISALLOWANCE
DOES NEED TO OCCUR.
THE GO FORWARD RISK FROM
WILDFIRES IS A MUCH MORE COMPLEX
ISSUE.
AND HERE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO SET EXPECTATIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT.
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM.
NEEDS TO START THINKING ABOUT
BUT MAY BE MORE COMPLEX THAN IS
FEASIBLE TO ADDRESS IN A MONTH
--
ONE POTENTIAL SOLUTION.
POR PART OF A SOLUTION I WOULD
I'M GONNA EXPLAIN WHY MEAN BY
THAT IS IN VERSE COMBINATION
REFORM.
FROM MY VIEW IF THAT'S GONNA
HAPPEN IS THAT THE BEST OPTION
IS TO MOVE AS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL DOES FROM STRICT
LIABILITY TO A REASONABLE
STANDARD. FOR ALL ELECTRIC
UTILITIES BOTH PUBLIC AND INVEST
AROUND.
LIM DOT CHANGE TO WILDFIRES.
AND INSURE THAT THE UTILITIES
ARE STILL LIABLE IF THEY'RE
NEGLIGENT WHICH THEY SHOULD BE.
AS THEY A AND NOT THAT RECREATES
IN CALIFORNIA THE NATIONAL
STANDARD. FOR TO WHICH UTILITIES
ARE HELD.
MY VIEW IS THAT IT IS
CONSTITUTIONAL I'M HAPPY
EXPLAINING QUESTIONS ON WHY I
THINK THAT.
THE KEY ISSUE THOUGH.
THE ONE NOT ADDRESSED SO FAR IS
THAT OUT OF THAT MOVE ALLOCATES
RISK FROM UTILITIES. TO
HOMEOWNERS AND THEIR INSURERS --
ANOTHER PIECE OF THE STATE'S
POTENTIAL SOLUTION IS UTILITY
BETTER UTILITY WHILE ARE
PLANNING A COST RECOVERY.
WE HAVE TO REQUIRE UTILITIES TO
TAKE INNOVATIVE STEPS TO REDUCE
RISKS IN THE DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEM.
TO SOME DEGREE THIS IS ALREADY
HAPPENING VIA THE CPC PROCESS
AND AND FAST ACTION AT THE
COMMISSION.
ARE S. B. TEN EIGHTY EIGHT OR
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WHICH IS
MY I THINK IN SOME WAYS MODELED
ON TEN EIGHTY EIGHT WILL IF
ENACTED CREATE A SORT OF
CENTRALIZED PROCESS FOR DOING
THIS.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
LOOK AT OTHER MODELS FOR
MANAGING RISK IN COMPLEX SYSTEMS
AND AT THE ENTERPRISE LEVEL.
AND TWO OF THE MOST IMPORTANT I
THINK OUR SARBANES OXLEY.
THE KILLER SECTION THREE OF TO
IN SECTION FOUR A FOR WHICH
REQUIRE CEO AND GENERAL COUNSEL
LEVEL ACCOUNTABILITY FOR RISK
MANAGEMENT.
AND THE NUCLEAR AND OIL INDUSTY
WHERE COMPLEX SYSTEMS.
SAFETY IN COMPLEX SYSTEMS IS A
CORE MISSION.
AND WHERE THERE'S A LOT OF
LEARNING THAT HAS BEEN DONE OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL DECADES THAT WE
COULD BENEFIT FROM AND THE
UTILITIES COULD --
A THIRD PIECE OF A POTENTIAL
SOLUTION AND ONE THAT WILL
BECOME ESSENTIAL IN MY VIEW.
IF INVERSE CONDEMNATION REFORM
WERE TO OCCUR IS REFORM OF
PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURERS.
WE WOULD NEED IS A STATE TO TAKE
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO REDUCE THE
EXIT OF MAJOR INSURERS FROM THE
HOMEOWNERS MARKET.
IF WE SHIFT SIGNIFICANT WILDFIRE
RISK TOWARD HOMEOWNERS INSURERS
THAT IS A PROBLEM THAT IS
ALREADY HAPPENING ALREADY
BREWING WHERE I LIVE.
MANY OF THE LARGE INSURERS DO
NOT WRITE NEW POLICIES THAT IS
TRUE ACROSS LARGE FRACTIONS OF
THE STATE AT THIS POINT.
NONE OF THOSE INSURERS ARE
CANCELING POLICIES ARE REFUSING
TO RENEW.
BUT IF WE WERE TO SHIFT A
SIGNIFICANT CHUNK OF LIABILITY
IN THEIR DIRECTION GIVEN
PROPOSITION ONE OF THREE AND
THEIR INABILITY TO PRICE THE
RISK.
THAT IS A FEASIBLE OUTCOME IF
YOU LIMIT PRICE THE RESPONSE OF
THE MARKET IS TO LIMIT SUPPLY
WE'RESEEING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
RIGHT NOW WE CAN SEE MUCH MORE
IF IF THE STATE ISN'T CAREFUL.
TOM I THINK A LOT OF THINKING
NEEDS TO GO ON HERE THAT'S A
VERY COMPLEX ISSUE WITH VERY
DIFFERENT POLITICS IN THE ENERGY
SYSTEM.
AND THAT'S PART OF THE REASON
THAT I VIEW THIS LIABILITY
REFORM ISSUE IS MORE COMPLEX
THAN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
LIABILITY.
AND THE AND TO SOME DEGREE ARE
CLARIFICATION OF THE COST
RECOVERY PROCESS --
ANOTHER PIECE OF THE PUZZLE THIS
IS MY TOWN.
ON A BAD DAY IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY NINE BUT PRINT
THAT WE HOPE NEVER OCCURS AGAIN
--
FOR FIRE.
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT NOT JUST
IN A CONTROL BURKE CONTEXT BUT
WHERE PEOPLE LIVE.
CURRENT NON UTILITY VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
DISPROPORTIONATE ON PUBLIC LANDS
AND SPARSELY POPULATED AREAS
THAT NEEDS TO CHANGE IF WE ARE
GOING TO REDUCE RISK --
I HAVE A NUMBER OF AYE THOUGHTS
ABOUT THAT --
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT ONE
PROBABLY IS TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS IS A COLLECTIVE ACTION
PROBLEM THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED THE COMMUNITY LEVEL.
AND THAT CARROTS ARE MORE LIKELY
TO BE EFFECTIVE AND STATE --
WELL I JUST SAID THAT DEFENSIBLE
SPACE IN MANY VERY FINE HIGH
FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES.
IS LARGELY NONEXISTENT.
THIS A PICTURE SAUSALITO ONE OF
THE PLACES WHERE STATE FARM
INSURANCE THAT'S NOT RIGHT NEW
POLICIES AND YOU CAN SEE EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE.
VERY HIGH VALUE REAL ESTATE.
NO DEFENSIBLE SPACE LOT OF OLD
STRUCTURES WITH SHINGLE SIDING.
THAT IS A TINDERBOX WITH MANY
LIVES AT RISK DENSELY POPULATED
URBAN COMMUNITY.
COULD BE JUST LIKE COFFEE PARK
ON A BAD DAY --
WE NEED INSPECTION EDUCATION
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES.
AND POTENTIALLY ASSISTANCE TO
HOMEOWNERS TO HELP THEM CUT DOWN
TREES THAT THEY MIGHT OTHERWISE
HAVE A HARD TIME AFFORDING TO
HELP PAY FOR THAT BARBAROUS WORK
IT'S GONNA KEEP THE COMMUNITY
SAFE --
FINALLY AND MAYBE THIS IS THE
HARDEST ISSUE [inaudible]
ARE.
LANCE LIMITING LAND USE
EXPANSION INTO THE WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE BECAUSE OF THE
RISKS BECAUSE OF THE COSTS
CURRENTLY SOCIETY IS SOCIALIZING
OF COSTS.
EITHER IN RATES OR IN --
OR VIA TAXPAYER FUNDING OF
FIREFIGHTER RESPONSE COSTS
[inaudible]
AND SOUND CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RISK MANAGEMENT DICTATES RETREAT
FROM SOME OF THESE AREAS.
AND AT A MINIMUM IMPOSING SOME
OF THE COSTS ON THOSE AREAS THAT
THEY CREATE.
THAT IS A VERY DIFFICULT
POLITICAL PROBLEM WE'VE SEEN.
EXAMPLES OF IT PLAY OUT IN THE
FLOOD INSURANCE CONTACTS OR
HAVEN'T MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS
--
OTHER STATES HAVE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS WITH RESPECT TO WINDS
DAMAGES AND WIND INSURANCE I
WOULD RECOMMEND THE COMMITTEE
LOOK AT THE EXPERIENCE OF THE
SOUTHEASTERN UNITED STATES.
IN ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE THERE A
LOT OF SURPRISINGLY PROGRESSIVE
POLICIES COMING OUT OF VERY
CONSERVATIVE STATES TO DEAL WITH
THIS PROBLEM.
AND I THINK IT'S ANOTHER THIS IS
ANOTHER.
VERSION OF THAT.
WE HAVE PUT PEOPLE IN HARM'S WAY
VIA A WHOLE SLEW OF POLICIES
THAT WERE WELL INTENDED OVER THE
LAST HUNDRED YEARS.
AND WE NEED TO HELP THEM STAY
OUT OF HARMS WAY BUT ALSO NOT
MAKE THE PROBLEM WORSE --
SO THERE'S A WHOLE SET OF THINGS
UC A COMPLEX MENU.
I THINK WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
FULLY ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM I
HOPE THAT THE COMMITTEE CAN MAKE
A VERY GOOD START PERHAPS
ACCOMPLISH SOME OF THE EARLY
ISSUES THAT THE SIMPLER PROBLEMS
NOW.
AND MAYBE GET A VERY SIGNIFICANT
SUBSTANTIVE BEGINNING AND START
TO THE CONVERSATION ON THE
HARDER ONES --
I JUST IF I SAID TO THEIR TWO
SETS OF ISSUES ONCE TRACTABLE
PERHAPS IN A MONTH.
ANOTHER MAY.
TAKE MORE TIME.
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE SURGICAL BUT
IT'S A STRETCH GOAL. TO RESOLVE
THE LIABILITY QUESTION IN MY
VIEW.
AND I WOULD ALSO JUST EMPHASIZE
ONE THING ARE.
THAT THAT THAT IN CONCLUDING.
THERE TO HAVE POLITICAL
CONCLUSIONS THAT I'VE HEARD.
IN THIS CONVERSATION FROM THE
ELECTRICITY CRISIS AND I THINK
THEY'RE BOTH WORTH BEARING IN
MIND ONE IS DON'T LET UTILITIES
GO BANKRUPT.
AND WE'VE HEARD THAT THE CEO A
P. GENIE HAS MENTIONED
BANKRUPTCY ON AN EARNINGS CALL
SHAREHOLDERS THAT'S AN UNUSUAL
THING FOR CEO TO SAY.
OUR TO HURT SHAREHOLDERS --
THE OTHER THOUGH IS EQUALLY
IMPORTANT BEWARE THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF COMPLEX CHANGES
HASTILY MADE.
RIGHT BEFORE THERE WAS A UTILITY
BANKRUPTCY THERE WAS.
RESTRUCTURING OF ELECTRICITY
SYSTEM IN A MANNER THAT.
TURNED OUT TO BE UNWISE AND
DIDN'T FULLY TAKE ACCOUNT OF THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE SYSTEM AND THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE CHANGES BEING
UNDERTAKE.
BOTH APPLY HERE.
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU --
TO HELP TO KEEP CALIFORNIANS
SAFE AND TO DO THE WORK THAT WE
CAN DO THIS YEAR TO KEEP
CALIFORNIANS SAFE AND TO MAKE
THEM WHOLE.
AND BUT ALSO TO BEAR IN MIND
THAT SOLVING A PROBLEM IN THE
ELECTRIC UTILITY SYSTEM BY
CREATING ONE SOMEWHERE ELSE MAY
NOT SERVE ANYONE'S INTERESTS.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I I'VE I'VE GOT ONE
QUESTION THAT I I YOU TALK ABOUT
THAT THE CONCEPT OF SECURITIZED
INVESTOR OBLIGATIONS --
YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT.
SECURITIZED AIMED AT AS AND A B.
--
THIRTY THREE I GUESS WHAT I'M
WONDERING IS IS.
CAN YOU SECURE TIES [inaudible]
THE INVESTOR.
PORTION OF IT.
IF IT WAS A HIGH BRED WHICH IS
SAY OF AB.
THIRTY THREE AND THERE WAS A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF THAT THAT
WE FELT WAS NECESSARY. TO TO
STAY WITH THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY.
AND SOME PORTION WITH THE
RATEPAYERS I'M WONDERING WHAT
THE MECHANISM.
COULD POSSIBLY BE TO
SECURITIZED.
TO HELP THE INVESTOR SO IT
DOESN'T [inaudible]
AT YELLOW.
PERHAPS TAKEN INTO BANKRUPTCY IF
THAT'S THE WORRY AFTER WE I HAVE
THIS THIS DAY IS CONCLUDED WHAT
WHAT WHAT DO YOU SEE THIS AS FAR
AS A PROCESS IN THAT REGARD.
WELL I THINK I THINK THE
PROPOSAL THAT'S BEEN PUT FORWARD
IS A REASONABLE ONE IT'S A ONE
THAT IT'S ONE THAT HAS A TRACK
RECORD THAT DATES BACK TO THE
ELECTRICITY CRISIS WE ALL PAY
ARGUE W. ARE BOND CHARGE ON OUR
ELECTRICITY BILL --
FOR BETTER OR WORSE --
AND IN MY VIEW STE
SECURITIZATION WAS TRADITION
REALLY DOES IS SPREAD THE COSTS
OUT OVER TIME. TO THE DEGREE
THAT IT'S PROBLEMATIC WHAT'S
PROBLEMATIC ABOUT IT IS THAT
YOU'RE IMPOSING COSTS.
THAT ARE CREATED BY CURRENT RATE
PAYERS AND THE UTILITY TO
CURRENT UTILITY ON FUTURE RATE
PAYERS WHO MAYBE DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING TO CAUSE THIS PROBLEM
OR CREATE THIS PROBLEM.
I THINK THAT.
SECURITIZATION WOULD DO MUCH TO
CALM SOME OF THE MARKETING IS IT
THAT APPEARS TO EXIST AROUND THE
CALIFORNIA INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES AND YOU SEE THAT IN
THE STATEMENTS OF THE RATING
AGENCIES [inaudible]
ALSO THE THE PRIVATE
CONVERSATIONS AND AND ANALYST
REPORTS FROM FROM THE FOLKS THAT
OWN.
OUR UTILITIES --
IT WOULD IT WOULD GIVE SOME
CONFIDENCE THAT.
THE UTILITIES --
THEY TILDE CONCERNS ARE TAKEN
SERIOUS AT IN THIS FACT THIS
COMMITTEE EVEN EXISTS GIVES SOME
CONFERENCE ON TO THAT --
THE PROBLEM WITH IT IS IT'S A
ONE OFF SOLUTION.
RIGHT IT MAKES PEOPLE HOLE IT
WOULD MEAN THAT.
P. JEANNIE COULD SETTLE --
PERHAPS SOME OF THEIR LAWSUITS
AND AND AND AND PAVE THE
UNDERINSURED AND UNINSURED
LIABILITIES FASTER RIGHT THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES PARTY PAID.
OR ARE PAYING MUCH OF THE
INSURED LOS --
I'M LESS CONCERNED THAT THEY GET
THEIR MONEY QUICKLY --
I THINK WE SHOULD BE LESS
CONCERNED --
BUT THE THE BIG QUESTION AROUND
I THINK THE BIG QUESTION AROUND
THIS IS HOW THE CREDITING.
RIGHT SO IF WE WERE TO SAY THAT
IF THE FIRM SECURITIZED IS THE
RISK -- AND
IT TURNS OUT [inaudible]
THAT.
TABS OR OR ANOTHER YOU KNOW OR
TALK HIGHWAYS THOMAS ISN'T IN
THIS BECAUSE IT'S I ONLY CAN
TURN SPEAKING AT THIS POINT.
BUT IF THE TUBS FIRE WERE --
ATTRIBUTABLE --
TO P. GENIES IMPRUDENCE --
HOW WOULD THAT CREDITING TAKE
PLACE OVER WHAT TIME FRAME WOULD
RATE PAYERS BECOME UNSEATED
WOULD BE OVER THE EXTENDED TIME
FRAME THAT WOULD TEND TO GIVE?
THE OWNERS OF THE COMPANY --
THE BENEFIT OF THAT TIME VALUE
OF MONEY --
AND WOOD HELP TO CALM THEM IN
TERMS OF THIS SORT OF PERCEIVED
CRISIS.
IT WOULD ALSO POTENTIALLY
BENEFIT RATEPAYERS IN TERMS OF
RETURN ON EQUITY --
THAT THAT THAT THERE WILL BE
ACOSTA CAPITAL PROCEEDING
EVENTUALLY FOR ALL OF THE
UTILITIES AND IF THEY ARE
EXPOSED TO THIS RISK FULY.
THERE'S LIKELY TO BE A MUCH
HIGHER COST OF CAPITAL MOVING
FORWARD.
AND THEN THERE IS NOW
[inaudible]
BUT THE KEY ISSUE THERE IS
CLARIFICATION ON HOW HOW TO PAY
BACK WHAT HAPPENS IF THIS WERE
ALLOWED.
PRIOR TO A FINDING APPROVED FIVE
FINDING IT PRETTY FIVE PRIOR TO
CONCLUSION OUT THE FULL CPUC
PROCESS.
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE OCCUR.
I GUESS THE I GUESS THE QUESTION
AND AND IT MAYBE WE DON'T HAVE
THE ANSWER NOW WE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO FIND THIS OUT.
YOU AT SOME POINT TIME
[inaudible]
YEAH IT'S EITHER CREDIT BACK
[inaudible] TO TO THE RATE
PAYERS OR SIMPLY.
THE UTILITY PAINT THAT SHARE.
YES OF THE SECURITIZATION YES
EITHER ONE WOULD BE FEASIBLE
YEAH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
REPRESENTATION NIGHT OF A COUPLE
QUESTIONS YOU KIND OF HIT ON A
COUPLE THINGS THAT.
THAT I THINK ARE IMPORTANT YOU
MENTION EXIT OF INSURANCE SIR
INSURERS FROM THE MARKET --
AND ENDING HE SAID WE NEED I
THINK YOU SAID WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY.
TO STEM THE TIDE OF THAT OR
MAYBE I MISSED THAT'S HOW I
INTERPRETED IT --
AND YOU TALK ABOUT BROADER
INSURANCE MARKET REFORMS --
DO YOU HAVE MORE THOUGHTS ON
THAT I MEAN.
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF BILLS
THAT CAME OUT OF THE FIRE THE
AFTERMATH OF THE FIRES.
AIMED AT SOME OF THESE THINGS
BUT I'LL BE HONEST YOU KNOW INS
IN SUMMER CASES I KNOW.
ABOUT 60% OF THE PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT WHO HAD LOSSES OR UNDER
INSURED.
AND IN MANY CASES INSURERS ARE
NOT WILLING TO WRITE UP POLICY
FOR THE FULL VALUE.
OF OF THE PROPERTY SO THEY WILL
BE CONTINUE TO BE CHRONICALLY
UNDER.
AND THAT'S A CHALLENGING EVEN
EFFORTS DO YOU ALLOW PEOPLE TO
BUY EXCESS COVERAGE --
BEYOND WHAT THEIR POLICY HAVE
BEEN MET WITH SOME RESISTANCE SO
--
YOU HAVE.
AS YOU AS WE START TALKING ABOUT
THIS.
AND AND THE SCOPE OF OF THE
ISSUES HERE IN THE POTENTIAL
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES I JUST
SEE.
I SEE [inaudible] TEN BILLS
COMING OUT OF OUT OF THIS
LOOKING AT A VARIETY OF SOBS
SUBJECTS BEYOND WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT HERE TODAY SO I WAS A
BROAD QUESTION BUT DO YOU.
YOU HAVE SOME THOUGHTS ON THAT
YOU COULD YOU MENTIONED YOU
MENTIONED PROP ONE OF THREE AND
THAT'S IF YOU HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE DISCOVERED I DON'T THINK
THAT PROP ONE OF THREE IS GOING
TO CHANGE ANYTIME SOON.
AND ANYTHING THAT HAPPENS ON THE
INSURANCE SIDE HAS TO BE
CONSISTENT FURTHER ITS PURPOSES.
AND THAT'S THAT'S THE JUDGE
MADE.
LAW ON THE ISSUE --
SO THE QUESTION IS HOW CAN WE
ACHIEVE.
INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR
HOMEOWNERS AT THE MOST
AFFORDABLE PRICE THAT REFLECTS
THE RISK THEY'RE TAKING RIGHT
AND RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE AT LEAST IN THE
VIEW OF THE MAJORITY OF THE
LARGE INSURERS.
THE PRICES THEY CAN CHARGE DO
NOT REFLECT AT RISK.
AND SO AND THAT'S PARTLY A
FUNCTION OF PROP ONE OF THREE
IT'S PARTLY FUNCTION OF RIGHT OF
DECISIONS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
IT'S IT'S A COMPLEX IT'S PARTLY
A FUNCTION OF PUSH BACK FROM
PEOPLE WHO RECENTLY YOU KNOW
DON'T ARE TRYING TO MINIMIZE
THEIR BILLS AND FOR THEIR
MORTGAGE.
AND THE LAST THING THEY NEED IS
A BIGGER INSURANCE BILL --
I THINK.
THERE A NUMBER OF ASPECTS OF THE
INSURANCE ON INSURANCE SIDE THAT
COULD BE CHANGED BUT THE
POLITICS OF INSURANCE ARE VERY
DIFFERENT THAN THE POLITICS OF
ENERGY WHICH IS WHAT I'M MOST
FAMILIAR WITH.
SO I'M I WANT TO BE A LITTLE BIT
HUMBLE HERE AND REFLECT THAT
REFLECT THAT KIND.
IGNORANCE --
BUT I THINK ONE OBVIOUS QUESTION
TO ASK IS.
WHY IT IS WHY IT IS THAT
INSURERS CANNOT REINSURER?
THEIR WILDFIRE RISK IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS A WELL USED TOOL FOR
MANAGING CATASTROPHIC RISK IN
OTHER STATES AND WE SHOULD BE
ASKING.
WHETHER THAT'S AN APPROPRIATE
STEP TO TAKE THAT WOULD HELP THE
INSURERS TO SPREAD OUT THEIR
RISK HELP THEM TO BE ABLE TO
ENSURE MORE.
OF THE RISK IN CALIFORNIA --
ANOTHER QUESTION TO BE ASKING IS
WHETHER WE WANT TO MOVE TOWARD
--
THE APPROACH THAT THE
SOUTHEASTERN U. S. IS TAKEN
WHERE THERE ARE SEPARATE STATE
RUN PROGRAMS THAT MANAGE A
PARTICULAR SLICE OF THE
HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE RISK.
THIS IS THE WIND INSURANCE AND
THE SOUTHEAST IT COULD WELL BE
THAT WE NEED TO DO THAT FOR WILD
FIRE INSURANCE IN CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD NOTS SING I WOULD NOT
SUGGEST THAT THE EARTHQUAKE
AUTHORITY IS THE RIGHT WAY TO DO
THAT.
I THINK THE LEARNING SINCE THAT
TIME IT'S BEEN DONE IN THE
SOUTHEAST ON WINS SUGGESTS A
DIFFERENT MODEL THAT IT'S MORE
EFFECTIVE --
AND I THINK THAT --
THERE HAS TO BE SOMEWAY IT'S WAS
INTERESTING SO PEOPLE WHO CAN'T
GET FIRE INSURANCE IN CALIFORNIA
KICKING HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE
BECAUSE OF FIRE.
AND UP ON SOMETHING CALLED THE
FAIR PLAN [inaudible]
AND IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING FROM
TALKING TO INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
ON THE FAIR PLAN.
THAT -- THEY
CAN BE CHARGED DIFFERENTIAL
RATES DEPENDING ON THEIR RISK
RATHER THEY HAVE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE OR NOT.
THOSE KINDS OF ISSUES.
THE SAME THING IS NOT
NECESSARILY THE CASE FOR THE
REGULATED LINES.
AND I DO THINK THAT WE NEED TO
START TO THINK ABOUT HOW TO
EDUCATE HOMEOWNERS ABOUT WHAT
THE RISKS ARE.
MOST PEOPLE WHERE I LIVE DON'T
HAVE DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND THEY
DON'T KNOW THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
IT.
NO ONE TELLS THEM.
NO ONE SAYS TO THEM YOU COULD
SAVE MONEY.
IF YOU CUT DOWN THAT TREE.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO MOVE IN
THAT DIRECTION IS A STATE THAT
MAY BE UNCOMFORTABLE FOR SOME
BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE TRIP.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
BUT IT ALSO IS RISKY AND
INCREASINGLY RISKY AND THE
CLIMATE WE LIVE.
COM AND YOU TALKED INTO.
JUST ANOTHER YOU TALK ABOUT
PROTECTION ESPECIALLY IN THE
WILD AND URBAN INTERFACE AND AND
WE'RE NOT DOING AS MUCH OF THE
GOOD IN YOU AND YOU JUST HIT ON
THAT I THINK.
I THINK SOMETIMES HOMEOWNERS
DON'T KNOW THAT THE TREES ARE
RISK AND THEN THERE I KNOW THERE
ARE SITUATIONS WHERE HOMEOWNERS.
MAY KNOW THERE'S A TO TREAT
SERVICE THEY DON'T WANT THEM CUT
DOWN BECAUSE FOR FOR OTHER
REASONS -- I
THINK THAT THAT AND THAT
CONTINUES TO JUST THE FUEL LOADS
IN THOSE AREAS CONTINUE TO BE A
PROBLEM.
AND WE KNOW WE'RE STARTING TO NO
OTHER WERE WAITING FOR SOME
ACTUAL MEASUREMENTS ON THIS THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE THESE HUGE FIRES
ALL THOSE GREENHOUSE GAS.
EFFORTS THAT WE'VE DONE FOR
REDUCTION --
GO OUT THE WINDOW BY HUGE
FACTORS AND THAT AIR QUALITY IS
PRETTY AWFUL BUT QUITE FRANKLY
AFTER HAVING LIVED THROUGH THAT.
THE DAY AFTER OUT THE TUBS FIRE
INBREEDING THAT FOR THREE OR
FOUR WEEKS --
SO.
IT YOU KNOW.
YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON IT
BECAUSE IT IS DIFFICULT TO GET
GRANDSON MEAN CERTAINLY IN MY
NECK OF THE WOODS WE CAN'T GET
GRANTS --
FOR SOME OF THESE ACTIVITIES
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THINGS ARE
SCORED --
THROUGH --
THROUGH ITS WE CAN'T GET ACCESS
TO SOME OF THE FUNNY TO DO
SOMETHING THE DO YOU HAVE
THOUGHTS ON ON HOW THAT MIGHT
HAVE THAT MIGHT PLAY OUT GOING
FORWARD.
WELL I MEAN I SEE JUSTIN MY
SLIDES THAT I THINK THAT WE NEED
TO DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE
LEVEL OF THE FUEL REDUCTION
GRANTS IN THE STATE AND THAT
THAT IS AN EXTREMELY COST
EFFECTIVE ACTION.
IN MY VIEW THOSE GRANTS ANY
INCREASE IN FUNDING SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON WHERE PEOPLE LIVE.
RIGHT DIRECTLY ON RISK REDUCTION
KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE.
THAT COULD BE A COST SHARE WITH
AN INDIVIDUAL PROPERTY OWNER
WHERE THEY HAVE A TREE THAT'S AT
RISK.
RIGHT IT'S BUDGET THAT CREATES
RISKY BUT IT'S IT'S IT'S GONNA
COST TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS TO CUT
DOWN.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT MAY BE A COST
SHARE FOR THE COMMUNITY.
IT COULD BE FULLY FUNDING
POSITIONS FOR PEOPLE TO GO OUT
INTO THE COMMUNITY --
ON THE IN THE LOCAL FIRE
DEPARTMENTS AND EDUCATE
HOMEOWNERS ABOUT WHAT HOW
THEY'RE CREATING RISKS.
NOT JUST FOR THEMSELVES BUT FOR
THEIR NEIGHBORS --
AND I THINK THE YOU KNOW THAT
THE LAST IN AND HARDER QUESTION
IS IS THIS ISSUE AROUND YOU
DEVELOPMENT.
AND AND AND THE FOOTPRINT OF NEW
DEVELOPMENT IN THE VERY HIGH
HAZARD AREAS.
AND THAT IS OBVIOUSLY THORNY
DEVELOPMENT LAND USE IS A LOCAL.
ISSUE ALONE AND ISSUE A REALLY
LOCAL CONTROL.
BY.
WE'RE CREATING THAT LOCAL
DECISION MAKING IS CREATING
SIGNIFICANT EXTERNALITIES FOR
THE STATE.
IN TERMS OF THE ELECTRICITY
SYSTEM AND ALSO TAXPAYERS AND SO
AT SOME POINT.
QUESTIONS NEED TO BE ASKED IN MY
VIEW.
THANK YOU A CENTER CANNELLA.
FIGURES CHAIRMAN SO IN YOUR
SLIDES I WANT TO THANK YOU
MENTION IS VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
--
WHERE PEOPLE LIVE YOU SAID WE
CAN EXPAND IT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
MY QUESTION?
OTHER THAN COSTS WERE SO THE
IMPEDIMENTS TO VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT [inaudible]
SEE -- ALL
THE ALSO TO THAT I THINK ARE
SIGNIFICANT. ONE IS THAT IN MANY
COMMUNITIES --
YOU ACTUALLY NEED A PERMIT TO
CUT DOWN TREES THAT ARE BIG.
FROM WHOM FROM THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CODE YOU NEED
HERITAGE TREE PERMITS I THINK
THAT THE STATE.
SHOULD LOOK AT THAT ISSUE AND
CONSIDER WHETHER --
IF A HERITAGE TREE IS LOCATED
WITHIN THE ZONE ONE AS CAL FIRE
I THINK LIKES TO CALL IT RIGHT
THAT FIRST THIRTY FEET. FOUR
HUNDRED FEET WEATHER PERMITS
SHOULD BE REQUIRED IF HOMEOWNER
ONE THIRTY FEET OR HER FEET FROM
THEIR HOUSE STRUCTURE THAT
YASSER --
AND THE YOU KNOW ANOTHER ANOTHER
BEER IN THIS IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT --
BUTI THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
ONE TO BE THINKING ABOUT.
IS THE ISSUE OF UTILITY.
TREE TRIMMING AND ARBORISTS IN
IS DENSELY POPULATED AREAS WITH
LOTS OF SMALL PARCELS CURRENTLY.
DE UTILITY CODE THE SAFETY CODE
SAYS THAT UTILITIES RESPONSIBLE
FOR CUTTING DOWN DEAD DYING
EXECUTIVE TREES OUTSIDE OF THE
UTILITY EASEMENT.
RIGHT IF THEY COULD FALL INTO
THE LINES THAT'S WHAT HAS CAUSED
ALL THE FIRES FOR WHICH WE HAVE
BY REPORTS SO FAR THIS FROM THE
PAST YEAR.
TREES OUTSIDE OF THAT TEN FOOT
ZONE THAT'S CLEAR GETTING BLOWN
INTO THE ZONE AND KNOCKING DOWN
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN YOU EXPLAIN A
LITTLE BIT SO.
THAT YOU'RE SAYING TREATING
HOUSES OR TREES THING Y. TREE
SITTING TREATING LINES OKAY SO
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT THAT
REQUIREMENT AND TEN FEET FROM SO
HOW FAR TO THE TREES OF BE
CLEARED FROM THE ACTUAL LINES.
THERE HAS TO BE TEN CLIP
CLEARANCE.
BEYOND AND PARDON ME I'M SURE
THERE ARE A LOT OF EXPERTS
SITTING BEHIND ME WHO KNOW THIS
MUCH BETTER THAN I DO UNLESS
THEM AS WELL BUT TEN FOOT
CLEARANCE AND THEN IT'S THE
RESPONSIBILITY ARBORIST. TO
CLEAR ANYTHING OUTSIDE OF THAT
EASEMENT THAT MIGHT FALL INTO
THE EASEMENT AND CAUSE A FIRE
THE CHALLENGES.
IN PLACES WITH THOUSANDS OF
LANDOWNERS YOU GOT TRESPASS
ISSUE.
AND MY QUESTION IS HOW CAN NOT
HOW CAN WE SERVE RESOLVE THAT
TRESPASS PROBLEM.
MAKE IT EASIER FOR THE ARBORIST
GOING TO SOMEONE'S BACKYARD IN
SAUSALITO AND CUT DOWN A TREE
THAT'S A RISK IT'S DEAD OR DYING
--
WITH DOUBTS --
AND AND AND MAKING OUT EASIER
THIS BOTH GOING TO REDUCE RISK
AND ALSO CREATE ACCOUNTABILITY
GREATER CAO BECAUSE THE CODE
ALSO EXEMPTS THE UTILITIES IF
THEY HAVE TO TRESPASS. TO GET A
TREE SO HOW DID YOU SEE THAT THE
FIRES WERE CARS BECAUSE LARGELY
BY.
TREES ON PRIVATE PROPERTY THAT
FILLED THESE LINES ARE WITH
THESE OUT YOU KNOW I CAN'T I
CAN'T LOOK AT IT I THOUGHT
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAID SO THERE
ARE SAID CENTER WE'RE GONNA BE
HAVE.
I UNDERSTAND BUT THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT TO CLARIFY WHAT HE SETS
OKAY I CAN'T.
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHEN YOU NEED NOTED YOUR
SOLUTIONS THE FIRST SLIDE ON
SOLUTIONS HAVE TO DO WITH
INVERSE CONDEMNATION?
AND DO YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS
CONSTITUTIONAL ACTION.
THAT A BIG PROBLEM WILL WORD
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THE INVERSE
CONDEMNATION.
A WHAT SPECIFICALLY DID YOU MEAN
BY.
CONSTITUTIONAL ACTION IN WHAT
I'M SORRY THAT WAS --
UNCLEAR --
WHAT I MEANT BY THAT IS THAT IT
WOULD BE CONSTITUTIONAL? FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO PASS A LAW WHICH
CLARIFIES --
THE MEANING OF INVERSE
CONDEMNATION --
AND THAT THAT ACTION IN MY VIEW.
WOULD BE UPHELD NOT REALLY IF
BUT WHEN IT WAS JUDICIALLY
CHALLENGED BY THE COURTS AND THE
KEY CASES THERE.
THERE'S A CASE CALLED --
METHODIST HOSPITAL OF SACRAMENTO
VERSUS SAILOR.
WHICH IS KIND OF THE THE THAT
DID MOST KEY CASON THAT DID LOOK
WITH THE SUPREME COURT LOOKED AT
ISSUE OF CLARIFICATIONS
INTERPRETATIONS OF AMBIGUOUS
PROVISIONS.
IN THE CONSTITUTION AND THE
LEVEL OF DEFERENCE THE COURTS
WILL GIVE TO LEGISLATIVE
INTERPRETATION OF AMBIGUOUS
PROVISIONS AND THE COURT SAID IT
IS NOT JUST THAT THEY THEY IN
GENERAL WILL DIFFER IN THE
SUPREME COURT'S YOU IT'S THEIR
DUTY TO DIFFER.
UNLESS THE PROVISION IS CLEAR --
AND AND IT LEGISLATURE IS TAKING
ACTION THAT'S CLEARLY --
CONTRADICTORY TO THE
CONSTITUTION NOW GIVEN THE CASE
LAW ON INVERSE CONDEMNATION
EARLY CASES ALBERS.
AND THE FLOOD INSURANCE CASES --
LACHLAN AND ITS PROGENY --
I THINK THERE'S A CASE TO BE
MADE A VERY GOOD CASE THAT A
NARROWLY TAILORED INVERSE
CONDEMNATION REFORM.
IS CONSTITUTIONAL WOULD WOULD
PASSED JUDICIAL MONSTER AND
JUDICIAL REVIEW --
ABROAD EXEMPTION.
IS A DIFFERENT STORY ALTOGETHER.
RIGHT BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT.
FLOOD CASES OR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL [inaudible]
ARE THEY'RE RELATIVELY NARROW.
LIMITED TO A CERTAIN SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES AND I THINK --
A BILL THAT.
LOOKS AT THAT ISSUE AND AND
EVALUATES THE FACTORS AND THERE
CAP APPLIES THEM TO THE FACTS WE
CONFRONT NOW --
HAS THAT HAS A VERY GOOD CHANCE
I'M OUT I WANT TO SAY IT'S A
CERTAINTY BECAUSE NOTHING IS
CERTAIN WHEN YOU.
GOT BEEN IN LITIGATION --
GOT TO SUPREME COURT BUT I THINK
IT HAS A VERY GOOD CHANCE OF
SURVIVING YOU SHORTLY.
TIM A MEMBER WOULD.
THINK THANK YOU MISTER I JUST A
QUICK FOLLOW UP AND THAT WAS IT
CO JOG MY THOUGHT PROCESS HERE.
YOU KNOW YOU TALKED ABOUT --
ART WHAT YOU TALKED ABOUT HOW WE
COULD DO SOME OF THAT ADDITIONAL
GRANTS FOR FOR AWHILE AND ENTER
THE URBAN INTERFACE --
AREAS AND IN MAKING AREA SAY ARE
THERE EXAMPLES WERE OTHER
JURISDICTION YOU TO AND YOU TALK
BUT CARROTS AND STICKS SO THERE
ANY EXAMPLES OUT THERE WHERE
THEY HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
IN THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS THAT
WE COULD.
RATHER THAN REINVENTING THE
WHEEL --
FIGURE OUT HOW.
BEACON.
IT'S I AGREE I I SEE WHERE
YOU'RE GOING BUT ARE THERE IS
THERE SOMETHING OUT THERE THAT
HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL THAT WE
MIGHT BE ABLE.
TO TELL I THINK YOU KNOW I I
DON'T MEAN TO BEAT A DEAD HORSE
IN THIS ONE BUT THAT THE WINDS
PROGRAMS AND SOUTHEAST ARE GREAT
EXAMPLE OF THIS WHERE.
THE KNOW THAT THE REFORMS THE
INSURANCE REFORMS WERE PAIRED
WITH BUILDING CODE AND LAND USE
REFORM.
THAT WAS AN ESSENTIAL PART OF
THE EQUATION.
AND THE INSURANCE REFORMS CREATE
STRONG INCENTIVES FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES TO TAKE LESS RISK AND
A BUILDING CODES AND THE LAND
USE REFORMS HELP --
TO AVOID THE CREATION OF NEW.
VALUE AT RISK [inaudible]
AND SO --
YOU KNOW IT'S THAT COMBINATION.
THAT ACTION THAT'S GONNA BE
IMPORTANT.
THAT CHALLENGE IT CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF OUR REAL ESTATE
MARKET WE HAVE FAR MORE VALUE AT
RISK DUE TO WILDFIRE THAN ANY
OTHER STATE.
IN THE COUNTRY.
THE DATA I'VE SEEN SUGGESTS THAT
YOU KNOW ORGAN WASHINGTON ARE
RIGHT BEHIND US BUT THEY'RE
THEY'RE VALUE RISK IS LOWER BY A
FACTOR OF FIVE AND SO.
WE'RE IN A SOMEWHAT UNIQUE
SITUATION --
AND WE HAVE TO WORK WE HAVE TO
LEARN FROM ANALOGOUS PROGRAMS
AND ALSO DO SOME.
CREATIVE THINKING
EXPERIMENTATION --
THE ONE OTHER PIECE TO THIS THAT
I WOULD SUGGEST IS THAT.
THE BEST APPROACH IS ONE THAT
CREATES PROCESS OF LEARNING.
AND RE EVALUATION AND ITERATION
RATHER THAN SPECIFYING ANSWER.
RIGHT SO.
IN THIS IS TRUE.
ON THE PRIVATE LANDOWNER SIDE
IT'S ALSO TRUE IN THE UTILITY
SPACES WE THINK ABOUT WILDFIRE
PLANNING FOR UTILITIES WHAT WE
WANT UTILITIES TO DO.
IS TO BE OPEN ABOUT WHERE THEIR
SYSTEM FOR PLANNING IS WORKING
AND WHERE IT IS NOT.
AND NOT TO FEEL PRESSURE TO SAY
EVERYTHING'S FINE.
ALL GOOD HERE SO THAT THEY CAN
ACHIEVE COST RECOVERY AND THAT'S
A REAL TENSION RIGHT IT'S
ATTENTION BECAUSE THE UTILITIES
ARE GOING TO WANT.
TO BE CERTIFIED AS COMPLIANT
WITH WHATEVER PLAN [inaudible]
APPROVED.
PART OF THAT PLANNING PROCESS
NEEDS TO BE SOME ADMISSION OF
WHERE THINGS NEED WORK.
SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE AND LEARN [inaudible]
SURE HOLD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANTED
--
TO SORT PICK UP IN THE AREA OF
THE INVERSE CONDEMNATION AND
MORE FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
OTHER STATES AND HOW.
IT APPLIES SIMILARLY TO
CALIFORNIA'S AND AND AND WHAT'S
DIFFERENT HISTORICALLY AND HOW
THEY GOT TO WHERE.
THEY'RE APPLYING.
OF THIS DOCTRINE IN THE SAME
WAY.
VERSUS HOW WE MAY BE DOING IT OR
WHAT THE SIMULATORS MAY BE.
SO OTHER THAN ALABAMA.
CALIFORNIA AS AS FAR AS OUR
RESEARCH HAS BEEN ABLE TO
DETERMINE IS THE ONLY STATE IN
THE COUNTRY WHERE INVERSE
CONDEMNATION HAS BEEN APPLIED TO
PRIVATE ENTITIES THAT HAVE THE
POWER OF EMINENT DOMAIN.
THAT BEING SAID IT IS WELL
ESTABLISHED LAW IN CALIFORNIA
THAT.
BECAUSE THESE PRIVATE ENTITIES
DO HAVE THE POWER OF EMINENT
DOMAIN.
THAT THEY SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO
SOME FORM.
BOB INVERSE CONDEMNATION
LIABILITY.
THE COURTS THOUGH IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE HAVE CREATED SOME NUANCE IN
THE DOCTRINE --
WHERE?
ESPECIALLY IN CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE THE LIABILITY MIGHT BE SO
CRUSHING LIKE THE RISKS CREATED
MIGHT BE SO DIFFICULT TO MANAGE.
THAT IT WOULD TO TURF PROVISION
OF THE PUBLIC BENEFIT.
RIGHT SO THERE'S A BALANCE THAT
HAS TO BE ACCOMPLISHED THERE
WHERE -- ON
THE ONE SIDE IS IS THE NEED TO
PROTECT INDIVIDUAL PROPERTY
OWNERS.
FROM PAYING HAVING BEING FORCED
TO PAY UNFAIRLY FOR THE
PROVISION OF SOME PUBLIC BENEFIT
BECAUSE THE HOUSE BURNS DOWN OR
ITS UNDERWATER BECAUSE A LEVEE
BREAKS -- ON
THE OTHER SIDE IS THE VERY
STRONG DESIRE OF THE STATE TO
SEE THAT THESE PUBLIC BENEFITS
ARE PROVIDED RIGHT AND WE'VE.
WE HAVE VERY STRONG PROTECTIONS
--
FOR ELECTRICITY CONSUMERS THAT
IN TERMS OF THE UTILITIES
OBLIGATION TO SERVE THAT WERE
REINFORCED DURING ELECTRICITY
CRISIS [inaudible]
AND AND SO UTILITIES ARE
OBLIGATED TO SERVE AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT --
THEY DO SO AT A PRICE THAT'S
AFFORDABLE FOR EVERYONE --
AND NOTS WHERE ANY OF THERE'S A
QUESTION AND IT'S ONE FOR THE A
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER --
WHETHER YOU KNOW WHETHER THE
RIGHT BALANCE IS BEING STRUCK.
AND I DON'T PRETEND TO KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THAT I THINK IT'S A
VERY POLITICALLY SENSITIVE
QUESTION DISABLED LEAST --
BUT IT THERE IS CERTAINLY
FLEXIBILITY UNDER CALIFORNIA
LAW.
IN OTHER STATES THESE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES ARE SUBJECT TO A
NEGLIGENCE STANDARD.
WHEN AND WILD FIRES OCCUR?
RIGHT SO THEY IF THEY ARE
NEGLIGENT IN MAINTENANCE OF
THEIR SYSTEMS AND A WILDFIRE
RESULTS [inaudible]
THEY'VE HAD.
IF THEY HAVE EXERCISED A
REASONABLE DUTY OF CARE.
THEY ARE NOT LIABLE --
AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND LOOK AT YOU KNOW
SORT OF WILD FIRES AND UTILITIES
WOULD YOU MOSTLY SEE IS THE
DISASTER RESPONSE ISSUES.
AND CONSIDERATION BY COMMISSIONS
OF HOW THEY STAND THE WOULD
POLLS UP AGAIN WHEN THEY'RE BEEN
BURNT TO THE GROUND.
NOT SO MUCH THE ISSUE OF HOW THE
UTILITIES WOULD PAY.
FOR THE DAMAGES THAT MIGHT ENSUE
FROM A DOWNED Y. [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
YES [inaudible]
PLEASE.
SO YOU ARE A LITTLE VAGUE YOU
SAID OTHER STATES OVER WE AN OUT
LIAR OR IS THERE OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE THE DEFINITION OF
VERNE INVERSE CON MISSION ARE
ARE USE INVERSE COMMISSION SAME
WAY EXTENDED CALIFORNIA DOES.
WHAT MANY STATES APPLIED THE
SAME LAW TO PUBLIC ENTITIES
RIGHT SORRY CLEAR OUT THAT --
MANY STATES APPLY INVERSE
CONDEMNATION TO A PUBLIC ENTITY
THAT --
TAKES PRIVATE PROPERTY EITHER
INTENTIONALLY THAT'S SENATE MAIN
OR UNINTENTIONALLY HOW BE
ENFORCED --
ONLY ALABAMA INSOFAR AS WE CAN
TELL HAS CASE LAW SUGGESTING
THAT INVERSE CONDEMNATION SHOULD
BE APPLIED TO PRIVATELY OWNED
FIRMS THAT HAVE BEEN GRANTED THE
POWER OF EMINENT DOMAIN.
SO THAT COULD BE YOU KNOW IT'S
IT'S NOT IT'S NETWORK INDUSTRIES
JESSA ALABAMA IN CALIFORNIA YES
AND I WOULD JUST ADD THAT IN
ALABAMA.
THE ALABAMA CASE IS MORE AKIN TO
THE EARLY INVERSE CONDEMNATION
CASES IN CALIFORNIA WHERE THE
LEVEL OF DAMAGES IS VERY MODEST.
IT IS NOT LIKE.
THE SITUATION WE FACE TODAY
WHERE THE LEVEL OF DAMAGES
SUPPOSES YOU KNOW KIND OF AN
ENTERPRISE LEVEL RISK TO THE
COMPANIES.
AND TO THAT PUBLIC BENEFIT THAT
FLOWS FROM THAT POLICE AWAY WE
USE IN CALIFORNIA IS UNUSUAL.
YEAH SO.
I DEFINITELY [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SIR.
I'LL DOT WHO REALLY PRETTY.
COMING TO THE CAPITAL --
TO INFORM US OF ALL THESE THINGS
AND ANSWERING OUR QUESTIONS.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME I TURN THE
MEETING OVER THE NEXT PANEL --
TO CHAIR HOLD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE ARE GOING TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE COVER ALL OF THESE
ISSUES THAT ARE IMPORTANT THAT
CERTAINLY WAS A PRESENTATION
THAT WAS --
TIMELY AND AND TOUCHED ON A LOT
OF IMPORTANT ISSUES.
THAT WE'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT
THE NEXUS WILL DO AS WELL.
OF THIS IS GOING TO ADDRESS
ENSURING A SAFE AND RELIABLE
ELECTRIC GRID.
AND I'D LIKE TO CALL THE PANEL
OF FORWARD WHO WILL BE
PARTICIPATING IN THIS PART OF
OUR HEARING TODAY.
MICHAEL PICKER PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION [inaudible]
ELIZAVETA --
SHINKO.
DIRECTOR SAFETY ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION
[inaudible]
TOM PORTER.
CHIEF SOUTHERN REGION CAL FIRE.
AND BRIAN DISGUSTING NO DIRECTOR
FIRE SCIENCE AND CLIMATE
ADAPTATION SAN DIEGO GAS AND
ELECTRIC.
WELCOME ALL OF YOU [inaudible]
MR.
THANK YOU AGAIN.
THESE ARE ALWAYS DIFFICULT
CONVERSATIONS AROUND SAFETY POEM
AND SO I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT I TAKE EVERYTHING WHAT'S
THERE WITH EXTREME GRAVITY THE
FACT THAT PEOPLE'S LIVES HAVE
BEEN LOST THAT.
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO BE AT STAKE PROPERTY DAMAGE
--
DAMAGE TO THE ENVIRONMENT FROM.
THE ACTIVITIES THAT WE OVERSEE.
ALWAYS KEEPS ME --
ON UP LATER TONIGHT.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT THAT FIRES
ARE NOT SOMETHING I THOUGHT I
WOULD DEAL WITH WHEN I CAME TO
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
BUT IT'S OBVIOUS THAT THEY ARE
BECOMING A BIGGER AND MORE
DRAMATIC ISSUE HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN IS ALREADY SET A RECORD
PACE FOR NEW WILDFIRES AND OTHER
CONDITIONS REMAIN PRIME FOR MORE
--
WE NOW APPEAR TO HAVE A NEVER
ENDING WILDFIRE SEASON IN
CALIFORNIA MUCH OF THE WEST.
DROUGHT DRY SOIL HIGH WINDS AND
OTHER EXTREME CLIMATE EVENTS
THINGS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN THE
METEOROLOGICAL RECORDS IN THE
PAST CONTINUE TO ENDANGER THE
STATE IN A SIGNIFICANT PORTION
THE CALIFORNIA'S CONTINUE TO BE
IN JEOPARDY.
SERVER DE TESTIFIED ABOUT --
AYE IN OTHER SETTINGS ON OUR
STRONG NEW RULES AND VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AND WE CONTINUE TO
WORK ON ON WILDFIRE PREVENTION
AND WE'VE --
RECENTLY --
PUT FORWARD VARIOUS --
CONSISTENT RULES ACROSS THE
STATE FOR DE ENERGIZING
DISTRIBUTE DISTRIBUTION LINES
BEFORE BEACH DURING WINDSTORMS.
AND DO ADDITIONAL WHERE I
REQUIRE THAT WHEN A FIRE OCCURS
UTILITIES RESPOND QUICKLY AND
RESPONSIBLY SONG --
THAT INCLUDES WATER AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS TO MAKE SURE
THAT SERVICES OF ACT.
AVAILABLE AND THAT THEIR
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN PLACE.
WE'RE ABOUT TO ADOPT THOSE
PARTICULAR MEASURES IN A
PROPOSED DECISION WHICH IS OUT
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND AND UNDER EXISTING LAW SO
WERE TASKED WITH REVIEWING
WILDFIRE PREVENTION PLAN
SUBMITTED BY THE UTILITIES WHICH
ARE --
DIRECTOR OF SAFETY IN
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION POLICE VEDA
MALASHENKO CAN SPEAK
[inaudible]
TO HI.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT --
EFFORT HAS BEEN TO WORK MUCH
MORE CLOSELY WITH OTHER STATE
SAFETY AGENCIES WHILE UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION WE ARE DEEMED A
INDEPENDENT AGENCY.
IT JUST DOESN'T WORK UNLESS WE
WORK WITH THE OTHER AGENCIES WHO
ARE ALSO WORKING IN THE SAME
FIELDS THAT WE ARE.
SO WHILE WE HAVE AGREEMENTS --
DO THE DIRECTOR MALASHENKO IS
LEADERSHIP OF WITH OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND WORKOUT
WITH CAL FIRE. ONE OF THE
PRIMARY FOCUSES OF OUR WORK WITH
CAL FIRE HAS BEEN THE EFFORT TO
TARGET STRINGENT TREE IN
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
WHICH REQUIRED TRANSFORMING
EARLIER STATE FIRE MAPS FROM A
GENERAL MODELING GENERAL FIRE
HAZARDS TO REAL STATE OF THE
MARK ART MODEL THAT FOCUSES ON
IGNITION RISK DUE TO AND UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE IN DROUGHT.
IN EXTREME FIRE WIND EVENTS.
BUT BEYOND THAT WE THINK THAT
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
DEVELOP A SINGLE COMPREHENSIVE
DATABASE OF THE FOUR POINT TWO
MILLION --
WOODEN POLES TO CARRY CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WHO OWNS THEM
THEY'RE UPDATED CONDITIONS
WHAT'S ATTACHED THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT PARTICULARLY IN
WINDSTORMS IS --
HAS EACH PIECE OF HAITIANS OR
ELECTRIC INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
ATTACHED TO PULL ACTS LIKE A
SEAL.
YOU CAN MAKE THEM SUSCEPTIBLE TO
OVERTOPPING A BREAKAGE.
AND HOW THAT LOADING CAN --
CAN AFFECT THE POTENTIAL FOR
FAILURES IN PUBLIC SAFETY SO.
WERE ALSO REFINING NEW RULES FOR
ENFORCEMENT WHICH BEEN LACKING
WITH TELECOM EQUIPMENT ISN'T DUH
WELL ATTACHED FOR HASN'T BEEN --
REPLACED IN A TIMELY FASHION.
WHEN HE WENT ELECTRIC UTILITY
REPLACES A POLL WE I RECENTLY
TOURED A VARIETY OF --
OF SETTINGS IN --
IN SANTA CLARA THIS IS A FOLLOW
ON TO MY VISITS TO TO OTHER FIRE
SITES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND FREQUENTLY WHAT WE SEE IS
THAT THE ELECTRIC UTILITY
WORKPLACE THE PAUL.
A TELECOMMUNICATIONS EQUIPMENT
IS JUST SORT OF DANGLING THERE
OR IS ATTACHED WITH ROPES AND
THEY DON'T RISK.
ON THAT'S A HACER.
WHAT I DO NEED TO POINT OUT I
THINK IT'S BEEN STATED IN SOME
RESPECTS?
THAT MORE AND MORE PEOPLE ARE
MOVING INTO AREAS OF ELEVATED
AND SEVERE FIRE RISK WHAT WE
CALL THOUGH WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE.
SO IN THE NORTH PART OF STATE
THAT'S RECALL WE'VE ARE ON THIS
YEAR AND AND SISKIYOU IN FORCE
BUTTON SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S RECALL WE CHAPARRAL.
AND HERE IN THE CENTRAL PART OF
THE STATE HITS OAK WOODLAND ALL
OF THESE DIFFERENT --
PHONE FIRE SETTINGS HAVE
DIFFERENT CHARACTERISTICS AND
PRESENT DIFFERENT KINDS OF
CHALLENGES.
WE'RE NOT FIRE SCIENTISTS WERE
NOT BY BOTANISTS WERE ECONOMIC
REGULATORS LEESER HARD THINGS
FOR US TO UNDERSTAND.
AND THAT'S WHY WE PRIZED ARE
GROWING RELATIONSHIP WITH CAL
FIRE BECAUSE OF THEIR FIRE THEIR
SCIENTISTS.
AND BECAUSE OF THEIR KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT FIRE BEHAVIOR. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE LEARNED FROM
WORKING WITH THEM IS THAT THE
SIZE OF THE FIRE RISK AREAS
GROWN PRETTY DRAMATICALLY THIS
PREVIOUS FIREMEN UP WHICH WE
CALLED THE INTERIM FIRE MAPS
FIRE THREAT MATCH COVERED ABOUT
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND SQUARE
MILES.
THE NEW MAP MORE THAN DOUBLES
THAT TO SEVENTY THOUSAND SQUARE
MILES.
THAT'S 44% CALIFORNIA'S LANMAN
--
THE NEW MAP ALSO INCLUDES
CALIFORNIA TREE MORTALITY HIGH
HAZARD ZONES WHICH ENCOMPASS
ABOUT NINE MILLION ACRES AND
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
MILLION TREES WITH DIED TO
DROUGHT AND BARK BEETLES.
SO I THINK THIS IS THAT'S
PRINCIPALLY IN THE SIERRA
FORESTS IN THE SISKIYOU USE BUT
WE ALSO HAVE PROBLEMS IN TERMS
OF ADVANCING ON DIE TEMPERATURES
CLIMATE CHANGE AFFECTING OTHER
TREE POPULATIONS.
SO WHEN PEOPLE MOVE FURTHER OUT
FROM DENSE URBAN CONCENTRATIONS
THEIR NEEDS AND THEIR DEMAND FOR
ELECTRICITY AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE [inaudible]
CHENEY'S.
WE DON'T TELL THEM TO MOVE THEIR
WE TELL THE UTILITIES THE YOU
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO SERVE.
YOU HAVE TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
THAT INFEST --
SO THAT.
PUTS MORE --
STRAIN ON OUR RESOURCES THE FIRE
AGENCIES AND AND AND YOU TOLD
THE SERVICE PROVIDERS WE
CURRENTLY REQUIRE.
UTILITIES TO CONNECT VIRTUALLY
EVERY HOME EVERY BUILDING.
IN EVERY BUSINESS IN THESE
GROWING FIRE RISK AREAS THERE'S
ABOUT OF ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
HOUSING UNITS.
AND WHO LIVE WITH THAT IN WITHIN
THIS FIRE --
THREATS OWNS WE ESTIMATE THAT
THERE'S ABOUT A MILLION WOODEN
POLES AND TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
MILES OF OVERHEAD ELECTRIC
DISTRIBUTION LINES CROSSING
THROUGH.
SPANNING FIRE HAZARD ZONES JUST
TO SERVE THESE GROWING
POPULATIONS.
ARE WE NEED REAL STRONG CENTRAL
MANAGEMENT OF THE GRID FOR
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT MORE
DETAILED WILDFIRE MAPS --
WE NEED TO CONTINUE VARGAS AN
EXISTING WILD FIRE MITIGATION
PLANS INCLUDING ENSURING
UTILITIES ARE IMPLEMENTING THE
PLANTS UPDATING THE PLANTS
ACTUALLY ADDRESSING.
THE SAFETY CULTURES THAT THE
UTILITIES I BELIEVE THAT --
DOCTOR OR SPOKE TO THAT.
THIS IS A CHALLENGE FOR US WE
STARTED TO ACTUALLY AUDIT TOP TO
BOTTOM HOME A ONE UTILITY TO
BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND HOW IS IT.
THAT TOP TO BOTTOM EVERYBODY IS
CONSCIOUS AND ACTIVE ON THESE
ISSUES WHAT IS THE BOARD.
TO WHEN THEY HEAR ABOUT AN
INCIDENT HOW DO THEY REACT WHAT
QUESTIONS DO THEY ASK WHAT TAX
INTO THEY TAKE WHO DO THEY HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE --
I THINK THAT WE ALSO WERE
INTERESTED IN IN IN OTHER
AGENCIES ESTABLISHING --
BEST PRACTICE MODELS FOR ZONING
AND BUILDING CODES.
ARE AND DUH I ALSO MENTION INTO
CONCURRENCE IN THE CPUC WILDFIRE
DECISION WE HAVE --
TO REFINE THE LEGAL FRAME.
TAKE COUNT ALL THESE CHANGES.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT MANAGING AN
OPERA IN THE GRID ITSELF CAN'T
BE PARCELED OUT EASILY.
JUST LIKE THE INTERSTATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM THE WIRES AND POLES OF
THE GRID HAVE TO HAVE SOME
CONSISTENT MANAGEMENT ACROSS
GEOGRAPHY IN ORDER TO OPERATE
EFFECTIVELY.
VOLTAGES HAVE TO MATCH UP.
WHERE YOU HAVE A SITUATION LOS
ANGELES IT LAUP IT HAS DIFFERENT
VOLTAGES THAN THE REST OF THE
STATE'S GRITS MAKES IT VERY HARD
TO SHARE RESOURCES AND AND ANTI
TIMES?
OPERATORS HAVE TO HAVE VERY
CLOSE COMMUNICATION ESSENTIALLY
TO THE MILLISECOND.
THE ARCHITECTURE THE GRID HAS TO
BE CAREFULLY DESIGNED SO THE
POWER GOES WHERE IT'S SUPPOSED
TO GO -- AND
WITH THE FORCE IT'S WELL WITHIN
THE DESIGNED LIMITS OF THE
SYSTEM.
SO HERE THE YOU THE ROLE THE
UTILITY IS NOT BY CONTRACT FROM
INDEPENDENT GENERATORS TO AND
THEN TO TO WE'LL THAT
ELECTRICITY TO CUSTOMERS.
BUT IS TO PROVIDE A RELIABLE AND
SAFE DELIVERY SERVICE FROM OF
VERY COMPLEX MACHINE.
IT LOOKS.
PEOPLE SEE PART WIRES AND POLES
BUT IT'S NOT IT'S VERY DYNAMIC
HOW IT OPERATES --
WIRES AMPLE --
PULLS IN UTILITY EQUIPMENT TO
LOOK DELINEATE A VERY IMPORTANT
THAT.
I HAVE TO STRESS THE FACT THAT
THE NETWORK IS NOT EASY TO TO
DIVIDE.
COMPLEX IN ITS A LARGE
UNDERTAKING THAT PROVIDES AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF VALUE TO
CUSTOMERS NOT JUST --
ELECTRICITY BUT ALSO
TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
SO WHAT I HAVE TO I CAN'T.
GO ARE FEW FALSE ASSURANCES LIKE
IN A WAY I THINK THAT THAT'S NOT
RIGHT.
PEOPLE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT
--
IT WHILE IT'S CHIU OUR NEW FAR
ROLES ARE THE TOUGHEST IN THE
COUNTRY.
WILL ALSO BE EXPENSIVE TO
IMPLEMENT WE PROBABLY COULD HAVE
GONE FURTHER BUT OUR RATE PAIR
ADVOCATES REMINDED US.
THAT THERE'S A COST THE SAFETY
THEY OPPOSED THE NEW FIRE AND
VEGETATION MAN [inaudible]
PROGRAMS.
THERE WE NEED TO CONSTANTLY
EVALUATE THIS COST TO MAKE SURE
THE RATES ARE ARE JUST AND
REASONABLE --
BUT I HAVE TO SAY THAT JUST
BECAUSE WE HAVE A PLAN
[inaudible]
DOESN'T REALLY.
ALLOW THE UTILITIES ARE OFF THE
HOOK WE CAN'T JUST BECAUSE WE
APPROVE A PLAN IT'S NOT
SUFFICIENT AND THE ULTIMATELY
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO OPERATE
THEIRS THEIR SYSTEMS --
SAFELY AND BASED ON ON THE
STANDARDS.
SO WE GET BETTER SETTING OF
WE'VE DONE THAT WE'VE ADOPTED TO
CHANGING AND ON EXPECTED
CONDITIONS THE NEUFELD
VEGETATION MAPPING DUE IN PART
WHAT -- WHAT
THE --
PROFESSOR WORSE AT THE ARE GOING
TO REALLY.
REQUIRE CUTTING BACK --
OF VEGETATION IN CERTAIN PARTS
OF THE STATE.
NOT EVERYWHERE THE PLACES THAT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE IDENTIFIED
[inaudible]
MY SUSPICION.
IS THAT WITH THE ADVANCING TEMAS
TEMPERATURE ONGOING DROUGHTS.
TEEN YOU'D DUH MOVEMENT OF
POPULATION STE A FIRE HAZARD
AREAS WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO
ADAPT THOSE MAPS DURING CREDIBLY
GRANULAR.
BUT I THINK THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO TO FOLLOW POPULATION
MOVEMENTS AND DROUGHT AND THE
FUEL AND AND CONTINUE TO ADAPT
THEM -- SO I
I JUST I WISH I COULD SAY THAT
WE HAVE A PERFECT SYSTEM AND
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF OF MAKING
SURE THAT IT'S APPLIED I THINK
WE ARE CONSTANTLY.
GOING TO BE ADVANCING.
AND IMPROVING ON PAST PRACTICES
--
I THINK THAT --
THAT IT MAY BE THAT PERFECT
SAFETY AND THE AIR UP WHERE WERE
RD SEEING MORE FIRES MORE MORE
--
FEROCIOUS STORM FIRE START MORE
FEROCIOUS WINDS [inaudible]
DRIER SOILS.
AND DIE AND ALMOST NO HUMIDITY
DURING WIND EVENTS ALL
UNPRECEDENTED NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA --
SAFETY JUST MADE NOT BE PERFECT.
AND SO PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW THAT
BECAUSE THEY NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY ARE AT RISK NO MATTER
HOW HARD WE WORK.
AS THE GOVERNOR SAID IN HIS
STATE OF THE STATE WE CAN'T
FIGHT NATURE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO LEARN HOW. TO GET ALONG WITH
HER.
SO I THINK THAT MAY ACTUALLY IS
THE IS THE THE GOOD DOCTOR SAID
DUH MEAN RETHINKING WHERE AND
HOW DEVELOPMENT HAPPENS.
AND AND BUILDING STANDARDS --
IF IT CONTINUES TO TO EXPAND IN
THE URBAN WILDLAND IN.
FOR INTERFACING CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT FOUR MILLION PEOPLE WERE
LIVING IN THOSE FIRE HAZARD
AREAS EXPECTED TO GROW TO FIVE
MILLION.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO BE
CHALLENGED WHO WORK HARD WILL DO
OUR BEST.
BUT I WANT EVERYBODY TO
UNDERSTAND THAT I DON'T THINK
WE'RE GOING TO DELIVER
PERFECTION THEIR WILL BE A
INCREMENTAL RISK SO LONG AS WE
CONTINUE TO INTERMINGLE BAR
URBAN DEVELOPMENT WITH A
WILDLAND.
INTERFACE.
SO I THINK COOLEY SAVANNAH MAY
HAVE SAID SOME THINGS TO ADD TO
MY COMMENTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO US SPEAK HERE
TODAY.
I LEAD THE SAFETY AND
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM AT THE CPUC
WHICH INCLUDES OVERSIGHT OF
UTILITY AND RAIL INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE OVERALL GROUP GOOD IS
COMPRISED OF ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY STAFF ABOUT THIRTY
EIGHT OF THEM ARE IN THE
ELECTRIC AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SAFETY PROGRAM.
OF THIS GROUP LEAD THOUGH
PERFORMS AUDITS AND INCIDENT
INVESTIGATIONS.
AS WELL AS SUPPORTS THE
COMMISSION IN DEVELOPMENTS OF
ELECTRIC AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SAFETY POLICY.
OF THE SIZE OVER A GROUP --
IN THE LECTURE EXCEEDS TWO MORE
THAN DOUBLED IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WE HAD ABOUT
FIFTEEN ENGINEERS WHO COVERED
ALL OF ELECTRIC AND
TELECOMMUNICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE.
OF FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE CBC RECOGNIZE THAT I OWE
THIS WAS INSUFFICIENT --
TO TACKLE ALL OF THE ISSUES
[inaudible] FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES INCLUDING ELSE THREE
PEOPLE TO SPECIALIZE AND WILD
FIRE.
WELL PREVENTION.
AND AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN WERE
BUSY HIRING AND TRAINING HAVE
THIS ADDITIONAL STAFF.
THEY WOULD JUST ABOUTS ONBOARD
WHEN THE FIRES OF STARTED
LAST FALL.
ANOTHER DEVELOPMENT IN TWENTY
SEVEN SEEM --
WAS THE ESTABLISHMENT OF CLOSE
PARTNERSHIP WITH CAL FIRE.
O. WHICH WAS --
MEMORIALIZE THROUGH A MEMORANDUM
OF UNDERSTANDING THAT WE SIGNED
LAST YEAR.
PRESIDENT PICKER MENTIONED SOME
AREAS SO WE ARE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY TOGETHER --
IN THE DISH AND A WE HAVE BE IN
THIS YEAR DEVELOPING DETAILED
REQUIREMENTS FOR UTILITIES. FOR
WELFARE MITIGATION PLANS --
TO GO BEYOND WHAT UTILITIES
CURRENTLY SUBMIT AS PART OF
THEIR EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE FILINGS.
OF TODAY THE COMMISSION HAS BEEN
PROACTIVE IN ADOPTING THE MOST
AGGRESSIVE ELECTRIC STANDARDS
ILL IN THE NATION MOST OF THE
STATE'S HEALTH PROGRAMS THAT
FOCUS PRO MILLER PRIMARILY ON
RELIABILITY RATHER THAN SAFETY.
OF MOST OF THE STATES IN THE U.
S. FULL SOMETHING THAT'S CALLED
THE NATIONAL ELECTRIC SAFETY
CODE.
WHICH IS A STANDARD THAT'S
DEVELOPED BY THE ELECTRIC AT ALL
IN THE STREET.
A THE HOUSES ON THE VEGETATION
MANAGER.
CLEARANCE IS NOT HARD
REQUIREMENTS --
CALIFORNIANS WERE AGAIN ARE THE
ONLY STATES THAT HOW HARD
REQUIREMENTS SO ON THE
DISTRIBUTION ALICE THE STUMP OF
EDUCATION CLEARANCE AT ALL --
HOME.
WILL SOMEHOW O. STRICTER O.
POLLUTING OUR CALCULATIONS
STANDARDS AT SOME OF THE
EXAMPLES OF WHERE THE CALIFORNIA
REGULATIONS EXCEED.
ABOUT THE NATIONAL ELECTRIC
SAFETY CODES [inaudible] OH THE
O. COMMISSION ALSO ADOPTED THE
FIRE HEALTH THREAT MOPS THERE'S
NOTHING LIKE THAT AND ANYWHERE
ELSE IN THE COUNTRY FOR WILDFIRE
PREVENTION.
OF THESE NEW REGULATIONS REQUIRE
UTILITIES TO MAINTAIN THAT EVEN
STRICTER VEGETATION --
CLEARANCE STANDARDS AND I'LL
MANDATE UTILITIES TO PRIORITIZE
CORRECTIONS OF SAFETY HAZARDS
BASED IN PART ON WHETHER THE
SAFETY HAZARD IS LOCATED AND HI
FI A THREAT.
DISTRICT --
ALSO THE NEW REGULATIONS
INTRODUCED NEW MINIMUM PATROL
AND DETAILED INSPECTION CYCLES
.
FOR OVERHEAD COMMUNICATION LINES
WHICH IS REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE OF THE EXPANDING NUMBER
OF COMMUNICATION FACILITIES
WHICH ARE OFTEN OH COAL LOW
KEYED AND WITH ELECTRIC
FACILITIES ON UTILITY POLES --
AND THIS YEAR OH MY GROUP ALSO
STARTED USING THE FIRE THREAT
MAP TO FOCUS AND PRIORITIZE OUR
AUDITS AND INSPECTIONS OF
ELECTRIC AND TELECOMMUNICATION
[inaudible]
INFRASTRUCTURE --
SINCE SO O. THE ADOPTION OF THE
FIRE THREAT MAPS THE PCS THAT
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH CAL FIRE
ON THE EXPANDING THE SUFFERED BY
DEVELOPING --
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF WIND
CONDITIONS O. THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE HOPE A REPORT THAT
IS --
SCHEDULED TO COME OUT O. LEADER
THIS YEAR WHOM.
ON OUT HOWTO BUILD UPON THE
FIGHT THRUPP MAPS --
WITH --
BETTER UNDERSTANDING ALL OF WIND
CONDITIONS WHICH IS REALLY A
CRITICAL OF A WOMAN'S WHEN WE
ARE CONSIDERING  THE OVER
WILL --
THREAT OF WILDFIRES [inaudible]
HOME.
IN JULY OF THE COMMISSION ALSO
ADOPTED A POLICY FOR UTILITIES
TO FOLLOW ONE PROACTIVE LEADS
THE ENERGIZING.
ELECTRIC LINES AS A MEASURE OF
LAST RESORT TO PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY.
OTHER COMMISSION REQUIRE
UTILITIES TO MEET WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THEY MAY BE
IMPACTED.
NOBLE A FUTURE DO YOU KNOW JUST
A CERTAIN EVENTS WELL BEFORE
PUTTING THESE PRACTICES IN THE
FACT -- IN
ANY PARTICULAR AREA AND TO
PROVIDE A CUSTOMER NOTIFICATIONS
PRIOR -- TO
IDEA DE ENERGIZING LINES OF
OPERATIONALLY FEASIBLE --
WITHIN NINETY DAYS UTILITIES ARE
A AND FOR IN WORKSHOPS O. WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM STATE
AGENCIES.
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS O. LOCAL
AGENCIES AND REPRESENTATIVES
FROM LOCAL COMMUNITIES THAT MAY
BE AFFECTED BY ALL THESE EVENTS.
THE PURPOSE OF THE WORKSHOPS IS
TO EXPLAIN AND RECEIVE FEEDBACK
ON THE UTILITIES --
DE IMAGES NATION POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES.
THE YEAR UTILITIES ARE ALSO NOW
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT REPORTS TO
THE CPC STAFF UP TO DE
ENERGIZING OUTLINES.
IN THE CBC WILL BE MONITORING
THESE EVENTS CLOSELY OUT TO SEE
HOW THIS --
PROGRAM IS SO PUT INTO EFFECT.
AS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT HOW THESE
PRACTICES ARE WORKING IN MAY BE
EL.
AND THE COMMISSION MAY CONSIDER
ADOPTING ADDITIONAL OF
REQUIREMENTS FOR UTILITIES.
WELL LAST TIME SO WHEN THEY
APPEAR BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE I
TALKED ABOUT THE FIRE IGNITION
DATA THAT THE UTILITIES ARE
REQUIRED TO REPORT ON THE ANNUAL
BASIS AB TO THE PC.
EL WOULD BE RECEIVING THIS DATA
SINCE --
TWENTY FIFTY IN.
AND ALL WE HAVE A TOTAL OF TO
HUNT A TWO THOUSAND IGNITIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN REPORTED OWE
IT TO THE COMMISSION. FOR TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE UTILITIES OF
REPORTED A COMBINED SIX HUNDRED
AND TWENTY NINE OH INCIDENTS
WHERE --
THEY HAVE REASON TO BELIEVE THAT
THEIR FACILITIES WERE INVOLVED
IN THE LIGHTING A FIRE.
OWE THE MAJORITY OF THESE ARE
MINOR.
FOR HELP BUT DOES THE TO GIVES A
SUPPORT INSIGHT AS TO WHAT'S --
DRIVES SO IGNITIONS.
AND IT CONSISTENTLY SHOWS THAT
THE NUMBER ONE CAUSE IS SO
VEGETATION O. FALLING INTO
UTILITY OF LINES.
SO THESE ARE SITUATIONS WHERE
OWE THE UTILITY FACILITIES ARE
NOT FEELING AS IN THE NATIONAL
STEP IT'S ACTUALLY JUST
VEGETATION THAT'S COMING AND
CONTACTS --
WITH THE LINES SO ABOUT A
QUARTER OF WHO AND HOME.
IGNITIONS ARE ATTRIBUTED SO TO
OF VEGETATION CONTACT OH IN
VARIOUS EARL SOMEWHERE Y.
TERRITORY WITH THE YOU ARE IN
THE NORTH OR THE SOUTH BOY
OVERALL OUT THAT TREND IS --
CONSISTENCE AND L. PART OF THE
CHALLENGE WHEN WE'RE LOOKING
ANTS OF EDUCATION MANAGEMENT
WHEN IT COMES --
TO ELECTRIC LINES FACILITIES AND
AGGRESSIONS IS BY --
ON THE WINDS OF FIFTEEN FIFTY
FIVE MILES PER HOUR YOU HOPE
HOLDS.
TREES AND BRANCHES OUT THAT
FAIL.
O. HOME SO THAT THAT WAS SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BUDGET SEE
FROM THE OUTSIDE OVER UTILITY
CLEARANCE REQUIREMENTS.
ELM AND THAT'S ALSO GOES BEYOND
A JUST DEAD AND DISEASED TREES
THAT YOU'RE IDENTIFYING HOW
POTENTIALLY DURING PATROLS.
OMA SO.
NOW THAT JUST TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF THE SCOPE OF THE
CHALLENGE OH WOULD THAT WOULD
THAT DATE AND WHY WE SEEING.
HOME I THINK SUCH HIGH WELL
NUMBERS OF OF THE JUST THIESSEN
RELATED ADMISSIONS --
THE SECOND BILL LEADING BECAUSE
OVER CONDITIONS ACCORDING TO THE
STATE THAT IS SO WIRES DOWN.
HOME SO THAT'S THE CONDUCTORS
ARE COMING DOWN O. FROM THE
POLLS WERE FAILING L. AT THE
SPLICE.
HOME THAT ACCOUNTS  FOR WELL
IT'S ABOUT TWENTY PERCENT'S HOME
OF ALL OF THE IGNITIONS REPORTED
BY THE UTILITIES --
THE YOU KNOW THE PIECE IS STAFF
FOCUSED ON AND IDENTIFYING BEST
PRACTICES AND SOLUTIONS TO
UTILITY THE AFIRE IGNITIONS AND
WELFARE PREVENTION [inaudible]
WELL.
I GROUP THESE POLICIES AND THREE
EL AREAS OF FIRES NEEDS SORT OF
THREE THINGS TO SPREAD SO.
NEED FUEL  AND THAT MISSION
SOURCE AND SPECIFIC WEATHER
CONDITIONS ALSO FROM A POLICY
PERSPECTIVE WE CAN LOOK AT
THINGS TO DO WITH THE SO FUEL
REDUCTION.
SO IT'S ANYTHING FROM UTILITY
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
BUT ALSO GOING BEYOND THAT IN
FIRE WAS WILLIAM FORESTS AND
MANAGING THE WILDLAND.
URBAN INTERFACE OF THE SECOND
SET OF POLICIES AROUND SO YOU
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURES SOURCE
OF IGNITION SO THAT'S WHEN YOU
CAN LOOK AT HOME.
INFRASTRUCTURE HARDENING.
HOME SURGES GOING AFTER THE SORT
OF THE CORE THAT THE FIRST
PROBLEM ELM.
ALL OF WIRES DOWN OWE YOU CAN DO
THINGS TO STRENGTHEN  A
CONDUCTORES AND INCREASE WAITED
WHAT EXPANSIVE THAT CAN IMPROVE
THE SAFETY OWN.
FACTORED WAY THOUGH ENSURING
THAT WIRES DO HOME BLOW INTO
EACH OTHER FOR EXAMPLE WHEN AND
HOW YOU HAVE HIGH WIND
CONDITIONS.
SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
EXAMPLES AROUND POLICIES ON AND
IGNITION PREVENTION HOME.
AND THEN THIRDLY IS THE WEATHER
AND THINGS THAT WE CAN DO --
TO BUILD A BETTER SEAT.
AND SEE GRANULAR CONDITIONS AT
THE POINTS WHERE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL BECAUSE
WHEN WE FACING SUCH YOU YOU
LARGE SCALE CHALLENGE.
THAT WE HOW MILLIONS OF POLLS
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF LINES
OF CONDUCTORS OWE MORE THAN
44% OF LAND MASS IN HI FI OF
THREATS [inaudible]
HOME AREAS.
HOME WE HAVE TO GET A LOT MORE
GRANULAR AND IN TERMS OF OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE NO WE SEE
THAT WE HAVE --
RISKS AND WHEN ANNA AND GET
SURGICAL AND AND OUR ABILITY TO
RESPOND --
SO THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF THE
CAPABILITIES THAT WE CAN BE
BUILDING A HOME IN THE SORT OF
WEATHER  RELIEF DID HEALTH
POLICIES --
SO SO.
WELL IT WAS STAFF AT THE
COMMISSION --
OR FOCUSED ON CONDUCTING AUDITS
AND INSPECTIONS OF THE
FACILITIES.
ARE CONDUCTING INVESTIGATIONS
THEM INTO UTILITY INCIDENTS
INCLUDING OUT THE FIRES --
AND WORLD SO --
SUPPORTING HIM.
THE POLICY DEVELOPMENTS AND
LOOKING FOR A HOME BEST
PRACTICES TO PUT INTO PLACE TO
PREVENT --
FIRES FROM HAPPENING.
IN THE FUTURE EL THIS IS A TOP
PRIORITY HOLE FOR THE CPC.
A GOAL IS TO MAKE A TANGIBLE A
NOTICEABLE DIFFERENCE IN THE
AREAS THAT ARE MOST AT RISK OF
WILDFIRES --
AND EL.
YEAH.
BUT THIS IS GOES BEYOND THE PC
WILL HAVE A REALLY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP  WAS CAL FIRED
THAT'S BE IN THE ESSENTIAL.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE QUIRKS
PARTIES WILD FIRES HOME AND FIRE
FIGHTING.
ELSE WE RELY ON THE EXPERTISE OF
CALIFORNIA HOME.
WELL AS WE GROW I KEEP ABILITIES
IN THIS AREA.
HOW AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL?
OWN ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
WILL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER FLAYED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BURGER ALL THE PRISONERS IN THEM
[inaudible]
OKAY --
THANK YOU OF CHAIRMAN HOLDEN AND
AND DODD FOR HOLDING THIS AND
MEMBERS.
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR HEARING US
--
MY NAME'S TOM PORTER I AM THE A
REGION SHE FOR CAL FIRE AND A
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL FORESTER
--
AND I CAN'T THANK YOU ENOUGH --
FOR ALL THE COMMENTS YOU MADE
PREVIOUSLY --
RELATED --
TO THE THANK YOUS TO OUR
DEPARTMENT FOR RESPONSE BUT ALSO
--
MY CONDOLENCES I'D BEEN WITH
MANY OF YOU ON THE GROUND --
AT YOUR DISTRICTS [inaudible]
HAD --
MEMBERS OF YOUR DISTRICT THAT
THAT -- ARE
NO LONGER WITH US AND LOTS OF
PROPERTY LOSS AND DAMAGED.
AND I CONDOLENCES FROM MYSELF
AND AND ALL OF OUR DEPARTMENT --
FOR THAT --
THIS YEAR AS WAS REFERENCED
ALREADY IS --
TURNING OUT TO BE --
MORE ACTIVE EVEN THAN LAST YEAR
AT THIS POINT IN TIME --
WE HAVE MORE FIRES MORE ACRES
BURNED THUS FAR THAN WE DID IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHICH WAS
AS YOU KNOW A RECORD YEAR FOR US
--
AND THAT WE'RE ON TRACK --
TO AT LEAST BREAK THOSE RECORDS
AND WE WILL HOPE NOT TO BREAK
OTHER RECORDS --
THE RIGHT NOW WE'RE ENGAGED AND
EIGHT EXTENDED ATTACK --
MULTIPLE DAY FIRES ACROSS THE
STATE.
A WE HAVE FIREFIGHTERS --
ON ON THE TWO BIGGEST FIRES
FIRES -- THE
WITH THE ONE THE CAR FIRE UP IN
SHASTA COUNTY WHICH IS GROWING
--
QUITE A BIT TODAY NUMBER IT
LAUNCHING --
INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TEAM PEAK --
AND THEN THE FERGUSON FIRE --
THE FERGUSON FIRED THIS MORNING
WAS THE APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
NINE THOUSAND ACRES AND 25%
CONTAINED --
ONE OF THE THE THINGS THAT THE
FERGUSON FIRE --
HAS ETCHED INTO OUR MEMORY IS
THAT.
THAT WE ARE NOT INVINCIBLE AS
FIRE FIGHTERS AND THE
FIREFIGHTING COMMUNITY EITHER --
WE LOST ONE OF OUR HEAVY
EQUIPMENT OPERATORS ON THAT FIRE
--
BRADEN BARNEY --
IT WAS VERY SAD DAY --
WE LAID HIM TO REST ON MONDAY.
AND IT BROUGHT BACK --
DIFFICULT MEMORIES FROM THE
THOMAS FIRE IN KOREA IVERSON --
WHO ALSO LOST HIS LIFE
[inaudible]
IT'S NOT INTERESTING TO NOTE BUT
THANKFUL THAT THE LAST
FIREFIGHTERS TO LOOK --
DIE IN THE LINE OF DUTY WAS --
CHRISTOPHER DOUGLAS IN RIVERSIDE
--
SENATOR STONE I KNOW YOU
REMEMBER THAT WELL.
AND AND IT'S I AM I I HAD TO
MENTION THOSE NAMES --
WE WE ARE UNFORTUNATELY STARTING
TO LOSE FIRES AT A HIGH.
FIREFIGHTERS AT A HIGHER RATE.
AS WELL WITH THESE LARGE AND
DAMAGING FIRES.
SO.
WHAT'S GOING ON WE'VE WE HAVE
CLIMATE CHANGE AS AND INDUCING
FACTOR -- TO
WHAT WE'VE IT DUBBED THE NEW.
THE NEW NORMAL IS NO LONGER THE
NOR NEW NORMAL IT IS THE NORMAL
AND I THINK --
THAT'S BEEN MENTIONED --
FROM FROM YOUR DYESS --
WE WE ARE SEEING --
A CONFLUENCE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
CONDITIONS IGNITION SOURCES AND
AND VEGETATIVE FUELS THAT ARE IN
[inaudible]
DESICCATED --
STATES [inaudible]
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING IS THAT IS
MAKING FOR A VERY DIFFICULT A
CONDITION FOR ALL OF US IN OUR
WILD FIRE SETTING.
IT IF THOSE THREE FACTORS A
COMBINED --
TO ELEVATE THE WILDFIRE RISK TO
LIFE AND PROPERTY WHICH WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY.
IN MY THIRTY YEARS AS A AS A
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL FORESTER
I I HAVE NEVER SEEN SUCH A
VOLATILE CONDITIONS ACROSS THE
SKATERS WE'VE HAD.
I WAS IN SAN DIEGO DURING THE OF
THE BEETLE KILL EPISODES THAT WE
HAD IN THE TOO EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS.
AND TO SEE THE STATE OF OUR
FOREST IN THE SIERRAS AND OTHER
PARTS THE STATE IT'S MADE MY MY
STOMACH SICK JUST TO SEE.
SO GALPHARM AIR IS IS
RESPONSIBLE --
FOR REDUCING RISK AND AND
INCREASING RESILIENCE OF OUR
WATERSHEDS AND FORESTED AREAS --
THROUGH --
PROFESSIONAL AND EFFECTIVE
WILDFIRE RESPONSE PROACTIVE AND
FIRE PREVENTION ACTIVITIES AND
FOUR STRAIGHT FORESTRY
REGULATION.
I THINK YOU ALL KNOW THAT --
QUITE WELL --
THE AND THANKS AGAIN TO ALL OF
YOU -- AND
THE GOVERNOR FOR THE AND THE A
BOLD INVESTMENTS THAT YOU HAVE
MADE.
AND OF FOREST HEALTH INITIATIVES
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS --
THEY ARE UNPRECEDENTED AND VERY
WELL NOTICED --
THOSE THOSE ACTION IN PLACE ON
THE ON THE GROUND IN THE FORM OF
GRANTS.
THAT -- WILL
BE AVAILABLE WILL CONTINUE TO BE
AVAILABLE BUT HAVE BEEN
AVAILABLE TO THE TUNE OF TWO
MILLION OR TWO TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS --
AT LAST FISCAL YEAR AND ON AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED AND SIXTY
MILLION --
IN THE CURRENT BUDGET GOING
FORWARD --
ALL OF YOUR DISTRICTS WILL HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY --
TO GET THOSE SOME OF THOSE
FUNDS.
SO FOR DE WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
S TRYING.
TO PROVIDE FOR RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES AND THE REASON I'M
HERE TODAY --
ALONG WITH MY UTILITY COMMISSION
--
MEMBERS COLLEAGUES HERE
[inaudible]
IS
TO ENSURING THAT YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT WE ARE COORDINATED AND A
LITTLE ELISABETTA --
WAS WAS CLEAR IN AND THE ITEMS
THAT THAT --
WE ARE COLLABORATING ON AND AND
TALKED --
VERY --
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT SEVERAL OF
THOSE -- THE
FIRED THREAT --
DISTRICTS THE FIRE THREAT MAP --
ELEMENTS OF THE FIRE THREAT MAP
THAT ARE GOING TO BE ADDED TO
INCLUDING A WIN AND AND LOADING
ON THE POLLS.
I WHICH IS EMPTY ACHE A KEY
INFORMATION --
TO TWO ADD TO THOSE MAPS SO WILL
HAVE A BETTER PRODUCT IN THE
FUTURE --
BUT ALSO THE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND WILDFIRE
MEDICAID MITIGATION PLANS OF
WHICH WE ARE --
TECHNICAL SUPPORT AND READ OF
ALL OF THESE THESE ITEMS --
AND MORE --
OUR OUR IT DEPARTMENT AND THE
COMMISSION ARE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY ON TO ENSURE THAT THAT
THE BEST TECHNICAL SUPPORT AT IS
GIVEN TO THE COMMISSION.
AND ALSO THE FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION --
LAWS AND PUBLIC RESOURCES CORE
CODER BEING MET UNDER --
CAL FIRES JURISDICTION.
SO THOSE MAPS --
OR THE MAP I'LL DISCOLORED THE
MAP -- FIRE
THREAT MAP VERY IS IS VERY KEY
--
TO TUNING OUR PROGRAMS FOR FIRE
PREVENTION.
I MENTION FIRE PREVENTION
PREVIOUSLY I'M COMING BACK TO IT
NOW.
BECAUSE WE WE ARE --
WORKING UNDER --
DIRECTOR HIM LOTS OF LEADERSHIP
TO INCREASE THE PACE AND SCALE
OF OUR FIVE OF OUR PRESCRIBED
BURN PROGRAMS --
AND NUMBERS OF ACRES THAT WE
BURN ANNUALLY --
FOR FUEL REDUCTION AND HABITAT
MANAGEMENT AS WELL AS OUR OUR
MANUAL FUEL REDUCTION PROJECT
WORK WHICH WE CAN DO MORE
SURGICALLY IN AND AROUND
COMMUNITIES --
AND THEN --
IN PARTICULAR OUR INSPECTION
PROGRAMS --
WE DO HAVE INSPECTION PROGRAMS
THAT ARE CODIFIED IN THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE.
OF FOR DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTION --
THAT'S THE INSPECTIONS --
THAT OF THE FIRST PANEL REFER TO
AS THOSE AREAS AROUND --
HABITABLE STRUCTURES WITHIN A
HUNDRED FEET OF THAT STRUCTURE
THERE'S A GRADUATED THIRTY FEET
AND THEN AN ADDITIONAL SEVENTY
FEET AND THEIR DIFFERENT
CRITERIA WITHIN THOSE --
SO THAT WE ARE WE ARE
ENDEAVORING TO VISIT EVERY --
EVERY.
HABITABLE STRUCTURE IN THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA ONCE EVERY
THREE YEARS --
THROUGH ARE PROGRAM AND WHO WERE
VERY CLOSE TO THAT --
JUST.
SLIGHTLY SHORT --
OF THAT GOAL THIS YEAR SO FAR --
BUT WE WILL CONTINUE TO ENDEAVOR
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN --
FURTHER WE DO --
RAILROAD AND OTHER MISCELLANEOUS
POINT SOURCE INSPECTIONS --
AND THEN --
PARTICULARLY --
PRUDENT HERE UTILITY LINE
COMPLIANCE INSPECTIONS --
THOSE ARE CODIFIED UNDER PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE FORTY TO NINETY
TWO AND FORTY TWO NINETY THREE
AND WE ARE WORKING DILIGENTLY TO
INCREASE OUR PACE AND SCALE ON
THOSE INSPECTIONS AS WELL
[inaudible]
OF THE FINAL FINAL ITEM THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO A POINT YOUR
ATTENTION TO IS --
WE HAVE A POWER LINE FIRE
PREVENTION A FIELD GUIDE.
AND I IT'S APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY PAGES LONG
AND IT IS A REALLY THE GUY THAT
THAT --
IDENTIFIES WITH PICTURES
EQUIPMENT ON POLLS AND DIFFERENT
TYPES OFTREATMENTS AND
PRESCRIPTIONS TO REDUCE FIRE
RISK -- FROM
FROM THOSE AND ALSO ON THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT SIDE.
THAT THAT FIELD GUIDE IS IS --
BEING -- RE
WRITTEN AS WE SPEAK AND WE WILL
BE --
PUTTING THAT OUT SOON.
SO IN CLOSING --
CAO FIRES POISED TO CONTINUE OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CP YOU SEE
AND BETTER PROTECT LIVES AND
PROPERTY --
OF THOSE IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
AND THE ENEMY.
ROOM AND WITH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND MISTER CHAIRMAN MR CO
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE.
ARE MY NAME IS BRIAN D'AGOSTINO
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF FIRE SCIENCE
AND CLIMATE ADAPTATION FOR SAN
DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC.
AND PART OF WHAT WE'VE HEARD WE
HAVE A VERY EXTENSIVE FIRE
MITIGATION PROGRAM IN SAN DIEGO
SO PART OF WHAT I'M GOING TO
SHARE WITH YOU TODAY IS.
HOW IF WE WORKED OVER THE LAST
DECADE TO BUILD?
IT'S NOT TO BUILD THIS
MITIGATION PROGRAM AND REALLY
HOW HAVE WE USED IT I'M NOT ONLY
IN DECEMBER BUT EVEN JUST A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO AS WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE EXTREME HEAT
WAVES -- AN
EXTREME FIRE POTENTIAL --
IMPART OF HOW THIS PROGRAM
STARTED WHO IS WAS GATHERING
WEATHER INFORMATION --
SO IN TWO THOUSAND TEN WE
EMBARKED ON AN EFFORT TO PUT A
WEATHER STATION ON EVERY.
ONE OF THE CIRCUITS THAT WE
OPERATE ACROSS OUR HIGHEST RISK
AREAS.
AND AND WE FOUND THAT THERE WAS
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION AND VALUE.
AND THAT HAS COME FROM THAT
NETWORK --
TODAY WE COLLECT TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND PIECES OF WEATHER DATA
EVERY DAY AND IF YOU LOOK AT
THAT OVER THE COURSE OF A YEAR.
IT'S ALMOST A HUNDRED MILLION
AND OVER THE COURSE OF A DECADE
NOW WHERE APPROACHING A BILLION
PIECES OF WEATHER DATA SO IT'S
REALLY BECOMING A A BIG DATA --
WHETHER COLLECTION AND WE CAN DO
LOTS OF INFORMATION --
AND MAKE LOTS OF GOOD CHOICES
WITH A LOT OF THIS INFORMATION
ON SOME OF THOSE EIGHT GOES AND
NOT TO HELPING US BUILD TO
WEATHER MODELS.
BEING ABLE TO ANTICIPATE AND
PREPARE.
NOW FOR THESE EXTREME EVENTS
WHEN THEY'RE COMING THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WE LOOK AT
VERY CLOSELY SO WE OPERATE A
MULTIPLE DATA SUPERCOMPUTERS IN
SAN DIEGO.
THAT TELL US EXACTLY HOW STRONG
WE THINK THE WINDS ARE GOING TO
BE AND EXACTLY WHERE THAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
WE UPDATE THOSE MULTIPLE TIMES
EVERY DAY AND IT REALLY HELPS US
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN I GET
CREWS AND RESOURCES IN THE RIGHT
PLACES -- AT
THE RIGHT TIME NOT IN ALL OF
THIS INFORMATION --
THEN ENDS UP BEING SHARED --
WITH THE NATIONAL WEATHER
SERVICE --
WITH THE FIRE AGENCIES IN AND
OTHER FOLKS SO A VERY VALUABLE
RESOURCE --
THAT WE HAVE DOWN IN SAN DIEGO
[inaudible]
AND ALL OF THIS INFORMATION ALSO
FEEDS INTO OUR TOOLS.
A BIG PART OF WHAT WE'VE NEEDED
--
TO OPERATE SAFELY AND RELIABLY
IT'S AN UNDERSTANDING OF A WHAT
IS THE FIRE POTENTIAL EVERYDAY
--
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
DAYS A YEAR.
SO WE DEVELOPED SOMETHING CALLED
THE FIRE POTENTIAL INDEX AND
WHAT IT IT WAS DEVELOPED BY
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS WITHIN
THE UTILITY TEAM OF
FIREFIGHTERS.
AND A TEAM OF METEOROLOGISTS
WE'VE COME TOGETHER AND TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT DRIVES.
HIGH FIRE DANGER IN SAN DIEGO.
IN YOU CAN LOOK AND IT'S THAT
THE GRASS CROP IN THE AMOUNT OF
MOISTURE IN THE LIVE VEGETATION
AND THEN.
THE AMOUNT OF MOISTURE IN THE
DEAD FUELS AND THEN OF COURSE
THE WEATHER AND BY COMBINING ALL
OF THOSE.
INTO A SINGLE INDEX WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DEVELOP THAT I'VE THIS
ONE TOOL THAT THE FIRE POTENTIAL
INDEX AND OVER TIME IT HAS GROWN
OUTSIDE THE WALLS OF THE
UTILITY.
WE STARTED SHARING IT WITH THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND THEN THE CITY
MANAGER'S AT ALL OF OUR LOCAL
CITIES AND THEN SAN DIEGO FIRE
AND RESCUE WE SEND IT TO CAL
FIRE EVERY DAY THROUGH OUR
PARTNERSHIPS.
I'VE DOWN IN SAN DIEGO.
TARA SO CERTAINLY A A VERY
VALUABLE --
TOOL AND SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
VERY NECESSARY IN OUR SAFE
OPERATION --
DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
SOMETHING I HEARD EARLIER --
IN THIS HEARING WHICH I
CERTAINLY AGREED WITH WAS TAKE
LOOKING AT FIRE WEATHER IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND RELATING
IT TO WHAT A HURRICANE COULD BE.
OUR FOR THE SOUTHEASTERN PART OF
THE STATES.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT ONE THING
THAT THEY HAD IN THE
SOUTHEASTERN PART OF THE UNITED
STATES IS A RATING WHERE IF A
HURRICANE WAS COMING.
YOU KNEW THEY WOULD SELL YOU IF
IT WAS A CATEGORY ONE A CATEGORY
THREE CATEGORY.
FIVE LEADERSHIP THAT SDG ANY
CHALLENGED US ARE.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO TO DEVELOP A
RATING SYSTEM SIMILAR TO THAT.
AND OUT OF THAT PROJECT THE
SANTA ANA WILDFIRE THREAT INDEX
TOM WAS BORN AND IT'S NICE TO BE
NEXT TO CHIEF PORTER HERE
BECAUSE WE WORKED VERY CLOSELY.
ON WITH HIS TEAM OF
METEOROLOGISTS AND RIVERSIDE AND
ALSO THE AND ATMOSPHERIC
SCIENCES DEPARTMENT AT UCLA AND
WE DEVELOPED THIS INDEX AND WHAT
IT DOES IS IT TELLS US.
ANA RATING FROM MARGINAL ALL THE
WAY TWO EXTREME WHAT IS THE FIRE
DANGER.
WITH THIS PARTICULAR SANTA ANA
WIND EVENT IN UNDERSTANDING THE
MAGNITUDE OF THAT RISK BECOMES
VERY CRITICAL TIME IN
MITIGATING.
AND THE RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT PARTICULAR SANTA ANA --
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
AVAILABLE ON TO ALL OF A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COVERS THE
SEVEN NINE SEVEN MAJOR COUNTIES
WE HAVE IN THE THE SOUTHERN PART
OF THE STATE.
AND ITS ISSUED BY --
THE UNITED STATES FOREST SERVICE
ARE PREDICTIVE SERVICES AND CAL
FIRE.
ON EVERYDAY.
SO GREAT TO HAVE A GREAT TOOL.
I'VE BUT OUR OUR ANALYTICS HAS
CONTINUED TO EVOLVE --
OVER THE YEARS AND A LOT OF WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT NOW --
BECOMES FIRE BEHAVIOR MODEL LIKE
--
IF A FIRE WHERE TO START --
EXACTLY WHERE WOULD IT GROW HOW
FAST CAN WE EXPECT TO GROW ON
AND WHAT COULD POTENTIALLY BE
AND ITS WAY.
AND HAVING THIS TECHNOLOGY AND
OPERATIONS IT'S BEEN REALLY THE
LEADING EDGE --
OF OUR TECHNOLOGY THESE DAYS AND
WITH SOME OF OUR BIG DATA --
WE ARE CURRENTLY --
SIMULATING OVER TEN MILLION
VIRTUAL WILDFIRES ACROSS SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND WE'RE DOING
THAT AT EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND THAT TELLS US EXACTLY WHERE
IF THEY FOUGHT IF A FIRE WERE TO
START HERE.
TODAY -- WE
HAVE BIG DATA AND ANALYTICS THAT
CAN TELL US WHERE IT WOULD GROW
AND AND THE AREA THAT IT COULD
ENCOMPASS AND THAT BECOMES
REALLY GOOD INTEL --
WHEN TRYING TO OPERATE SAFELY?
AND THEN AS RECENTLY AS JUST A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO AS WE START
SEEING SEVERAL FIRES BREAKING
OUT ACROSS SAN DIEGO.
YOU CAN SIMULATE YOU GET A
REALLY GOOD UNDERSTANDING OF IBM
IMMEDIATE THREAT.
POSTED BY SOME OF THESE A
CONNECTION.
ASA THESE ARE SOME SOME VERY
VALUABLE --
TECHNOLOGY TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCEMENTS THAT
WE'VE REALLY BEEN PUSHING
FORWARD.
DOWN IN SAN DIEGO ITS STATE
LEADING EDGE OF A LOT OF THE
FIRE SCIENCE IN ITS WHERE FIRE
SCIENCE IN BIG DATA MEET --
AND WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
CONTINUE TO PUSH THAT FORWARD
LIKE WE HAVE --
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
AND I FOCUSED A BIT ON THE
TECHNOLOGY --
AND SOME OF THE INNOVATION THAT
HAS HAPPENED ON MAJOR COMPONENT
BECOMES OUR CUSTOMER OUTREACH ON
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT --
WE ARE CONTINUOUSLY CONTINUOUSLY
WORKING ON ON AND EVOLVING UP
PARTNERSHIPS WITH ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE THE AMERICAN RED CROSS I'M
SAN DIEGO.
TO ONE ONE OUR COMMUNITY
EMERGENCY RESPONSE TEAMS LIKE
THE CIRCUITS ON WE WORK WITH
THESE FOLKS BECAUSE WE'RE ALL
TRYING TO BE RESILIENT TOGETHER
--
WE NOW HAVE A FIRE MITIGATION IN
CLIMATE ADAPTATION GROUP --
WHICH IS UNDER THE DEPARTMENT
THAT I DIRECTED NOW AND WEEP
BRINGING IN A COMMUNITY
RESILIENT SPECIALIST.
AND PART OF IT IS TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND --
WHAT CAN WE DO TO HELP THE
COMMUNITY?
A BE MORE RESILIENT AND REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE RESILIENCY IN THE
ADAPTATION ASPECT --
OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THAT IS SO
AND I IMPORTANT MOVING FORWARD
--
OTHER VERY CRITICAL ASPECTS OF
OUR COMMUNITY FIRE SAFETY
PROGRAM.
ON WINE IS THE HELLER TANKER --
AS THE GENIE BRINGS THE LARGEST
FIRE FIGHTING HELICOPTER ON THAT
THERE IS IN THE UNITED STATES TO
SAN DIEGO.
OUGHT TO HELP FIGHT THESE FIRES
AS WE IN.
A SOME OF THE INTRODUCTORY MARKS
FROM SENATOR STONE THE PROXIMITY
TO GETTING AVIATION TO THE SITE.
ARM AND HAVING WATER DROPPED ON
A SITE IMMEDIATELY IS CRITICAL.
ON AND WE HAD.
RECOGNIZED THE CRITICALITY OF
THAT NOT BECAUSE OF THAT WE
BRING IN.
OUR THIS HOW A TANKER YEAR ROUND
TO DISPATCHED BY CAL FIRE.
I'D TO IMMEDIATELY RESPOND AND
HELP SUPPRESS ANY FIRES THAT
BREAK OUT NOT JUST UTILITY
RELATED WILDFIRES ANY WILDFIRES.
THAT BREAK OUT IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY.
WE'VE HEARD QUITE A BIT ABOUT
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT ON
SOMETHING THAT WE TAKE OF COURSE
EXTREMELY --
SERIOUSLY WE HAVE AN AWARD
WINNING VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM WE HAVE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND TREES
--
WHICH ARE CURRENTLY LOGGED AND
INSPECTED EVERY YEAR.
ON AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
EVEN THIS YEAR THERE HAVE BEEN
ADDITIONAL ENHANCEMENTS.
ON TOP OF A HOBBY ALREADY A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM AND THAT
IS IN PLACE --
SO SOMETHING THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT AND THEN SYSTEM HARDENING WE
WE'VE HEARD --
LIZA MENTIONING ABOUT --
HARDENING THE SYSTEM THERE'S
ALREADY BEEN OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS INVESTED IN SAN DIEGO IN
FIRE HARDENING THE SYSTEM.
I SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HEARD OF EARLIER IT'S A
CONVERTING WOULD POLLS TO STEAL
POLLS GETTING THINGS HIGHER OFF
THE GROUND SO IT'S LESS LIKELY
THAT THE DEBRIS THAT WE HEAR
ABOUT.
AYE IT'S LESS LIKELY THAT THE
DEBRIS IS GOING TO GET INTO THE
LINES MOVING LINES FURTHER APART
SO THAT THEY'RE LESS LIKELY.
TO I COME INTO CONTACT AND IT IS
A IT IS A HUGE --
HARDENING UNDERTAKING --
THROUGH ALL OF THIS BUT
SOMETHING THAT --
SDG ANY IS A IS VERY COMMITTED.
TO AND I WANTED --
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
RECENT EVENTS OUT BECAUSE AS WE
HEAR ABOUT CLIMATE SHIFTS IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING A VERY MUCH SO IN
SAN DIEGO JUST LIKE THE REST OF
THE STATE AND THE RIGHT THE REST
OF THE WORLD.
AYE WE BROKE SOME ALL TIME HIGH
TEMPERATURES EARLIER THIS MONTH
ON JULY SIXTH.
ON SOME OF OUR COMMUNITIES NOT
TOO FAR FROM THE BEACH I WOULD
CONSIDER ARE FOOTHILLS WERE
APPROACHING A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DEGREES.
AND THEY'D NEVER GONE HIGHER
THAN A HUNDRED ELEVEN BEFORE --
AND AT THE SAME TIME WE HAD
MULTIPLE WILD FIRES AND BREAKING
OUT ALL ACROSS.
AND SAN DIEGO COUNTY --
SO CERTAINLY A VERY
UNPRECEDENTED TYPE OF EVENT FOR
US IN THE MONTH OF JULY
[inaudible]
AND HISTORICALLY SPEAKING WE DO
SEE FIRES IN JULY USUALLY UP IN
THE MOUNTAINS AND AN AFTERNOON
SEA BREEZE BUT THIS IS A VERY
DIFFERENT EVENT --
THAT WE EXPERIENCED ON THEIR
WORST THREE OUTAGES ON OUR
SYSTEM ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
EVENT IN JULY ON NINE THAT THE
COMPANY PROACTIVELY DE
ENERGIZED.
AND THIS WAS THE TYPE OF EVENT
ON THAT WEEK END UP TURNING OFF
THE POWER ON ONE CIRCUIT NOT
BECAUSE THE FIREFIGHTERS ASKED
US.
TO OFFER SAFETY AND WE
COLLABORATE VERY CLOSELY WE HAVE
RETIRED FIREFIGHTERS THAT JOIN
INTO THE INCIDENT COMMAND ON THE
SYSTEM AND HOW WE WORK IN A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT TO KEEP.
EVERYBODY SAFE --
DURING THESE TYPE OF EVENTS AND
THEN ALSO THE THE FIRE ITSELF ON
CAN CAUSE OUTAGES THROUGH THEIR
BURNING INTO THE SYSTEM SO
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT'S BEEN
EXPERIENCED --
EARLIER THIS MONTH.
AND THE AIR CRANE WHICH WE
TALKED ABOUT --
IS HAVING IT'S ON PACE TO BY FAR
HAVE A RECORD YEAR IN SAN DIEGO.
ON ONE FIRE LOAN EARLIER THIS
MONTH THAT DROPPED FIFTY
THOUSAND GALLONS OF WATER.
ARE JUST JUST SHY OF FIFTY
THOUSAND I SHOULD SAY.
AND SO FAR THIS YEAR WERE
APPROACHING A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO THOUSAND GALLONS.
ON THAT THE UTILITY PALITANA
OCCUR.
HAS RIGHT NOW CONTRIBUTED TO THE
FIRE FIGHTING EFFORTS SO A VERY
VERY SIGNIFICANT I'M
CONTRIBUTION THERE.
WANTED.
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
DECEMBER.
AS WE'VE SPENT A DECADE
DEVELOPING A VERY COMPREHENSIVE
COMMUNITY FIRE SAFETY PROGRAM
THAT WAS [inaudible]
STRESSED IN DECEMBER WITH THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE EVENT THAT
IMPACTED SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND ULTIMATELY ONE OF THE
BENEFITS WE WERE ABLE TO
ANTICIPATE IT.
AND WE WERE ABLE TO SEE IT
COMING OUR MODELS TOLD A SEVEN
TO TEN DAYS OUT.
THAT THIS COULD BE I'M A TYPE OF
EVENT THAT COMES AROUND.
YOU KNOW IT'S HARD TO SAY IN OUR
IN WHAT IS NOW NORMAL --
BUT OF RARE EVENT WILL SAY ONCE
IN A TEN YEAR ONCE IN THE TWENTY
FIVE YEAR TYPE OF EVENT.
SO BEING ABLE TO SEE IT COMING
WE TOOK ALL PRECAUTIONS TO
MITIGATE THE RISK.
THAT WAS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
I'VE YOU PUT SENSITIVE RELAYS ON
THE ELECTRIC SYSTEM.
YOU MAKE SURE THAT ALL RE
CLOSING IS TURNED OFF IN SOME
CASES ACROSS THE ENTIRE SYSTEM
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO THE BEACH.
AND YOU TAKE ALL THE STEPS TO
BEGIN TO MITIGATE THAT YOU WORK
WITH THE RED CROSS YOU WORK WITH
COMMUNITY LEADERS --
AND MAKE SURE THAT OUR CUSTOMERS
ARE AWARE OF WHAT'S --
WHAT'S POTENTIALLY COMING ABOUT
POTENTIALLY COULD HAPPEN --
BUT WHAT WE FOUND DURING THIS
PARTICULAR EVENT.
ON IS THAT THEIR WORD DE
ENERGIZED HAITIANS FOR SAFETY --
AND THAT BECOMES THE LAST RESORT
IT'S NEVER THE FOR THE FIRST
THING THAT YOU WOULD DO BUT WHEN
ALL OF THESE OTHER.
MITIGATION OF FAT AS THE FACTS
HAVE BEEN EXHAUSTED ARE BUT
THEY'RE STILL VERY SIGNIFICANT
SAFETY ISSUES THEN DE ENERGIZED
ATION --
BECOMES A REAL OPTION AND IN
THIS CASE YOU LOOK AT OTHER
THINGS LIKE WARNINGS.
ARE THERE RED FLAG WARNINGS IN A
FACT IS THAT THE SANTA ANA
WILDFIRE THREAD INDEX WHAT'S THE
RATING ON THAT --
OUR INTERNAL TOOLS LIKE THE FIRE
POTENTIAL INDEX IF ALL OF THOSE
ARE TELLING US THAT THIS IS AN
EXTREMELY RARE.
VERY HIGH RISK EVENT --
WE LOOK AT WEATHER CONDITIONS
FROM OUR WEATHER NETWORK --
WE'LL GET VEGETATION FUEL
CONDITIONS HOW MUCH OF WHAT IS
THE BURNING ENVIRONMENT FOR FIRE
GOES AND WILL IT GROW
EXPLOSIVELY.
ON AVAILABILITY OF FIREFIGHTING
RESOURCES IS IS A HUGE ONE IF
THERE ARE FIRES BURNING ALL OVER
THE STATE --
THAT BECOMES A BIG FACTOR AS
WELL AS WINS A LOT OF TYPES CAN
GROUND AND SO --
SO IF WE KNOW THAT IF A FIRE
WERE TO START ALL OF THE ARE ALL
OF THE AVIATION SUPPORT IS
GROUNDED THAT BECOMES A VERY BIG
FACTOR --
WHEN MAKING A DECISION LIKE THAT
AND THAT WAS EXACTLY WHAT WE
CAME INTO IN DECEMBER --
WE WERE.
MATTER WHICH DIRECTION WE LOOKED
IN SAN DIEGO THERE WAS SMOKE IN
THE SKY ALL AROUND US --
THE THOMAS FIRE HAD BEEN BURNING
AT AN EXPLOSIVE RATE --
FOR THE PREVIOUS EIGHTEEN HOURS
--
AND THERE WAS ALSO A LARGE FIRES
DOWN IN NORTHERN BAJA --
WHICH WE WHERE I TRACKING SO WE
WE AT THAT POINT HAD BEEN FULLY
SURROUNDED AND WE'RE EXPECTING
WINDS OF SIXTY TO NINETY MILES
AN HOUR --
ACROSS OUR BACK COUNTRY IN OUR
WEATHER NETWORK STARTED TO
CAPTURE THAT WE ACTUALLY SAW
WINDS ARE UP TO EIGHTY SEVEN
MILES AN HOUR IN THE BACK
COUNTRY OF SAN DIEGO UNDER THOSE
CONDITIONS.
I'M SO WAS EXTREMELY CRITICAL
AND THAT'S WHEN WE DID TAKE
THOSE STEPS --
TO DE ENERGIZED FOR FOR THE
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC --
ONE OF THE BIG PIECES OF
FEEDBACK THAT WE GOT AS AS SOON
AS THE WINDS COME DOWN.
EVERYONE SAYS OKAY LET'S LET'S
TURN IT RIGHT BACK ON BUT RE
ENERGIZING AYE IS A VERY LARGE
EFFORT.
I FOR A COUPLE REASONS WHEN THE
SYSTEM IS DE ENERGIZED THERE
COULD BE TREE LIMBS UNDER WIND
CONDITIONS OF NINETY MILES AN
HOUR THEIR COULD BE TREE LIMBS
FROM HALF A MILE AWAY.
THAT ARE IN THE LINE --
SO AT THAT POINT WE HAVE TO
MONITOR.
THE ENTIRE LINE INCH BY INCH AND
LOOK AT IT AND MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS NOTHING IN.
IN THE LINES ITSELF AND THIS IS
AFTER THE WINDS HAVE DROPPED LOW
ENOUGH THAT WE'RE CONFIDENT
NOTHING ELSE IS GOING. TO TO
BLOW INTO THE LINES SOME OF
THESE HAVE TO BE DONE BY
HELICOPTER.
AYE IN THE SAFETY OF THE PILOTS
OF COURSES PARAMOUNT.
AND SO EVEN AS THE WINDS IN A
SANTA ANA DECREASE RIGHT THERE
AT THE SURFACE THEY GET UP IN A
HELICOPTER AND THEY SAY IT'S
STILL REALLY WINDY APPEAR.
NAM SO WE HAVE TO WAIT FOR
REALLY THE WHOLE EVENT. TO COME
TO AN END AS WE START PATROLLING
AND IN SOME CASES --
WERE PATROLLING HUNDREDS IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF MILES --
OF LINES TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE CLEAR AND SAFE AND READY TO
BE RE ENERGIZED SO THESE ARE
SOME MAJOR FACTORS --
THAT WE LOOK AT AGAIN I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND HAVING
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TO TALK ABOUT
THIS AND LOOK FORWARD IF THERE
ARE ANY FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE DO APPRECIATE A
NOT ONLY ARE PRESENTATION IT WAS
VERY ENLIGHTENING IN TERMS OF
WHAT --
YOU'RE TAKING THE TECHNOLOGY AND
AND KIND OF LOOKING AT WHAT WAS
DESCRIBED EARLIER ABOUT PC AND
AS WEATHERIZATION ISSUES AND
HOW.
TO A GIVE US MORE INFORMATION TO
BE IN A STRONGER POSITION SO I
THINK THAT'S VERY HELPFUL I'M
GONNA HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TOUR THE FACILITY ON FRIDAY SO
IT ENCOURAGES.
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE PANEL
THAT SOME POINT.
A TO MAKE THEMSELVES AVAILABLE
TO DO SO AS WELL.
ARE I'D LIKE.
TO ASK A QUESTION OR TWO OF YOU
MISTER PICKER AND THEN WE'LL
TURN TO OTHER MEMBERS.
TO EXPLORE QUESTIONS AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO THE PUBLIC.
THERE YOU'D MENTIONED THERE ARE
BEING THE A SAFETY STANDARDS.
AS A RELATED TO SAFETY STANDARDS
WERE A MORE TYPICALLY BASED ON
FUNDING --
RATHER THAN ON WHAT WAS
NECESSARY FOR SAFETY OR MAYBE
YOU CAN CORRECT ME ON ON THAT
POINT BUT I BUT I GUESS IF THE
PART THAT WE REALLY WANT TO GET
TO IS.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
OTHER ENTITIES THAT ARE MORE.
APPROPRIATE TO MAYBE LOOK AT
SETTING THESE SAFETY STANDARDS.
I I THINK ABOUT THAT A LOT.
OF BUT OUR OBLIGATION IS TO HAVE
SORT OF A LEGALISTIC FRAMEWORK
IT'S ALMOST LIKE A COURT IS
SIMILAR TO THE ADMIRALTY COURTS
WORD THEM WHEN WE AUTHORIZE
EXPENDITURES A. COMES. FOR THE
JUDGE WHO ALLOWS PEOPLE TO
DECLARE THAT THEIR PARTIES IN
THAT PROCEEDING AND THEY CAN
CHALLENGE.
THE UTILITIES ASSERTIONS ABOUT
WHAT WOULD BE SUITABLE
EXPENDITURES.
AND THEN WE HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION THIS BASED ON THE
RECORD SO DEPENDING UPON HOW
WELL THE UTILITY CAN MAKE THEIR
ARGUMENTS ABOUT WHETHER AN
EXPENDITURE IS REASONABLE AND
JUST.
AND THE EVIDENCE THAT'S
PRESENTED BY PARTIES.
I HOPE WE SOMETIMES DON'T HAVE
THE RECORD TO MAKE A FINE THEN
EXPENDITURES NECESSARY.
HERE IN PART BECAUSE WE COULD
RELY ON THE EFFORTS OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND ARE PROCEEDING AROUND
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WE DID NOT
ACCEPT THE ARGUMENT FOR THEIR
WORK FROM THE RATE PAYER
ADVOCATES THAT THE EXPENDITURES
THE NEW EXPENDITURES FOR IT AND
MORE.
EXPANDED DIVERT PROGRAM WERE
INAPPROPRIATE WE FOUND THAT THEY
WERE FROM.
SO WE'VE BEEN ORDERED THIS THIS
PAST IN THE COUNTRY [inaudible]
SENATE PRACTICES [inaudible]
IN THE WHO DO YOU CONSIDER
THEY'RE BEING AN OPPORTUNITY OR
NEED FOR THIS SAFETY STANDARDS.
THEY COULD BE SAID BY.
A DIFFERENT ENTITY BID THEN
CLOSE THE P. YOU SEE MORE IN A
POSITION OF IMPLEMENTATION SO
I'M ALWAYS LOOKING FOR BEST
PRACTICES AND SO WOULD EXAMPLE.
WHAT I'VE SEEN ELSEWHERE IS FOR
EXAMPLE A NUCLEAR SAFETY?
WE DON'T CHALLENGE THE FINDINGS
TO THE NRC.
THEY SAID A SAFETY STANDARD AND
THEN THE UTILITIES BRING FORWARD
THEIR COST ESTIMATES WILL LOOK
AT COST ESTIMATES TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE REASONABLE BUT WE DON'T
CHALLENGE THE STANDARD WE DON'T
SET.
SNOW HERE WE BECAUSE WE THOUGHT
IT WAS NECESSARY BECAUSE IT'S
IT'S CURRENTLY OUR DUTY TO DO
THAT WE WE WORK WITH CAL FIRE TO
COME UP WITH --
A VEHICLE TO DO THAT AND SO
UNTIL THERE'S MAYBE A STATEWIDE
SAFETY AGENCY THAT DEALS WITH
ALL KINDS OF SAFETY RISKS AND
PUTS FORWARD STANDARDS.
IT'LL ALWAYS FALL TO US TO TO DO
THE SINKS WITHIN OUR EXISTING
SETTING --
SO.
A CHALLENGES ALWAYS OF COURSE
THAT WHEN WE DO THINGS
INDEPENDENT OF OTHER AGENCIES WE
CAN SET A DIFFERENT STANDARD OR
WE CAN UNDERCUT.
OR OTHER AGENCIES CAN UNDERCUT
WHAT WE COME UP WITH SO IT'S IT
REQUIRES US TO BE VERY NOBLE.
AND TO WORK VERY CAREFULLY
FEATHER OUTSIDE AGENCIES.
BUT EVEN THERE I THINK THAT THAT
YOU WILL KIND OF GET PEOPLE KIND
OF SHOPPING FOR THE JURISDICTION
TO FIGHT OVER WHETHER SOMETHING
IS REASONABLE WE AND EFFECTIVE.
AND WHETHER THE EXPENDITURE IS
IS IS NECESSARY.
WOULD YOU RECOMMEND.
SUCH A STATEWIDE AGENCY BE
RESPONSIBLE ENOUGH TO FIND A
CERTAIN WAY.
I THINK THAT THAT IF YOU START
DOWN THAT PATH YOU HAVE TO LOOK
AT ALL THE OTHER INDEPENDENT
AGENCIES WHO HAVE DEEP EXPERTISE
IN OTHER KINDS OF INDUSTRIES AND
OTHER KIND OF BEHAVIORS RANGING
FROM WATER QUALITY TO THESE
TOXICS TO ON HIGHWAY SAFETY.
SO I THINK IT'S ROBABLY
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS A WHOLE LOT
OF THOUGHT I TALK A LOT WITH MY
COLLEAGUES HERE TO WE ASK
HELLFIRE ABOUT HOW WE GET
BETTER.
IT SHARING INFORMATION AND
COORDINATING.
BUT I THINK IT'S AND IT'S IT'S A
LITTLE BIT OUT BEYOND OUR CAR
OUR PORTFOLIO TO ACTUALLY TALK
ABOUT WHETHER SOMEBODY ELSE
SHOULD DO IT.
THERE ARE TIMES WE DO OUR BEST.
ALRIGHT WE WOULD [inaudible]
MR DOT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
CAUTIONARY NORSTAR.
I'VE DOES FIT MANY HOURS WAS THE
PRESIDENT PICKER AND I SPENT
SOMETIME WITH CHIEF AND I JUST
WANNA --
START OUT BY SAYING.
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE SECOND
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT NOTED THAT
TIME.
A COUPLE YEARS BACK ON I DID
STAND ON THE FLOOR AND SAY.
FIRES IN EFFECT CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
YEAH.
IT'S WITH A HEAVY HEART. TO KNOW
THAT WE LOST ABOUT FIFTY LIVES.
THE CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE NOT
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM AND WE
ARE HERE BECAUSE OF LIABILITY
WE'RE HERE BECAUSE WHO'S GONNA
PAY.
AND WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO FIGURE
THAT OUT BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY WE HAVE A FUEL LOADING
PROBLEM.
AND WE HAVE TAKEN A LOT OF THE
TOOLS AWAY.
THAT WE MANAGE THOSE HEELS WITH.
I'VE DEBATED ABOUT GRAZING.
I DEBATED ABOUT HOW WITHIN A
FORCED.
IN THE SIZE OF A TREE THAT YOU
NEED TO COME OUT WHEN THEY'LL
BURN DOWN.
NOW WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT SOME
SERIOUS THINGS THAT HAPPEN HERE
CALIFORNIA IF BEFORE WE LOSE.
A LOT MORE LIVES AND A HELL OF A
LOT OF PROPERTY DAMAGE.
SO I'M EXCITED ABOUT THIS
COMMITTEE BUT THERE A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT.
WE SPENT ABOUT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS.
FROM 200-082-2000 AND FOURTEEN
FIGHTING FIRE.
AND WE LOST SOME GOOD MEN AND
WOMEN OUT THERE DOING IT.
WE PUT A LOT OF MONEY THEIR WE
TALKED ABOUT THE GREENHOUSE GAS
FUNDS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT ISSUES
WE TALKED ABOUT.
HOW WE GONNA TAKE THE BIOMASS
AND PUT IT INTO A PLEA AND WHO'S
GONNA PAY FOR THAT?
AND BATTLED THOSE OUT BIPARTISAN
IS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE.
THIS IS A A PUBLIC PART WHETHER
WE HAVE YOU KNOW TALK ABOUT IT
THERE'S DEBATE ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE NOT COMMITTEES MANY TIES
UP WE ARE CLIMATE IS CHANGING.
SO HUNDRED AND TWENTY DEGREES IN
PLACES WORST.
USED TO HER LAB.
SO I WANTED TO SHARE YES.
MY FRUSTRATION WITH.
THE BILLION NOT REALLY ADDRESSED
THE BIG PROBLEM THIS IS HOW ARE
WE IN A MAJOR FUEL WE CAN SHUT
DOWN THE GRID LIGHTING WILL
STILL STRIKE.
MEN MAKE BECAUSE THE A CAR CAN
STARTED A RAILROAD THERE'S SO
MANY OTHER THINGS OUT THERE THAT
WE DON'T.
TALK ABOUT THE CAN START FIRE
BUT I THOUGHT HUNDRED
LEGISLATORS TO MY DISTRICT.
AND I TAKE A MOUNTAIN FORCED.
AND I SHAUNA FORCES OVERGROWN
BECAUSE OF OUR POLICIES STOPPING
WELFARE YOU CAN'T PUT WELFARE
BACK IN THAT.
FORCE BECAUSE THEY CROWN NOW
THAT MEANS THAT THE TREES BURN.
THEY'RE TOO CLOSE TOGETHER THE
FIRE BURNS FROM TREE TO TREE.
WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT THE
CANOPY.
THAT MEANS OPEN UP THAT FOREST
SO THAT FIRE CAN BURN ON THE
FLOOR LIKE IT'S SUPPOSED TO LOW.
AND WE CAN MANAGE THAT FIRE.
WE HAVE ABOUT THE WHOLE STATE IN
MY MIND IS A HIGH FIRE SEVERITY
ZONE NOT YOU'RE ON THE COAST
WE'LL HEAR THAT JACKSON LIVES.
IT'S BRUSH THEIR WHO NEED TO
MANAGE THAT AND IT'S A LIVE. ONE
THING I THINK GO OUR
CONSTITUENTS DONOR STAND IS THAT
IT IS GROWING EVERY SINGLE DAY.
IS GROWING UP THERE RIGHT NOW.
AND IT WILL BURN.
UNLESS WE MANAGE THAT FUEL.
WE HAVE TO GET THE IDEOLOGY OF
COTTON A CERTAIN SIZE TREE OR
PUTTING GRAZING IN OR WHATEVER
THOSE TOOLS ARE WE GOING TO
START TALKING ABOUT THOSE TOOLS.
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE TO US
THAT DON'T COST OUR RATE PAYERS
AND OUR TAXPAYERS USUALLY PAY
FOR IT THAT AT THE UTILITY BILL
ARE GONNA PAY FOR BY PUTTING MEN
AND WOMEN IN HELICOPTERS AND
AVIATION AND BULLDOZERS AND ALL
THAT OTHER THEN YOU'RE GONNA
PAY.
FOR WHEN YOU GET YOUR WATER BILL
BECAUSE AFTER BURNS THE REAL
DEVASTATION COMES IN WE HAVE THE
SLIDES WE HAVE HUGE.
HUNDREDS OF SQUARE MILES
THOUSAND SQUARE MILES OF
WATERSHED THIS DESTROYED FOR THE
NEXT TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
SO I KNOW I'M RAMBLING BUT I'M
I'M I WANT TO MAKE THE POINT
THAT WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM.
THE PROBLEM IS THE FUEL LOADING
OUT THERE WE NEED TO PUT THE
TOOLS AND POLICIES IN PLACE THAT
ALLOW US TO START DIRECTING
THAT.
PROBLEM THIS IS BEEN THERE FOR
OVER A HUNDRED YEARS.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF POLITICAL
THINGS THAT HAPPEN IN YOUR YOU
DON'T ADDRESS THE PROBLEM
BECAUSE IT'S JUST WHAT THE WHAT
THE PRESIDENT SAID.
THERE'S THE WATER QUALITY PART
OF IT THERE'S THE FORESTRY PART
OF IT THERE'S THE FIREFIGHTING
PARTS OF IT THERE'S A LIABILITY
PART OF IT THERE'S ALL THESE
MOVING PIECES.
THAT IS HOPEFULLY [inaudible]
GOT HOME.
HE DID IN THIS HEARING WE CAN
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THOSE IN THAT
WE TAKE THE TIME.
NOT TO JUST FIX TO WHOEVER THE
BEST LOBBYIST OF THE DAY IS TO
GET THERE WHATEVER THEY NEED TO
GET DONE WE ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT
THE REAL ROOT OF THE PROBLEM.
AND FIX IT FOR THE LONG TERM OF
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
CHAIR --
FIRST OFF I'D LIKE TO SAY --
WELL THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION AND I'M I I WANT.
TO SAM REALLY HAPPY TO HEAR I'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT WHAT'S GONE ON
SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC AND I'M
ACTUALLY.
I'M CURSED BY THAT IN MY OWN
COUNTY CINEMA COUNTY WHERE I
LIVE OUR WATER AGENCIES LOOKING
AT TRYING TO IMPLEMENT SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
I THINK THAT'S THAT'S A HUGE
STEP FORWARD I'M I WANT TO GET
DOWN TO VISIT WITH YOU I I I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT THINK
EVERYBODY ON THIS DIET SHOULD BE
DOWN TO SEE EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
DOING BECAUSE I THINK.
IT IT IS A ROLE MODEL FOR HOW WE
CAN HOW WE DO THINGS GOING
FORWARD SO I APPRECIATE PRETTY
PRESENTE.
BUT YOU WANT TO COME BACK TO
SOME THINGS THAT HAVE THAT DO DE
DO CONCERN ME I THINK. TO PICK A
YOU SAID RIGHTFULLY SO WE ARE
NOT FIRE SCIENTISTS I'M REALLY
ENCOURAGED YOU GUYS ARE ACTUALLY
WORKING WITH CAL FIRE --
ON ON HOW WE GO FORWARD HERE --
I SHOULD ASSUME ANYTHING BUT WE
I DO HAVE YOU SEEN THAT.
OKAY ALRIGHT AND WE'RE NOT HERE
TO TALK ABOUT THAT PROPOSAL SO
POINT OBVIOUS THAT'S A STARTING
POINT.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU I I AM I
HAVE SOME CONCERNS --
ABOUT ABOUT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT I'VE SEEN THEIR I THINK ONE
OF THEM.
IS.
A HEARING TODAY HEARING ABOUT
WILD FIRE MITIGATION PLAN SOUNDS
LIKE THOSE THOSE ARE PLANS AND
ALREADY EXIST OR THERE ARE PLANS
OUT THERE FOR AWHILE FOR
MITIGATION.
BUT WE HAD THE WAY I READ THE
PROPOSAL IS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT STEPPING UP WHILE FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS FOR I'LL USE
THE INVESTOR YOU TO IS AND OWNED
UTILITIES IN A BIG WAY --
AND THERE'S THERE'S TIMES WHICH
IS A TIMEFRAME FOR REVIEWING
THOSE THREE MONTHS.
BUT NO MORE THAN FIVE MONTHS AND
THEN THERE'S IMPLEMENT DUE TO
REVIEWS FOR IMPLEMENTATION WAS
OR TWELVE MONTHS.
NO MORE THAN EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
STILL ON THE SAME PAGE SO MOM I
GUESS WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
IS.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA NEED TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE IF THIS PROPOSAL
WERE TO GO THROUGH WITH SOME IS
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO NEED? TO
MAKE THIS GO THROUGH BECAUSE I
WILL SAY AND I PASSED AND I'VE
SAID THIS BEFORE AND I HAVE A
BILL THAT WAS PASSED IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN IT'S A
TWEAK TO AN EXISTING PROGRAM.
ALMOST OVER EIGHTEEN MONTHS NOW
WERE WAITING FOR FINAL
REGULATIONS ON THAT.
SOME OF A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MASSIVE WILD
WILD FIRE MITIGATION PLANS HOW
THAT HAPPENS OUT THERE.
WHEN WE CAN GET REGULATIONS ON A
ON A ON A BILL TO TWEAK AN
EXISTING SYSTEM?
IN LESS THAN TWO YEARS.
SO -- SO.
I HAVE A I HAVE THE SAME
FRUSTRATIONS I'LL JUST SAY THAT
WE WERE DESIGNED TO SLOW THINGS
DOWN.
WE WERE DESIGNED TO MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LITIGATE.
BOTH THE POLICY AND ALL THE
CHANGES THAT ARE MADE STRAIGHT
PEOPLE GET DIFFERENT BITES AT
THE APPLE.
AND PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH VERY LARGE.
PEOPLE HAVE FOUND THAT THAT IS
NECESSARY.
SO -- IF YOU
FEEL LIKE YOU NEED A DIFFERENT
STANDARD BY WHICH WE ADOPT
CERTAIN KINDS OF POLICIES.
THEN PERHAPS YOU NEED TO REALLY
KIND OF THINK ABOUT REDESIGNING
OUR PROCESSES I WILL SAY THAT
ONE OF THE THE FEATURES THERE
WERE WERE WRESTLING WITH IS THAT
WE CAN DO SOME OF OUR FIVE SAY
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS.
THROUGH NOTICING CAR COMMENT
PROCESSES THAT'S NEW TO US IN
WORD WORD WE'RE CONTINUING TO TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THAT.
EXPEDITIOUSLY HIM FAIRLY.
SO IT WOULD RATHER THAN HAVING
PEOPLE COME BEFORE A
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE.
AND PRESENTING A CASE AS TO WHY
THEY OUGHT TO BE ALLOWED TO
PARTICIPATE.
HAVING THE PARTY'S COMMENT ON A
SCOPING DOCUMENT AND NOT HAVING
THE SCOPING DOCUMENT REPUBLISHED
IS IN ORDER.
THEN HAVING AND PEOPLE SUBMIT
BRIEFS THEN HAVING PEOPLE ON
COMMENT ON EACH OTHER'S PRES
THEN HAVING EVIDENTIARY
HEARINGS.
HAVING CROSS EXAMINATION OF EACH
OTHER'S WITNESSES.
AND THEN ACTUALLY HAVING A
PROPOSED --
DECISION COMMENTS ON THE
PROPOSED DECISION SOMETIMES REAL
LITIGATION SOMETIME BIFURCATING
PIECES OF IT WHERE THERE'S NOT A
CONSENSUS OR A CLEAR RECORD.
YEAH THAT'S SLOW.
AND I WANT TO CHANGE IT WELL YOU
KNOW I'M.
YOU KNOW YEAH I DO BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE DYING LET'S TALK A
PIECE WE'RE DYING LESS IT SO I'M
CONCERNED.
HOW LONG IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
DESIGNED TO SLOW THINGS DOWN?
HOW LONG IS IT GOING TO TAKE?
FOR US TO MOVE FORWARD ON SOME
OF THESE THINGS THAT WE REALLY
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD HOW LONG IS
IT REALISTICALLY TAKE TO REVIEW
THESE FIRE MITIGATION PLANS HOW
LONG IS IT GOING TO
REALISTICALLY TAKE TO DO THE
INSPECTIONS THAT ARE NECESSARY.
BECAUSE I'M REAL CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT BASED ON MY MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH THE WAY THINGS
WORK WELL I'D JUST BE HONEST
WITH YOU ABOUT ONE THING WHEN WE
DEPART FROM THE LONG STANDING
PRACTICE OR PRECEDENT FOR A SET
OF POLICIES AND PROCEDURES.
HE GETS LITIGATED WE GET SUED
SOMETIMES PUBLIC POLICY ARGUMENT
AS TO WHY WE'RE DOING THINGS
DIFFERENTLY IN THE FUTURE.
IT'S HELPFUL TO GET DIRECTION.
CHANGE THOSE THINGS.
THEN THAT AT LEAST IS ONE OF THE
PUBLIC POLICY ELEMENTS THAT WE
CAN DEPEND ON WHEN WE GET SUED.
SO I'LL BE HONEST WITH YOU THAT
IT'S IF THAT IS THE DIRECTION
THE LEGISLATURE WHICH IS FOR US
TO GO.
YOU SHOULD.
TELL US WHERE AND WHEN WE SHOULD
USE THOSE OF THOSE NEW --
KINDS OF AUTHORITIES WHEN TO
EXPEDITE PROCESSES WINTER
ACTUALLY GO.
IN A DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
THE OTHER ALTERNATIVE IS WHAT --
WHAT --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN SUGGESTED
WHICH IS THAT MAYBE THERE ARE
OTHER VENUES WHERE THESE THINGS
ARE DECIDED AS A MATTER OF
PUBLIC POLICY AND THAT IT'S UP
TO US TO IMPLEMENT.
STILL WILL TAKE SOME TIME
BECAUSE IT MEANS TO IMPLEMENT
THINGS YOU GOTTA HAVE PEOPLE IF
IT'S NEW.
HE GOT TO HAVE THEM TRAINED YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THE
STEPS.
BUT I THINK THAT THAT.
I DON'T DISAGREE WITH YOU THAT
IT'S A LONG TEDIOUS PROCESS ALL
I'VE DISCOVERED IS THAT THAT'S
THE WAY WE WORK DESIGN.
THAT WAS PURPOSEFUL.
YOU WANT TO CHANGE IT
[inaudible]
JACK.
I'M JUST CONCERNED I DON'T WANNA
BE HERE FIVE YEARS FROM NOW
[inaudible]
WHEN?
MILLIONS OF MORE ACRES MAYBE OF
BURNING CALIFORNIA AND MANY MANY
MORE LIVES OF LOS WONDERING WHAT
THE HECK ARE WE DOING SO I
PROJECT MY PASSION BUT NO I LIVE
THIS IS MY DISTRICT GASES WERE
FORTY FOUR PEOPLE. FORTY FOR MY
CONSTITUENTS DIE.
AND I'M I DON'T WANT TO SEE
ANYMORE DOT WEIRD I WATCHED FOR
FOUR YEARS --
LITIGANTS PARTIES IN OUR
PROCEEDINGS ARGUING ABOUT WHAT
IS THE PROPER LIFE SPAN OF
WOODEN POLES IT FORTY YEARS
SERVICES SEVENTY YEARS WHETHER
THE CRITERIA USED TO TO TO
EVALUATE WHETHER WHERE UNDER
UNDER WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES YOU
SHOULD YOU SHOULD EVALUATE IT
DIFFERENTLY.
THAT SEEMS LIKE COULD BE A
SIMPLE QUESTION.
BUT I GOTTA TELL YOU THEIR WORK
PANEL LIKE THE TAX COURTS WERE
KINDA LIKE --
THE ADMIRALTY COURTS WERE KINDA
LIKE THE PATENT COURTS AND I
WILL REMIND YOU THAT THE
ADMIRALTY COURTS ARE STILL
LITIGATING WHETHER THE SPANISH
ADMIRAL MADE A MISTAKE GOING TO
THE WEST SIDE OF SCOTLAND AFTER
HE GOT.
BEAT BY THE BY DRAKE AND AND
ENGLISH CHANNEL.
SO THOSE THINGS.
YOU MAY WANT NOT WANT TO KIND OF
JUDICIAL BODY THAT WE WE WE FORM
BUT IN OTHER CASES THERE SEEMS
TO BE A PREFERENCE TO HAVE US
PARTICULAR IN THINKS INVOLVED
EXPENDITURES OF MONEY.
DO WE HAVE STANDARDS ON POLLS.
WE HAVE STANDARDS ON POLLS BUT
THE HOW DO YOU BEGIN TO APPLY
THEM WITH FOR ME AND PULLS DO
YOU DO IT ON A HIGH EVERY SIX
MONTHS BASIS DO YOU DO IT ON A
FIVE YEAR BASIS DO IT ON A TEN
YEAR BASIS IN INVASIVE
INSPECTION.
USUALLY DONE EVERY FIVE TO TEN
YEARS DEPENDING UPON WHERE THE
LOCATION.
BUT POLLS TEND TO BE FAIRLY LONG
LYFT OBJECTS I REMEMBER THAT A
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITY IN THE
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES TEND TO
ARGUE THAT THEY ARE NOT UNDER
OURS ARE SUPERVISION.
WHERE THE GENERAL MANAGER OF
LADWP SAID THAT POLL IS BENT
BECAUSE IT?
WAS PROLLY FIRST PLACED IN THAT
LOCATION WITH THOMAS EDISON
WALKED THE FACE OF YOUR SO DO WE
ABANDON THE VALUE OF A POLL THAT
STILL IS FUNCTIONAL.
WHERE DO WE DO WE TRY TO FOCUS
ON THE ONES THAT TRULY NEED
REPLACE?
I TEND TO ERR ON THE SIDE OF
SAFETY BUT THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT THERE'S AGREEMENT.
YES AND AND AT A CHRISTIAN AND I
UNDERSTAND THE PREDICAMENT THERE
APPRECIATE THAT.
DO WE HAVE NGUYEN STANDARDS ON
POLLS.
WE DO THEY'RE VERY COMPLICATED
AND I DON'T THINK THAT THAT THE
ASSUMPTIONS THAT WE MADE TWENTY
YEARS AGO THIRTY YEARS AGO STAND
UP TO THE KINDS OF CONDITIONS
THAT WE SAW IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA I CAN A LITTLE LEASE
OF ATTIC. TO GO INTO MUCH DEEPER
BUT BASICALLY LOOK AT ALL THE
EQUIPMENT CLEANING
TELECOMMUNICATIONS EQUIPMENT
THAT'S INSTALLED ON HE SAID.
MORE --
EQUIPMENTS ATTACHABLE CAN ACT
LIKE A SAIL WORK MORE WIRES THAT
PUT ON THAT PEOPLE CAN ACT LIKE
A SALE.
IT CAN RESULT IN BREAKAGE
OVERTOPPING.
AND I WILL SAY THAT IN SOME
CASES WE KNOW.
THAT SOME FIRES RESULT IS IS.
FROM INAPPROPRIATE WERE POORLY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE ON A WOODEN POLE.
WE GENERALLY HOLD ELECTROCUTED
FOR MANAGING THAT BUT AS I SAID.
SOMETIMES THEY DO THE RIGHT
THING.
IN THESE OTHER UTILITIES DON'T
FOLLOW UP IN A TIMELY FASHION
I'VE SEEN BUDDY PULLS THOSE
POLLS WHERE THE ELECTRIC UTILITY
REPLACES THE PAUL.
BUT THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE PEOPLE DIDN'T
SHOW UP ON THE SAME DAY THEY
DIDN'T SHOW UP TWO WEEKS LATER.
SEE HITS HITS SOMETIMES TWO
YEARS LATER BEFORE YOU FINALLY
START TO SEE THE TELECOM
PROVIDER SH CHAU WHAT. TO DO ALL
OF THEIR WARES SOMETIMES.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE FROM [inaudible]
HOLD [inaudible]
PHONE SERVICE.
OLD CABLE SERVICE NEW PHONE
COMPANY SERVICE THAT'S BOTH
INTERNET CONTENT AND THE
TELEPHONE.
AND THEN CABLE COMPANY.
ALL MORE WHERE YOU SEE SOME OF
THE WIRES HAVE BEEN TRANSFERRED
BUT NOT ALL OF SO.
THE UTILITY CAN CONSUME.
BUT THEY CAN'T.
WE CAN'T UNILATERALLY MOVE OTHER
PEOPLE'S EQUIPMENT.
IF YOU AND I AND DESPITE MY
FINAL QUESTION IS ON CHEAT IN
THIS TO CHEAP OR FIRST WELL I
THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING THAT
YOU OR YOUR STAFF HAS DONE.
THROUGHOUT THE FIRES I SPENT A
WHOLE LOT OF TIME WITH CAL FIRE
PERSONNEL.
OVER THE OVER IN OCTOBER AND
SUBSEQUENTLY I APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING YOU GUYS DO.
THERE MAY SEEM CREWS ON THE
GROUND AND ALL THE MUTUAL AID
EVERYTHING ABSOLUTELY AMAZING SO
THANK YOU I KNOW YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH A LOT.
YOU NEVER EVEN GOT A BREAK MEANS
THE FIRE SEASON IS CONTINUED
ON CONSTANTLY SINCE --
SINCE LAST YEAR AND AND I SO --
DO WE HAVE ANY SORT OF AN
ESTIMATE ON WHEN WE'RE GOING TO
GET THE REPORT ON THE TABS FIRE
--
LIKE I SAID IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS I FEEL LIKE WE'RE
OPERATING.
WITH A FEW CARDS MISSING FROM
THE DECK AND I THINK IT'S I
THINK IT.
I'M NOT AYE I'M CONCERNED THAT
THERE'S INFORMATION THAT WE
WON'T BE CONSIDERING HERE AS WE
GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS IT THAT
IT REPORT IS A FORTHCOMING
FAIRLY SOON.
WELL THANK YOU FOR ASKING THAT
QUESTION --
YEAH WE WE DO HAVE A OF OF THE
TWENTY SEVEN PLUS FIRES THAT
OCCURRED IN OCTOBER DURING THAT
FIRE SIEGE --
MEMBER --
WOULD WE WE DEFINITELY HAVE --
COME TO CONCLUSION ON MOST OF
THEM.
AND I'M SURE YOU'RE AWARE THAT
--
APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN OF THOSE
HAVE BEEN REFERRED --
TO DISTRICT ATTORNEYS FOR
DETERMINATION ON ON MOVING THEM
FORWARD.
THEN THAT LEGAL SO --
AND THEN THERE ARE TWO THAT ARE
SET OUTSTANDING OF WHICH ONE OF
THOSE IS THE TUBS.
AND OF THE TUBS IS A VERY
DIFFICULT --
SITUATION --
WE COME ACROSS THEM ON OCCASION
--
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT THE
THOMAS FIRE IS BEING IS IS
PROVING TO BE DIFFICULT AS WELL
EVEN THOUGH THAT'S THAT'S IN --
THE THE COUNTY OF VENTURA US
JURISDICTION --
THE DIFFICULTY IS THAT NAILING
DOWN THE ACT EXACT BECAUSE CAN
BE VERY TEDIOUS AND SO.
WITH REGARD TO THE TUBS WE ARE
GOING THROUGH THE EVIDENCE
METHODICALLY.
AND WE'RE TESTING AND RETESTING
--
THE EVIDENCE THAT WE HAVE.
A SOME OF THAT'S OUT FOR THIRD
PARTY WE CURRENTLY AND I DON'T
HAVE FOR YOU --
WHAT YOU WANT IT BEING THAT DATE
OR A TIME FRAME THAT THAT --
REPORT WILL BE [inaudible]
THE COMPLETE --
WE ARE WORKING METHODICALLY AND
VERY DILIGENTLY TO GET THAT DONE
[inaudible]
TRICKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AB MISTER DOUGLAS DO YOU KNOW.
WE IS DESCRIBED IT THE AID
PROGRAM IN SAN DIEGO THAT HAS
BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE.
WHAT WAS THE NECESSARY
INVESTMENT TO GET YOU TO WHERE
YOU ARE NOW?
WELL WHEN WE LOOK HOLISTICALLY
THROUGH OUR AND THROUGH THE
TECHNOLOGY.
THE ENHANCEMENT OF THE
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS --
VAST ENGINEERING.
PROJECTS --
AND EXTENSIVE CUSTOMER OUTREACH
ITS BEEN OVER A BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT --
ALREADY --
OVER THE LAST DECADE OR SO
[inaudible]
IS.
WHAT YOU HAVE DONE IN SAN DIEGO
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE DONE
STATEWIDE?
IT WOULD THERE'S VERY DIFFERENT
TOPOGRAPHIES AND I'D DIFFERENT
FACTORS --
IS THAT WOULD BE APPLIED
STATEWIDE SO WOULD HAVE TO BE
TAKEN REGION BY REGION TO TO
LOOK AT ITS APPLICABILITY.
ON IN DIFFERENT AREAS.
THE RESULT HAS BEEN SOMETHING
THAT HAS BEEN EFFECTIVE.
THE RESULTS IN SAN DIEGO --
YES I FEEL THAT THROUGH THE
COLLABORATION THROUGH THE
TECHNOLOGY AND WE'VE HAD A LOT
OF SUCCESS AT MITIGATING --
OUR FIRE RISK.
SHOULD BE SOMETHING THAT YOU
WOULD RECOMMEND BE LOOKED AT FOR
THE REST OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
YOU STARTED TO TALK IN RESPONSE
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAS QUESTION
--
OR ONE OF THE IN ONE OF THE
ARTICLES FROM LA TIMES.
VERY FIRST SENTENCE READS DOWNED
POWER LINES AND SPARKING
ELECTRIC.
ELECTRICAL EQUIPMENT IGNITED
MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S RECENT
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES.
WHAT IS THE METHODOLOGY WHAT IS
THE PROCESS OF DETERMINING THE
CAUSE OF A FIRE ONE OF THE
FACTORS YOU CONSIDERED?
REYES --
WHILE I AM NOT A CERTIFIED
INVESTIGATOR OF SUCH --
WHAT WE DO IS WE IDENTIFY
INDICATORS --
INITIALLY OF AFTER A FIRE BURNS
CERTAIN CHARACTERISTICS HAPPEN
TO DIFFERENT PLANETS AND
DIFFERENT --
ELEMENTS THAT ARE BURNED YOU CAN
IDENTIFY AND DIRECT BACK TO A
POINT OF ORIGIN SO WE'RE TRYING
TO DETERMINE WHAT THAT POINT OF
ORIGIN IS.
ONCE WE DETERMINED THAT THEN THE
POINT OF ORIGIN IS SEARCHED FOR
ANY POSSIBLE CAUSE FOR THAT --
AND THAT AND WE WE WEEK IT'S A
PROCESS OF ELIMINATION --
WE DETERMINE WHAT WAS NOT THE
CAUSE --
CHECK THOSE BOXES OFF UNTIL WE
GET -- TO
HANDFUL OR A POSSIBLE SINGLE.
THIS IS WHAT CAUSED THE FIRE --
IF THERE'S A DEVICE IN THERE IN
THE CASE OF AN ARSON --
THAT CAN BE IDENTIFIED OUT WOULD
BE --
BECAUSE SOMETIMES WE CAN'T FIND
THE CAR SOMETIME ME SO --
IT'S A ROADSIDE [inaudible]
ACTUAL.
BECAUSE THAT WE CAN IDENTIFY.
IT'S CLEAR THEM THAT IT IS A
VERY DETAILED PROCESS WHEN YOU
FIND.
OR WHEN YOU PUBLICLY STATE.
THAT AN ENTITY OR IT ARSONIST
HAS CAUSED THE FIRE.
YOU'VE GONE THROUGH QUITE A
PROCEDURE BEFORE YOU HAVE COME
TO THAT CONCLUSION.
THAT IS CORRECT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IT IN THANK YOU IT.
AT THAT WITH PEARCY --
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU HAVE.
THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
REQUIREMENTS YOU OF YOUR PLANS.
HOW OFTEN ARE THOSE VIOLATED BY
THE UTILITIES --
SO WE HAVE EXTENSIVE --
REQUIREMENTS FOR OVERHEAD AND ON
THE GROUND.
ELECTRIC EQUIPMENTS.
AND WE CONDUCT AUDIT AND
INCIDENTS INVESTIGATIONS --
THE FREQUENCY IS.
HOME.
IT REALLY RANGES EL IN TERMS ALL
OF THEM.
KHOMEINI EL VIOLATIONS WERE
POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS THERE ARE.
NO.
THEY ALSO RANGE IN THERE WELL
SEVERITY AND IMPACTS SO ON
SAFETY CERTAIN EXAMPLE OF THAT
I'D IS EVERY WELL PULL IS
REQUIRED TO HAVE A HIGH VOLTAGE
SIGN.
ALL ON ITS OWN THE FREQUENTLY
FALL OFF PEOPLE SOMETIMES LIKE
TO USE THEM AS TARGET PRACTICE
ALL KINDS OF THINGS.
SO IT CAN BE TECHNICALLY A
VIOLATION BUT IT'S A MISSILE IN
HIGH VOLTAGE SIGN IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO FOR
EXAMPLE SPARKED A FIRE.
SO IT'S THE DIFFICULT QUESTION
--
TO ANSWER IN TERMS OF L.
FREQUENCY.
HOME BUT IT'S THOUGH WE HAVE THE
EL.
IN THE EXTENT SO --
PROGRAM TO LOOK FOR WELL
VIOLATIONS OF POTENTIAL
VIOLATIONS AND ENSURE.
THAT UTILITIES CORRECT THE HOME
AND IN CASES WHEN THEY DO NOT
THAT WE SEEK UP ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS.
HOW WOULD YOU ASSESS THE STRAIN
THEM THE EFFECTIVENESS?
OF YOUR CURRENT STANDARDS.
IF IF YOU SAY HERE'S A PLAN THEN
HERE'S WHAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
DO IT ISN'T DONE.
GIVE THEM FIND THE UTILITIES BUT
HOW EFFECTIVE IS THAT.
YEAH HER HISTORY IS AS ECONOMIC
REGULATOR AND SO WHEN WHEN WE
GET TO SAFETY WE FREQUENTLY USE
THE SAME KINDS OF TOOLS SO WE'LL
DO AUDITS.
AND THEN WE'LL DO SPOT CHECKS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE THAT THE
PROGRAMS THAT THE UTILITY HAS IN
PLACE IN THE REPORTS THEY HAVE
ON THEIR THEIR ACTIVITIES
ACTUALLY MATCH UP.
TO TO WHAT WE SEE WHEN WE GO OUT
AND DO THOSE THE SPOT CHECKS.
WHO FREE CALL WE DO THAT BASED
ON -- THE
THE KIND OF A INDUSTRY RAIL IS
--
IT WE WERE REQUIRED BY LAW TO DO
A MUCH DIFFERENT KIND OF
INSPECTION PROCESS AND WE DO
WITH FOUR MILLION POLLS.
SO FRANKLY I THINK THAT ONE OF
THE THINGS WE'RE PROBABLY GONNA
HAVE TO DO START TO RELY AND
TECHNOLOGY.
SO OUR REALIST BACKERS FOR
EXAMPLE GO OUT EVERY YEAR HE
LOOK AT EVERY FOOT OF TRACK AND
THE CARRY LITTLE MIRROR SO THEY
CAN LOOK AT THE UNDERSIDE OF THE
TRACK TO SEE IF THERE ARE
CRACKS.
ARE DE FEDERAL RAILWAY
ADMINISTRATION HAS A HIGH TECH
LOCOMOTIVES THEY CAN ACTUALLY
ROLL THAT SAME TRACK.
DUE TO THREE TIMES A YEAR AND
TAKES IMAGING.
SOPHISTICATED ELECTRO --
MAGNETIC IMAGING THAT CAN DETECT
THE CRACKS IN THE LOGO I DO THIS
INSPECTION.
I THINK WHEN IT COMES TO REALLY
MONITORING THESE BROTHERS WE
HAVE TO GET TO THE POINT WHERE
WE HAVE DRONES WITH WHITE ARE.
THE GENIE IS CURRENTLY USING TO
ACTUALLY MANAGE SOME OF THEIR
VEGETATION.
AND THEN PATTERN RECOGNITION
SOFTWARE SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
LOOK AT THE EQUIPMENT SIGN THAT
PULL AND THEY RELATE IT BACK TO
THAT DATABASE FOR TRYING TO BILL
TO UNDERSTAND.
WHO IS SUPPOSED TO BE THERE AND
IF SOMETHING SHOWS UP THAT'S NOT
THERE IN THE DATE PATTERN
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE --
DOESN'T RECOGNIZE.
BUT THIS IS A CHALLENGE FOR
STATE GOVERNMENT --
TO ACTUALLY USE TECHNOLOGY ON
THAT LEVEL AND PARTICULARLY TO
START DE TO GET TO THAT HIGH
LEVEL OF ALMOST ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE TO DO THE
RECOGNITION OF BOTH OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WHAT'S ON IT.
AND VEGETATION.
BUT I THINK THAT'S THE DIRECTION
THEY WERE HEADED.
IF THIS IS SOMETHING YOU FEEL
WOULD BE HELPFUL HOUSE THAT
PROPOSAL BEEN MADE.
JUST FORCED BUDGET AS SOON AS I
SAW THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL I
THOUGHT THAT'S WHERE WE HAVE TO
GO.
BUT I THINK THAT IS GOING TO BE
A BUILDING PROCESS.
THIS YOU WELL KNOW.
AGENCIES DON'T GET TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS ARE ON THEIR OWN THEY
HAVE TO GO THROUGH CAL I. T.. TO
ACTUALLY GET PERMISSION TO
DEVELOP THINKS I HAVE A NAP ON
MY PHONE THAT WE THAT WE
DEVELOPED.
AT CPUC SO PEOPLE COULD TAKE A
PICTURE.
OF A POLL VIOLATION AND WOOD
AUTOMATICALLY UPLOAD --
TO TO THE CPUC.
BUT WE CANNOT GET.
KIND OF DATABASE AND THE SERVERS
THAT WE NEED TO ACTUALLY MANAGE
THOSE THINGS AND BEGIN TO TURN
IT INTO AN ENFORCEMENT TOOL.
BUT YOU ALREADY KNOW FOR SURE
THAT THERE ARE MANY.
REQUIREMENTS.
THAT HAVE BEEN IN MANY PLANS
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED WHERE
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN COMPLIED WITH
WE ALREADY KNOW THAT.
CORRECT.
AND THAT THE UTILITIES ALREADY
BEEN FINED.
AND EVEN AFTER THEY'RE FINE
THEY'RE STILL NOT CORRECTING IT
IS THAT STILL HAPPENING.
WE GENERALLY OF A MIDDLE
DEFERRED TO TO TO KNOW HE'S VERY
WE DO NOTICES OF VIOLATION WE
DON'T HAVE THAT CITATION
AUTHORITY FOR THE TELCO
COMPANIES HOWEVER SO IT REALLY
IS A MUCH MORE DIFFICULT.
KIND OF A PROCESS SO WE'RE
TRYING TO DEVELOP --
THE THE TOOLS THAT WE NEED TO
ACTUALLY GET THE OTHER UTILITIES
UNDER COMPLIANCE.
BUT I THINK THERE WILL WE FIND
OF VEGETATION MANAGEMENT ISSUE
WE REQUIRE CORRECTION.
AND IF THERE ISN'T SPEEDY
CORRECTION WE TRIED ESCALATED TO
CITATION.
CITATION IF WE FIND A PATTERN
THEN WE MOVE IT TO AN
INVESTIGATION.
BUT LIKE A LOT OF ENFORCEMENT.
DO YOU ACT WHEN LIGHTNING
STRIKES.
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT LIKE EVERY.
POLICE DEPARTMENT KNOWS EVERY
DRUG TRANSACTION WAS TAKING
PLACE.
SOMETIMES IN THE CATCH PEOPLE IN
THE LIVE.
SO I'M JUST SAYING THAT WITH
FOUR MILLION POLES MILLIONS OF
MILES.
OF PHONE.
FILE WIRES AND AND MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF TREES WHO.
THE THE EXPENDITURE AND THE
AMOUNT OF OF HUMAN LABOR THAT IT
WOULD TAKE TO DO THAT IS
EXTREME.
P. GENIE FOR EXAMPLE HAS THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
THE PGA THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION HAS ELEVEN TWELVE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES RIGHT ABOUT
NOW.
AND THAT'S SPLIT ACROSS A WHOLE
RANGE OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS SO
TO ACTUALLY MATCH THAT KIND OF
INSPECTION CAPABILITY.
WILL BE A CHALLENGE FOR US SO IN
THE MEANTIME WE DEPEND ON
AUDITS.
OR EVEN IN YOUR AUDIT SO YOU'RE
FINDING THAT THE COMPLIANCE IS
NOT THERE.
IS THAT CORRECT DO YOU GENERALLY
DON'T FIND COMPLIANCE IN ANY
PROGRAM TO BE PERFECT.
AND SO WHAT YOU NEED NOT NOT.
EXCUSE ME FOR INTERRUPTING SORRY
I'M NOT ASKING ABOUT PERFECTION
I KNOW YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT
RESPONSE JUST SO WE ARE
ESCALATING AT OWN FORCED NOBODY.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY.
WOULD REQUIRE PERFECTION BUT I
THINK THAT HAVING A RESPONSE IT
IF SOMEONE IS NOT IN COMPLIANCE
AND YOU YOU THEN.
ARE GOING TO FIND THEM
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL NOW
INCREASES THE PENALTIES
SUBSTANTIALLY.
AND PART OF THAT IS BECAUSE IF
THE PENALTIES THAT DO YOU OR
HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO A CELLS
ARE NOT ENOUGH TO GET THE
CORRECTIVE ACTION.
THAT PERHAPS YOU NEED MORE OF A
PENALTY IS THAT GOING TO BE OF
HELP TO YOU.
I THINK IT WILL.
I THINK THAT WE'VE BEEN TOLD BY
FEDERAL AGENCIES FOR EXAMPLE IN
GAS --
PIPELINE MANAGEMENT THERE ARE
ARE ARE PENALTIES ARE UNDER WHAT
THEY EXPECT THEM TO BE.
BUT THOSE LEVELS ARE SET BY THE
LEGISLATURE SO WE'VE ACTUALLY
ASKED ABOUT RAISING THOSE A
NUMBER OF TIMES.
I SUSPECT TO BE HONEST WITH YOU
THAT THERE WILL BE A LOT OF
OPPOSITION TO INCREASING THE
PENALTIES BECAUSE WE WOULD APPLY
THOSE THE TELEPHONE COMPANIES AS
WELL SO THE ELECTRICAL COME.
I WOULD BE VERY SURPRISED IF
THERE ISN'T DUH CONCERN ON THE
PART OF THESE OTHER UTILITIES.
OKAY SAID THEY IT'S TO
ABSOLUTELY TRUE THAT THE TELCOS
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN WILL
FAILURES.
AND THEN MY LAST.
QUESTION MORE MORE SO COMMENT.
WHEN --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD WAS ASKING
ABOUT THE PROCEDURE AND EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AND STILL.
NOTHING HAS HAPPENED
[inaudible]
IT.
I REALIZE THAT THE YOUR COMMENT
YOUR RESPONSE WAS THE
LEGISLATURE'S ONE SETS THE
STANDARD.
IF THERE IS A PROBLEM WITH
SOMETHING.
WE WOULD LOOK TO YOU TO TELL US
WHAT NEEDS TO BE CORRECTED.
OR CHANGED SO SOMETHING IS
HOLDING UP THE PROCESS WERE
EXPECTING IT TO BE. TO TAKE WILL
WHO RUN ITS COURSE AND COME UP
WITH EVERITT DOES SOLUTION AT
THE END IF THERE IS SOMETHING
THAT IS CAUSING A PROBLEM OR
CAUSING.
THE PROCESS TO SLOW.
THIS DOESN'T EVEN SOUND LIKE
IT'S SLOWING DOWN SOUNDS LIKE
IT'S ALMOST STOPPED.
I DON'T I TRULY I WOULD
ABSOLUTELY I DID I WOULD
PERSONALLY SAY WE WOULD ALL I
WOULD WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU
ABOUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE CHANGED
SO THAT WE CAN THEN LOOK TO SEE.
WHAT WE DO TO HELP YOU DO THE
JOB THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE BY THE
P. YOU SEE?
ABSOLUTELY WE RAISED A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES AND REFORM BILLS OF
SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
SENATOR HILL ACTUALLY --
RESPONDED ON ON ONE OF THOSE
ISSUES AND GAVE US A A PROCESS
TO BEGIN IN LINE ON ONE OF OUR
THREE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PROCEEDINGS.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO TO PERFECT
THE I DON'T KNOW LAW WHICH THAT
WOULD INCLUDE WHAT CATEGORY THIS
SPECIFIC --
ON TWEAK THE YOU WANTED TO MAKE
FELL.
BUT I'LL JUST SAY THAT YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU HAVE.
A SETTING WHERE EVERYBODY HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A VOICE
AND EQUAL VOICE BEFORE A
DECISION MAKER.
DEMOCRACY IS THE GOAL OF
DEMOCRACY HAS NEVER BEEN
EFFICIENCY AND SPEED.
BUT DEMOCRACY ALSO REQUIRES THAT
WE COME TO A SOLUTION AND IF
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO COME TO A
SOLUTION THE WE HAVE TO FIX.
A PROCESS WHICH STILL HAVE
DEMOCRACY AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
CHANGE THAT BUT IF THERE'S A
PROBLEM WITH THE PROCESS WE'VE
GOT TO FIX THE PROCESS SO WE
ACTUALLY DO.
GET DEMOCRACY WILL BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOUR OFFICE TO GO OVER
SOME OF THE PROPOSALS THAT
REJECTED BY IN THE LEGISLATURE
LAST TIME AROUND I LOOK FORWARD.
TO SO THERE WERE SOME.
THANK YOU EN.
I JUST WANNA THANK ALL ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE PANEL SO SPOKE
TODAY AND IN AND RAISE SOME OF
THESE CONCERNS I THINK THAT I
THINK FOR THE NEXT STEP.
YOU KNOW I'D LIKE TO SEE US
FOCUS ON WHAT WHAT WHAT THIS
COMMITTEE INTENDS TO WORK ON AND
REALLY BRING THOSE SOLUTIONS THE
FOREFRONT HAVE THOSE BE
DISCUSSED BECAUSE I MEAN.
WEEK THAT AS AS MISTER WAR A
MINIATURE AND THE A
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION TO THESE
FIRE WHAT LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN GO
VERY FAR INTO LAND USE.
INTO WHERE WE BILL HOW WE BUILD
WHAT CODES.
ABOUT REQUIRE OF PEOPLE IN
CONSTRUCTION AND WHAT IS
REQUIRED OF THE UTILITIES IN
TERMS OF WHAT POLLS WERE GOING
TO USE WHAT KIND OF POWER WE'RE
GONNA.
SITE AND WHAT LOCATIONS WHERE WE
WILL ALLOW PEOPLE TO CONTINUE TO
BE CONNECTED TO UTILITIES YOU'RE
GOING TO LIVE.
IN A VERY HIGH FAT FIRE HAZARD
AREA WILL.
WILL WE EVEN SHOULD WE EVEN
ALLOW PEOPLE LIVE THERE AND IF
THEY DO LIVE THERE.
SHOULD THEY SHOULD WE HAVE POWER
LINES EXTENDING. TO THOSE PARTS
OF THE STATE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THAT.
ENGINEERING WISE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITIONS TODAY
S. MR PICKER STE NAY STATED.
ARE VERY DIFFERENT TODAY THAN
THEY WERE A HUNDRED YEARS AGO
THAT NECESSITATE.
DIFFERENT KIND OF WIRES
DIFFERENT KIND POLLS.
AND SO SO.
I MEAN I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
TODAY I MEAN I I CAN I CAN ASK
VERY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS.
ON ON MANY OF THE DIFFERENT
PRESENTATION BUT IN THE END WHAT
WHAT WE I THINK WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO NEED US LEGISLATURE.
MISTER BEGIN THE FOCUS ON THE
MOST URGENT.
ISSUES I I UNDERSTAND BIOMASS
PLANTS.
AND HOW THEY CAN BE AN IMPORTANT
SOURCE OF A SOLVING THIS
PROBLEM.
BUT IT'S NOT THE CHEAPEST WAY TO
MANAGE.
BRUSH AND WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
MILLION DEAD TREES BECAUSE JUST
BY THE DROUGHT [inaudible]
THAT WAS.
THAT'S JUST IN THE SIERRA HIGH
FOR US THAT IS THAT DOESN'T
COVER THE WILD OAK WOODLAND
PROBLEM OR DIE MANAGEMENT AND
WE'RE SANDRA MAINLY PINE TREES.
THE ONES THAT ARE MOST
COMBUSTIBLE [inaudible]
GENERALLY.
WELL I UNLESS A RELISH VERY
COMBUSTIBLE WAS AND BUT THAT'S
NOT INCLUDED I'M JUST TALKING
ABOUT THE HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
MILLION TREES.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
BRUSH OR THE THE THE THE THE
GROUND FLOOR OF THE FOREST WHICH
IF WE JUST FOCUSED ON THE GROUND
FLOOR THAT WOULD BE [inaudible]
EXORBITANTLY EXPENSIVE.
THAT NEVER MIND THE TREES THAT
ARE ARE STANDING AND THEN NEVER
MIND.
YOU KNOW THE POLLS THE
ENGINEERING WISE ARE NOT.
BUT WHAT THEY NEED TO BE. TO
WITHSTAND WINDS AND FIRES AND
EXTREME RAIN EVENTS.
SO WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT TRYING
TO PUT A PRICE TAG ON THE WHOLE
I MEAN WE CAN TALK ABOUT
PROCESS.
I WAS ON THE SENDING A CITY
COUNCIL AND UP THE COAST
COMMISSION AT THE SAME TIME.
THE CITY WAS TRYING TO CREATE
NEW REGULATIONS FOR BRUSH
MANAGEMENT WE WE HAD TO GO
THROUGH THE COASTAL COMMISSION
TO GET THESE APPROVED.
AND THE COULD NOT CLOSE THE
COMMISSION COMMISSION DENIED OUR
APPLICATION SO IT TOOK.
YEARS FOR US TO ACTUALLY GET.
A BRUSH MANAGEMENT PLAN FOR THE
CITY.
AND AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE FOUND CENTER WHICH AT FIRST
PEOPLE LAUGHED AT IT'S A
LAUGHABLE THING YOU CAN SAY
WE'RE GONNA USE GOATS. TO MANAGE
OUR BRUSHES SENEGAL AND SAN
DIEGO IN A CITY LIKE MANY PEOPLE
RESPONDED. TO THAT PLANET
LAUGHTER BUT ACTUALLY BEEN IT
WAS ACTUALLY ONE OF THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE.
AND MOST EFFECTIVE TOOLS AT
TREATING BRUSH.
IN RESIDENTIAL AND OPEN SPACE
VERY.
AND THEN IT ENDED UP BEING BUT
THE COAST COMMISSION DIDN'T LIKE
PUTTING.
GOATS INSENSITIVE HABITAT.
SO I MEAN THERE THERE ARE NO
REAL CONSIDERATIONS.
THAT --
OREGON --
BRING CONFLICT TO THIS DEBATE IN
THE STATE CAN JUST COME AND SAY
WE'RE GONNA AVOID.
FORGET ABOUT SENSE OF HABITAT WE
WERE GONNA IGNORE IT NOW BECAUSE
OF FIRES SO DO ANYTHING ANYONE
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE JUST I
MEAN WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT.
REGULATIONS A PROCESS YOU CAN'T
JUST COME IN AND STEP ON CERTAIN
THINGS THAT ARE ALSO VERY
IMPORTANT [inaudible]
SO.
HAVING THE LOCALS ENGAGE IN A
LOCAL PROGRAM IS VERY EXPECT A
VERY IMPORTANT.
HAVE BEEN THE MANAGER LOCAL
PROGRAMS VERY IMPORTANT AND THEN
THE STATE CAN COME IN AND
SUPPLANT AND THAT'S WHERE I I
THINK THIS THIS HEARING WILL BE
VERY HELPFUL GETTING PEOPLE TO
ENGAGE IN SAY YES.
THIS IS WHAT WE CAN PROVIDE THIS
IS WHAT WOULD THE STATE I DON'T
THINK AND THINK WE'LL FIX EVERY
PROBLEM IS IT'LL JUST BE
[inaudible]
JUST.
COST PROHIBITIVE TO COME TO THE
CP A SECOND FIX EVERY PROBLEM --
CAL FIRE FIX EVERY PROBLEM.
UTILITIES YOU NEED A FIX EVERY
PROBLEM.
BUT WE CAN ALL.
ALL AS A COMMITTEE AND THERE AS
A COMMUNITY PROPOSE.
THE MOST IMMEDIATE SOLUTIONS TO
THE MOST PRESSING PROBLEMS THAT
COULD HELP US AT LEAST.
YOU KNOW A ADDRESS.
A MAKE THESE WILDFIRES LESS
DESTRUCTIVE.
MAKE THE STATE MORE PREPARED TO
RESPONSE IN CASE OF A VERY.
CATASTROPHIC EVENT.
WHAT DO WE NEED HAVE A PLACE AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON A FEW
BILLS THIS YEAR?
THAT I THINK WILL BE HELPFUL.
BUT I THINK AT SOME POINT THIS
COMMITTEES GONNA HAVE TO GET
TOGETHER PRIORITIZE AND SAY
THESE ARE GOING TO BE THE
ISSUES.
THEIR MOST IMPORTANT ON THIS AND
WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS ON THAT ME
WE HAVE. FOR WEEKS TO WORK ON ON
ON A MAJOR LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE
AND FROM THAT OUT I WAS HOPING
THAT WE COULD START TO FOCUS.
NOW ON WHAT THE SOLUTIONS ARE
GOING TO BE.
AND AND MAYBE EVEN THE CREATE
WORKING GROUPS IN DIFFERENT
AREAS THAT MAY.
SPILL INTO LAND USE --
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION --
AND AND INSURANCE ME WE STATE WE
SET A CODE ON SHARON'S.
AND THAT ME JUST BECAUSE ARISE.
IN WHAT INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE
WHAT WHAT ONCE YOU SET
REQUIREMENT. TO TO USE A CERTAIN
METHOD.
OR A CERTAIN PRODUCT.
THAT IS GOING TO CREATE.
OUT OF OUTNUMBER DON'T BE A
MARKET ADJUSTMENT AND THAT MAY
JUST BE HOW BY CREATING A RULE
WE CREATE.
AND INCREASED THE RATE PAYERS
THAT WE DON'T NECESSARILY WANT.
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO FIND
A WAY TO DO THIS MOST
EFFICIENTLY AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE THAT RATEPAYERS ARE NOT
[inaudible]
HARM -- TO
OR OR THAT WE LOOK AFTER REPAIRS
IN EVERY DECISION WE MAKE
BECAUSE I MIGHT HAVE MAY HAVE.
I AN IMPACT ON RATE FAIRS I JUST
COULD.
IN TURN ALSO DEVASTATE OUR OUR
ECONOMY AND DEVASTATE --
YOU KNOW THE POOR.
HIS MILITARY TO THE POOR
PEOPLE'S ABILITIES SAYING
CALIFORNIA.
AND AND HOW.
AND HOUSING.
WE KNOW WHERE WE CITED THE THE
REASON WHY WE'RE HAVING SPRAWLS
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT THAT IT'S A
FINE OUR URBAN CENTERS WIFE
BECAUSE IT'S IT'S JUST
POLITICALLY --
YOU KNOW I IT'S NOT POLITICALLY
SMART. TO TO GO AGAINST WHAT
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES ONE
ARKHAM PEOPLE CALIFORNIA DO NOT
WANT DENSITY IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THAT'S WHY
ZONING.
HAS NOT CHANGED IF NOT WE HAVE
DOWN SO WE'VE GONE FROM.
ALLOWING A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
UNITS OF ZONING DOWN TILL A
LESSON THAT'S IN THE LAST THIRTY
YEARS WHICH IS MADE.
SO I MEAN THAT EVERYTHING IS
RELATED.
WHERE EVERYTHING IS RELATED WE
CAN'T IGNORE THOSE AREAS BUT I
THINK AS THIS COMMITTEE WE NEED
TO FOCUS?
WHAT THAT'S GOING TO BE AND?
WE HAVE THE EXPERTS HERE THAT
COULD LEND.
SOME SUGGESTIONS AS TO WHAT WE
SHOULD WORK ON AND AND I THINK
WE SHOULD.
GET STARTED ON ON ON ON WORKING
ON THAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ORNAMENT MISTER CHAIRS.
THEY'D YOU SENATOR --
POINTS WILL TAKE HIM AND WE ARE.
COLLABORATE INSIST TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY AN ARCHITECT WITH THE
NEXT MEETING WILL LOOK LIKE CAN
GET MORE INTO THE ISSUES YOU
DESCRIBE [inaudible]
CENTER SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRS AND LAW
I ALSO A WE ARE NEVER GOING TO
HAVE PERFECTION --
IN OUR PROCESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE
SHOULDN'T SEE BEST PRACTICES.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO.
YOU KNOW OFTEN LEAVES THE THE
COUNTRY AND SOMETIMES THE WORLD.
A AND A LOT OF INITIATIVES THAT
WE WE DEAL WITH --
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT BY THE
END OF THIS FOUR WEEK PROCESS
AND WE HAVE.
CHANGES IN PLACE THAT WILL
BETTER GUARANTEED WERE NOT GOING
TO SEE THIS SIGNIFICANT LOSS OF
LIFE AND PROPERTY THAT WE HAVE
WITNESSED --
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
AMOUNT TO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS I
JUST GET A ATTACKS THAT --
IDYLLWILD IS HAVING EVACUATIONS
NOW BECAUSE OF A WILDFIRE IN MY
DISTRICT SO --
MY SISTER LIVES IN OREGON THEIR
BAND AND WAS JUST TOLD HER HOUSE
SHE'S GOING TO HAVE TO
POTENTIALLY EVACUATE.
BECAUSE A FIRE SO --
I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS IF I MAY
MISTER CHAIR --
FIRST DUH. TO MR PICKLER THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION AND I
DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DO WHAT YOU
DO WITH THE NUMBER PLACE THAT
YOU HAVE.
AND THE RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
YOU HAVE CERTAINLY YOUR SCHOOL.
OF RESPONSIBILITY HAS BECOME.
MORE COMPLICATED --
OVERTIME NOT LESS COMPLICATED
OVERTIME --
AND YOU SAID ON A A FEW DO ABOUT
THE COMPLEXITIES OF PEOPLE
COHABITATING INFRASTRUCTURE ON
POLLS YOU MENTION TELECOM AS AN
EXAMPLE.
SO WHEN TELECOM WANTS TO COLLECT
KATE ON A HOLE IS THAT THE
REVIEW THAT YOU DO OR IS THAT A
REVIEW THAT THE UTILITY DOES IT
SUBMITS IT TO YOU. TO ENSURE
THAT.
I ASSUME THERE'S SOME --
GUIDELINES THAT THEY HAVE TO
FALL TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE.
ATTACH SAFELY THAT THEY DON'T.
CAUSE A FIRE HAZARD COULD YOU
JUST ELABORATE ON THAT A LITTLE
BIT FOR ME.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT COMPLEX IN
THIS DIFFERENT AROUND THE STATE
SO IN SAN DIEGO WHOSE --
GAS ELECTRIC SERVICE AREA THEY
PRETTY MUCH MAINTAIN THE PROCESS
IN HOUSE --
IN OTHER AREAS BECAUSE OF
COMPLAINTS THAT THE ELECTRIC
UTILITIES WERE SLOW --
AND REMEMBER PARTICULARLY AFTER
DEREGULATION IN
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND A HUNGER
TO SEE NEW TECHNOLOGIES BROUGHT
TO TO THEIR CUSTOMERS --
THE THEY'VE SHOPPED IT OUT SO
FOR EXAMPLE P. JEANNIE AND
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ACTION ACTUALLY GAVE UP TO THE
WHAT THEY CALL THE
COMMUNICATIONS SPACE. TO A TNT
AND THEY MANAGE.
THERE'S ARE ALSO VEHICLES THERE
WE CALL THE POLISH AUTHORITIES
WHO HAVE FOR MANY MANY MANY
DECADES SORT OF MANAGE THAT
PROCESS THEY COLLECT RENTS THEY
FREQUENTLY TRACK.
WHO'S DOING WHAT BUT THEY DON'T
THEIR PRIVATE ASSOCIATIONS THAT
ARE ESSENTIALLY PROVIDING A
SERVICE. TWO THE POLL.
ABOUT 9295% OF ALL THE POLLS
ROOM BY THE ELECTRIC UTILITIES.
BUT AGAIN.
THE LEGISLATURE ITSELF HAS BEEN
VERY CLEAR ABOUT USING THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE TO GET
TELECOMMUNICATIONS TO POPULATION
TO RUN THE SERVE.
SO WE PROVIDE A GRANT OF SERVICE
BECAUSE OF THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND.
THAT'S DESIGNED TO HELP GET
COMMUNITY DON'T HAVE HIGH SPEED
OR BROADBAND TO THE HOUSE.
AND THAT INFRASTRUCTURE HAS TO
GO ON POLLS SO THERE'S
COUNTERVAILING PRESSURES HERE.
AND DUH AND WHO DEVELOPS A
STANDARDS FOR THEM TO DEVELOP A
STANDARDS.
SO OF THE THE STANDARD O. FOR
WELL POOL OF LOOTING AND FOR THE
AT THE C. FOR ATTACHMENTS IS THE
SAME FOR ELECTRIC AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
AND IT'S WITHIN THE SCENE
SET OF REGULATIONS THAT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
ADOPTED [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND THIS BETTER ASSN.
NICE TO MEET YOU ARE YOU TALK
ABOUT THE NATIONAL ELECTRIC
SAFETY CODE.
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE A YEAR
INTIMATING THAT WE HAVE OUR OWN
CODE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
--
COULD YOU COMPARE CONTRAST THE
TWO JUST CALIFORNIA TAKE IT.
A A STEP IN A MUCH BETTER
DIRECTION AND YOU SEE AREAS
WHERE OUR CALIFORNIA.
ELECTRIC SAFETY CODE NEEDS TO
BE.
RADICALLY IMPROVE.
ALONG WITH Z. THOUGH
CALIFORNIA'S OVERHEAD FACILITIES
SO OF SAFETY REGULATIONS SCHOOL
GENERAL WOULD IN NINETY FIVE
IT'S THESE THE CPUC STANDARD
WHICH PREDATES THE NATIONAL
ELECTRIC SAFETY CODE.
I BELIEVE SO.
AND A IT IS SPECIFICALLY MORE
STRINGENT SOME OR ALL THE AREAS
SO THE RELIEF IT'S WILD FIRE
SAFETY.
HOMELESS VEGETATION CLEARANCE
REQUIRE --
AND POLLUTING CALCULATIONS OF
THE AREAS SPECIFICALLY WHERE THE
CALIFORNIA STANDARDS EXCEED THE
NATIONAL ELECTRIC SAFETY CODE.
WELL WE HAVE SEVERAL EL STUDIES
THAT COMPARE OF THE NATIONAL
ELECTRIC SAFETY CODE TO GENERAL
ORDER. NINETY FIVE OH WHEN WE
IDENTIFY SOME POTENTIAL AREAS SO
WE ARE AT THE DID GENERAL ORDER
NINETY FIVE CAN BE IMPROVED.
WELL WE AND THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE PROPOSED
THERE IS --
THERE'S BEEN AN ONGOING WORKING
GROUP EL FOR GENERAL ORDER
NINETY FIVE AND WE'VE HAD --
ALSO RULED PROCEEDINGS AT THE
COMMISSION WE CONTINUOUSLY AMEND
AND UPDATES --
THAT CALIFORNIA REGULATIONS IN
ORDER TO SOLVE MAJOR AMENDMENTS
TO IT JUST RECENTLY.
WELL ONE OF THEM WAS THE FIRE
THROAT MOPS THE WERE TALKING
ABOUT EARLIER HELD THE MAPS
THEMSELVES HAD ANOTHER --
COMMISSION DECISION.
AND THAT WAS ADOPTED SO WHAT
MORAL LESS CONCURRENTLY OR HOW
THE ELECTRIC CH T..
REQUIREMENTS --
OR DIFFERENCE DEPENDING ON THE
FIRE RISKS SO THAT WAS A BIG
AMENDMENTS A TO GENERAL ORDER IN
NINETY FIVE A TO HELP MAKE IT
MORE STRINGENT IN THE AREAS OF
HIGH FIRE THREATS LOANS.
AND THEN THERE'S THE THERE WAS
ANOTHER DECISION RECENTLY THAT
GO.
NEED THOUGH CHANGES TO GO
PORTION OF THAT RULE THAT DEALS
WITH SO.
HOW FAST THE UTILITIES HAVE TO
CORRECT --
POTENTIAL ISSUES DEPENDING ON
THEIR OF A SEVERITY OF
SIGNIFICANTLY TIGHTENING UP THE
TIME LINES AND STRENGTHENING
HELL THOSE REQUIREMENTS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT BOTH ELECTRIC AND SO
THE COMMUNICATION COMPANIES ARE
INSPECTING THEIR FACILITIES AND
AS THEY IDENTIFY ISSUES THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN AGGRESSIVE RISK
ASSESSMENT PROGRAM.
THE TITLE NAM.
AND WE CONTINUED TO EVALUATES
.
ALL WERE THOUGH REGULATIONS
AGAINST THE NATIONAL ELECTRIC
SAFETY CODE AND LOOK ELSEWHERE
FOR BEST PRACTICES WALL IN THE
AREA OF WILD FIRE EL PREVENTION
THAT'S MOSTLY AUSTRALIA.
HOME.
THAT KNOW THAT WE'RE OF FELT
LOOKING UP WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN
DOING AS WELL AS CAL FIRE AND
THE UTILITIES A SMALL.
HOME THEY HAVE THE FACE SIMILAR
ISSUES AND SO.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THEM YOU
MENTIONED ALSO THAT A QUARTER OF
THE ADDITIONS ARE DUE --
TO VEGETATION COMING CONTACT
WITH --
ELECTRICAL INFRASTRUCTURE ARMY
PERCENTAGE --
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT YOU HAVE A
STAFF WITH THE ENORMOUS
GEOGRAPHY THAT STATE CALIFORNIA
HAS TO PROACTIVELY ENSURE THE
VEGETATION IS.
IS KEPT UNDER CONTROL NUMBER ONE
TO NUMBER --
TWO ARE WE UTILIZING OUR
TECHNOLOGY TO OUR BEST ADVANTAGE
AS AN EXAMPLE.
AND THE OTHER CORPORATE AREAS OF
TO MACULAR VARIETY CAME FROM --
CAL STATE SAN DIEGO OWNS A TWO
THOUSAND ACRE ECOLOGICAL
RESERVE.
THAT IS OBSERVE BY PEOPLE ALL
OVER THE PLANET BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THOUSANDS OF CAMERAS WE
KNOW THE COST OF THIS TECHNOLOGY
HAS COME DOWN --
WE ARE ABLE TO SEE THINGS THAT
WE NEVER THOUGHT WE'D BE ABLE TO
SEE AS INEXPENSIVELY AS WE COULD
HAS THERE BEEN A THOUGHT OF
PUTTING.
CAMERAS IN THESE VERY DANGEROUS
FIRE PRONE AREAS WHERE INSTEAD
OF HIRING PEOPLE WITH
HELICOPTERS FLYING.
OF PEOPLE TO GO ON THE GROUND
WITH JEEPS AND LOOKING AT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF MITIGATING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT WE COULD USE.
TECHNOLOGY AS A COST EFFECTIVE
ANY MUCH MORE EXPEDIENT WAY OF
RECOGNIZING WHEN WE SEE OVER
GROWTH THAT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
CAUSE FIRES --
SO TO YOUR THE FIRST QUESTION AS
TO WHETHER WE HAVE --
THE SUFFICIENT STAFFING O..
WE AS I MENTIONED IT IN MY
TESTIMONY WE HAVE INCREASED OUR
STAFFING AND WILL CONTINUE TO
EVALUATE SO WAY NOW.
WE NEED TO DO FROM THE PC AS
WELL POINTS OF VIEW EL THE ORDER
OF MAGNITUDE OF AN ISSUE FACES
OBVIOUSLY EARTHQUAKE EXTENSIVE.
AND SO WE HAVE TO RELY ON
UTILITIES TO DO OF THE
PATROLLING TO ASSURE THE SAFETY
OF THEIR LINES WHICH IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY --
IN TERMS OF TECHNOLOGY THAT IS
AN AREA WHERE --
ANYTHING THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY --
FOR USING ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY
OTHER.
PROVE HOW WE TACKLE THIS ISSUE.
WELL THE CHALLENGES AS I
MENTIONED WITH VEGETATION A
REALLY OUTSIDE OF CLEARANCES
MEAN WE YEAH BUT YOU KNOW THAT
WE HAVE A TENTH VOIGTS --
CLEARANCE REQUIREMENT NOW --
FOR HIGH VOLTAGE DISTRIBUTION
LINES BUT YOU CAN KEEP
INCREASING OF THOSE LITTLE A
LIMIT OF DIMINISHING RETURNS
BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE ANY COULD
LOOKED THE STREET BUT IS.
A FULL TOLL THIRTY FORTY FOOT
AWAY FROM THE ELECTRIC CLIMB IT
STILL POSES DE PIECE THE FIRE
WELL THREATS.
SO UNLESS WE COMPLETELY CLEAR
WELL WILL VEGETATION AND THAT
THE SCHOOL ENOUGH TO POTENTIALLY
FULL OVER YOU KNOW YOU'RE NEVER
GOING TO COMPLETELY ELIMINATE
THE RISK IN THE ONE THAT POINTS
WHEN YOU HOW OF WINS.
ELM ALL EXCESS OF FIFTY SIXTY
AND UP TO NINETY MILES AN HOUR
THAT VEGETATION CAN BE EL
TROUBLING QUITE FAR SO WHAT WE
CAN BE DOING WITH ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGIES IS DOING MUCH MORE
FREQUENT SURVEYING AND
COLLECTING NO.
DATA FOR ALMOST ALL LIGHT ARE
FROM.
HOME ADVENT OF THE TYPES OF THE
DANCE IMAGING AND THEN USING
ADVANCED ANALYTICS TO HELP HIM
POINTS SO AREAS WHERE YOU HAVE
THE HIGHEST RISKS IT'S REALLY
COMBINING.
ALL THE DATA THAT I EAT YOU CAN
GET FROM --
TOOK A FROM THE ADVANCED
SURVEYING WITH ANALYTICS BECAUSE
AS THEY EAT TOO IF YOU HEALTH US
SENSORS AND USE DIFFERENT DATA
SOURCES.
YOUR EVIL WITH TECHNOLOGY TO
IDENTIFY BUT CENTRAL VALLEY RISK
O. VEGETATION LOOKS AT RISK THAT
YOU JUST CANNOT DO WITH THE AT
AN ARBORIST WAS VISUALLY LOOKING
AT A TREE.
SAVING TO GO THERE --
DE IN THE V. SENDS IN THE SPACE
--
IN CAMERAS THAT CAN BE USED SO
IT IS SO WOOD HELICOPTERS OR
AMOUNTS OF THEM PULLS OF ALL
KINDS OF SOLUTIONS.
THAT ARE LIMON REACTING HEAR
FROM YOU ABOUT THAT TECHNOLOGY
WHICH IS INTO TECHNOLOGY WENT
WITH COST APPRECIATE YOUR
ANSWERS AND AND CHIEF PORTER.
A THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
RECOGNIZE AND PER SITE
FIREFIGHTER THAT --
LOST HIS LIFE I APPRECIATE THAT
--
IN YOUR VIEW --
CHIEF WHAT IS THE BIGGEST
IMPEDIMENT AFTER READING OUR
FORCE OF A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINE MILLION DEAD TREES THAT ARE
KINDLING. FOR OUR FIRE SITUATION
HERE IN THE STATE --
CAPACITY IS IS --
THE BIGGEST ISSUE THERE --
SENATOR STONE BOTH CAPACITY IN
THE ABILITY --
TO HAVE.
CREWS AND EQUIPMENT AND JUST
SURE --
HUMAN POWER TO REMOVE THOSE
TREES -- BUT
ALSO IN THE THE OUTLETS FOR
THOSE FOR THE WOOD PRODUCTS THAT
COULD COME FROM THOSE THINGS
GOOD THOSE THOSE ARE THE BIGGEST
IMPEDIMENTS --
FOLLOWED CLOSELY BY A LOT OF
THESE TREES THE VAST MAJORITY
ACTUALLY ARE IN THE BACK
COUNTRY.
AWAY FROM --
ROADS AND AND INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR THEIR
REMOVAL --
WHICH HAS --
SOME BENEFIT IN THAT THEY'RE FAR
ENOUGH AWAY FROM FROM PEOPLE
THAT THEY'RE NOT A HUMAN HAZARD
AN ISSUE --
THERE STILL IS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
--
COST TO THAT.
ARE ALL OF THAT STANDING --
CARBON CELLULOSE IS GOING TO
FALL AND HAS STARTED TO FALL --
AND THAT WILL BE --
FUEL LOADING PROBLEM FOR US FOR
DECADES TO COME WHY UNDER I
UNDERSTAND THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS IT'S JUST NOT GOING IN
THERE WITH BULLDOZERS AND A AND
REMOVING TREES.
BUT I THINK WE NEED A MORE
PROACTIVE APPROACH IN THE STATE
AND MAYBE WE NEED TO PRIORITIZE
AREAS WHERE WE HAVE A LOT OF
DEAD TREES THAT ARE CLOSE.
TO POPULATION CENTERS SUPPOSEDLY
HE A RISK.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T IF WE LET THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SIDE OF IT WAY TOO
MUCH.
WERE RISK OF HAVING A FIRE WHICH
IS GOING TO DECIMATE THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF ACRES
AND THERE WILL BE NO CRATERS
LEFT OKAY ISN'T GOING IN THERE
AND TRYING --
TO DO WEEKEND TO TO ELIMINATE
SOME OF THAT WOULD --
YOU KNOW AS WELL AS I DO RIGHT
NOW THERE'S A FIRE IN THE LIGHT
OF WHAT IS VENTURE THAT DID YOU
KNOW THAT ARE YOUR FIREFIGHTERS
IT --
HAVEN'T RYAN ARE PROBABLY
ACTIVELY FLYING THERE IN TRYING
TO GET THAT FIRE OUT --
IS IT STILL CALIFORNIA YEARS
POLICIES THAT THE FLY BY VISUAL
FLIGHT RULES AND WILL ONLY FLY
DURING DAYLIGHT HOURS OR DO WE
NOW HAVE ADVANCED AIRCRAFT.
THE COULD FIGHT FIRES --
THIRD OF THE TIME WHEN FIGHTERS
ARE GOING IN SPREADING AND AND
HISTORICALLY WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO PUT THE THING IN THE AIRPORT
AMOUNT.
IT'S SO RELATED TO FIXED WING
AIRCRAFT --
IT IS VISUAL --
THEY THEY CAN FLY TO A HALF HOUR
AFTER SUNSET --
AND THAT'S THAT'S THE END OF IT
--
SO FOR THAT'S THE FIXED WING AND
NOW FIXED WING THEY HAVE THEY
HAVE A DIFFERENT --
FLIGHT PATTERN VICTORY THAT AND
WOOD ROTARY WING --
WE DO HAVE ROTARY WING THAT WEEK
AND CALL UP BY --
OUR OUR CALL WHEN NEEDED PROGRAM
--
AND SOME OF OUR PARTNER AGENCIES
HAVE SHIPS THAT CAN FLY TWENTY
FOUR HOURS A DAY.
SO THEY CAN DO WATER DROPPED --
IN THE IN THE IN THE NIGHT TIME.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT CAPABILITY
TODAY -- BUT
THE THE NEW FLEET THAT IS COMING
THANKS -- TO
THE EFFORTS OF OF ALL OF YOU AND
AND HELPING US --
TO REPLACE OUR HELICOPTER FLEET
ALL OF THOSE HELICOPTER WILL
HAVE THAT CAPABILITY.
AND SEVERAL OF THEM WILL BE --
ON AND STAFF TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
THREE SIXTY FIVE IN ORDER TO DO
THAT.
THAT MISSION IN THAT WILL BE AT
EVERY ARE COPIES I SUMA BE
REGIONALLY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WILL ALL HAVE THE
CAPABILITY --
AND DO IT THE BASES THAT WILL BE
ON THROUGHOUT THE YEAR WILL BE
REGIONALLY --
DISTRIBUTED THE RATE LIMITING
STEP TO HAVING FIXED WING BEING
ABLE TO FLY OR NOT FLY AT NIGHT
ISN'T BASED ON THE AGE OF ARE
FLYING INFRASTRUCTURE OR ARE
THERE FIXED WING AIRCRAFT OUT
THERE AND OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY.
DO FLY AT NIGHT BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THAT ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY.
THERE ARE NOT --
READILY AVAILABLE --
FIXED WING AIRCRAFT THAT DO FIRE
FIGHTING --
LIKE DROPPING ANYTHING OUT OF
THE AIR AT NIGHT THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO OKAY SO WOULD WE
NEED MORE THE HELICOPTERS
WHATEVER WE CAN GET THOSE
HELICOPTERS AND THEN LASTLY --
BEST BEDS DENIES THAT RIGHT --
EYES WANT TO SAY --
HOW IMPRESSED I AM WITH THE
PROGRAM THAT YOU'VE IMPLEMENTED
AT -- IN SAN
DIEGO AND ALL QUOTE ROSS PEROT
WHEN IT WHEN HE SAID THERE'S
NOTHING WRONG WITH STEALING A
GOOD IDEA FROM SOMEBODY ELSE.
I THINK WE ALL NEED TO LEARN
FROM YOUR VERY POSITIVE
EXPERIENCE AND SAFEGUARDING THE
CITIZENS OF OF SAN DIEGO AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE.
THANK YOU.
IF IF I COULD.
SENATOR YOU HAD A LOT OF
QUESTIONS CURRICULA SENSE SO HOW
LONG IT'S GOING TO BECAUSE I
WANT WE'RE GONNA BE ON YOUR BUT
FIVE SO.
MOST OF MY QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN
ANSWERED AT SOME COUPLE PHONE
OKAY BECAUSE I JUST WANT TO KEEP
AN EYE ON THE CLOCK WE HAVE ONE
MORE PRESENTER YEAH.
AND AND THEN WE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GIVE.
APPLE TIME FOR A QUESTION
ANSWERS AND IT IS.
CONCEIVABLE I ACTUALLY HAD MORE
QUESTIONS AS WELL BUT WILL
SUBMIT THOSE TO YOU IN WRITING
--
BUT I'D I WANT HER DO YOU RESIST
MEASURE THAT WE CAN.
ALL BE BRIEF I DO HAVE SEVERAL
OTHER QUESTIONS THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO DO AS WELL POSSIBLE.
SO I KNOW RUN SHORT ON TIME BUT
JUST A COMMENT FIRST TO PRESENT
PICKER YOU MENTIONED THAT.
IT'S THE LEGISLATURE THAT'S
DIRECTING.
SAYS THAT WERE DIRECTED A LOT OF
THESE THINGS BETWEEN POLLS BUT
AS A REGISTERED CIVIL ENGINEER I
WOULD NEVER.
JUST SAY PUT THAT ON THAT TOLD
ME WE SHOULD HAVE SOME
ENGINEERING STANDARDS WE SHOULD
HAVE ENGINEERS ARE LOOKING AT
THESE POLLS.
BECAUSE I REALLY DON'T THINK
THAT'S THAT'S SO UNFAIR EXCUSE
IF IF THAT'S THE REASON THAT'S
HAPPENING WE NEED TO CHANGE OUR
FIRST. TWO WE DO DO THAT BUT I'M
JUST POINTING OUT THAT THERE ARE
FREE CALL THE UNAUTHORIZED
ATTACHMENTS THAT TAKE TIME TO
CATCH IN THERE'S A THERE'S A
SLOW PROCESS FOR THE TELCOS TO
ACTUALLY CATCH UP TO THE
ELECTRIC UTILITIES WE THINK
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
I DO THINK THAT.
WE SHOULD POINT OUT THE LAST
YEAR THE LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY --
ADOPTED LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
HAVE PREEMPTED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ABILITY TO LIMIT WHAT'S ON POLLS
THAT THEY OWN AND OPERATE.
AND I THINK THAT THERE'S A VERY
AGGRESSIVE EFFORT AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL TO ALSO --
PREEMPT STATE LAWS I THINK THERE
WILL ALWAYS BE ABLE TO PROTECT
OUR SAFETY STANDARDS BUT I THINK
THAT.
WHAT I'M TRYING TO DRIVE THAT IS
THERE'S A HUNGER FOR MORE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE ON THOSE
SPORTS THAT NETWORK THAT I
DESCRIBED?
HAS MORE VALUE.
THEN WE SEE.
AND WE THINK AND IT'S TIGHTLY
CONTESTED SPACE AND THERE'S
ALWAYS GONNA BE COMPETITION
CROWDING.
AND I UNDERSTAND IT IF A CITY OR
ANYBODY DIRECTED ME AS AN
ENGINEER TO DO SOMETHING THAT
WAS NOT SAFE.
I WOULD NOT DO IT IF I DID I
WOULD BE PERSONALLY RESPONSIBLE
I THINK THE UTILITIES GENERALLY
DO THAT ONE OF MY CONCERNS
HOWEVER IS THE DESIGN STANDARDS
A CONSTANTLY CHANGING WE NEVER
EXPECTED TO SEE WINS AS
FEROCIOUS AS WE SAW IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WAS OUTSIDE THE TEST
THAT'S A DIFFERENT.
ISSUE I UNDERSTAND WITH BUT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THAT.
AND THEN SHE PUT I THINK YOU YOU
ADDRESS THIS IDENTIFIES OWN NOW
BUT ARE THERE THINGS THAT ARE
NOT.
THAT THERE ARE OTHER BARRIERS
THAT ARE EITHER KEEPING US FROM
FROM SENDING THE FORCE PERMIT
REQUIREMENTS SEEK REQUIREMENTS.
THEY'RE MAKING SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BE ABLE TO BE DONE
QUICKLY TAKING A LONG TIME OR
NOT BEING ABLE TO DO LONG LIKE A
SENATOR HUESO WITH WITH THE
GOATS.
AND THANK YOU FOR COMING BACK TO
THAT SUBJECT --
WHAT WHAT WHAT I WANT TO TIE I
WANT TO TIE?
YOUR QUESTION --
SENATOR STONE'S QUESTION.
AND BOTH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
DOLLY AND AND WHAT'S QUESTIONS
BACK TOGETHER --
AND ANSWER.
THE THAT IS AN ISSUE THERE THERE
IS A PROCESS THAT TAKES TIME --
ENVIRONMENTALLY TO CLEAR
PROJECTS ON THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA.
THE THEIR IS --
FEDERAL PROCESS THROUGH NEPA --
THAT THAT TAKES TIME ON THE
FEDERAL LANDS --
ALL OF THESE PROCESSES ARE BEING
LOOKED AT FOR STREAMLINING AND
ENTER INTER AGENCY COLLABORATION
ACROSS FEDERAL STATE.
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
AGENCIES AND GROUPS --
THROUGH THE THE NEWLY CREATED
GOVERNOR'S --
FORCE MANAGEMENT TASK --
THAT WAS BORN OUT OF A BIGGER
NEED STATE WHY.
THAT WAS IDENTIFIED DURING THE
TREE MORTALITY TASK FORCE DAYS
OF THE LAST TWO AND A HALF
YEARS.%
AND SO THOSE EFFORTS ARE GOING
TO BE EXPANDING TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE REGULATORY.
CONCERNS THAT YOU MENTIONED --
AND DAY THE MOVEMENT FORWARD OF
OF THAT FOREST HEALTH INITIATIVE
--
STATEWIDE OKAY WOULD LIKE US TO
TALK ABOUT THAT AS A COMMITTEE
AS WELL FOR LOOKING AT MAYBE
SHIFTING SOME OF THE BURDEN TO
RATEPAYERS OR OTHER THINGS THAT
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT WAYS TO
EXPEDITE THIS [inaudible]
AND THEN.
THE ISSUES THAT I UNDERSTAND
OCCUR WE'RE TRYING TO FEND THE
FOREST IS WHAT DO WE DO WITH
THOSE TREES ONCE WE TAKE THEM
DOWN.
IS BIOMASS ON THEM JUST ASK THE
QUESTION ANYBODY CAN ANSWER BUT
WOOD IS BIOMASS A IMPORTANT PART
OF THAT TOO WILL KNOW INDICATE
THAT ON OCCASION EVEN GROUND UP
INTO SPREAD BUT THERE ARE SO
MANY TREES WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
WITH ALL THIS.
ALL ALL THESE TREES WERE TO BE
TAKEN DOWN.
I'LL ANSWER FROM FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF CAL FIRE IN.
FORCE MANAGEMENT TASK FORCE THAT
IS BEING LOOKED AT AS ONE OF THE
OPTIONS FOR AN OUTLOOK BIOMASS
FOR THAT MATERIAL --
TYPICALLY WE LOOK AT A HIERARCHY
OF THE THAT THE HIGHEST AND BEST
USE OF THE MATERIAL FIRST AND
BURNING IT UP OR TURNING IT INTO
POWER ARE LOWER ON THAT ON THAT.
KIND OF GOOD CONTINUUM.
BUT A LOT OF THE MATERIAL THAT'S
THE ONLY --
THE ONLY POSSIBLE --
OUTLET FOR IT SO --
I'LL I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT FROM
THE FOREST MANAGEMENT TESTABLE
ISSUE RESPECTIVELY THAT'S
SUFFICIENT THEY CAN THEN LASTLY
--
MISTER D'AGOSTINO.
SO.
I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT WHAT YOU
GUYS ARE DOING I THINK WE SHOULD
LOOK AT IT AS STATEWIDE.
PERSPECTIVE.
BUT I JUST HAVE TO IMAGINE IF
YOU'RE GOING TO DO.
AND IF YOU'RE ABLE TO REROUTE
POWER TO TO THOSE HOMES REVIEW
DE ENERGIZED THEY HAVE NO POWER.
AND HOW HAS THE RESPONSE BEEN
FROM FROM THE CUSTOMER.
WELL WE'VE WE'VE GONE OUT EVEN
SENSE THE EVENT IN DECEMBER AND
HOWLED TOWN HALL MEETINGS AND
ALL OF THE AFFECTED COMMUNITIES
AND WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO FIND
WAYS THAT WE CAN TRY TO MITIGATE
THAT IMPACT. ONE OF THEM THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT NOW IS RESOURCE
CENTERS SO PREDETERMINED
LOCATIONS AND WE PUT THE
ENGINEERING EQUIPMENT THAT NEEDS
TO BE THERE THAT WE CAN.
HAVE A GENERATOR. TO TRY TO
PROVIDE THIS FOR THESE LOCATIONS
WE HAVE OTHER DOWNTOWN AREAS
WHERE THERE ARE DIFFERENT
ENGINEERING SWITCHING PLANS AND
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE DONE.
ON TO TRY TO RE ROUTE AROUND.
PARTICULARLY HIGH RISK AREAS AND
WE LEARNED A LOT IN DECEMBER ON
ABOUT HOW THIS WHOLE --
AND DE ENERGIZE ATION PLANNED
CAN PLAY OUT SO WE'RE ADDING
ADDITIONAL SWITCHING TO THE
SYSTEM ADDING ADDITIONAL WEATHER
STATIONS TO TRY TO MINIMIZE THE
CUSTOMER IMPACT WHEREVER WE CAN
SO IT'S A CONTINUOUS EVOLUTION
--
WHERE YOU KNOW EVERY YEAR WE SEE
MORE SAN AND AS WE LEARN MORE
AND THEN WE FIND ENGINEERING AND
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS TO TRY TO
ADDRESS IT?
AND MINIMIZE THE IMPACT TO THE
CUSTOMERS SO THAT'S HOW WE'RE
CONTINUING TO APPROACH THIS
MOVING FORWARD APPRECIATE THAT
SO BUT WHAT HAS BEEN THE
RESPONSE FROM THE CUSTOMERS IF
THEY LOSE POWER.
AYE IT IS BEEN MIXED SOME PEOPLE
HAVE SAID THANK YOU --
AND AND SOME PEOPLE HAS BEEN YOU
KNOW WE WE NEED THE POWER TO RUN
OUR WELLS WE NEEDED. TO TO RUN
OTHER THINGS SO IT IT'S BEEN A
VERY MIXED RESPONSE OKAY THEY
ARE VERY MUCH I'LL TESTIFY TO
THAT EVERY TIME THERE'S A D.
INITIALIZATION.
THE PHONES LIGHT UP THE CP YOU
SEE AND I GET FORTY OR FIFTY
EMAILS PERSONALLY --
TASKING ME WITH MAKING SURE IT
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN --
NO ACTUALLY I THINK THERE IS
THERE IS THERE IS THIS DUTY TO
SERVE WHICH IS STATUTORY BUT I
THINK THAT THE CHALLENGES THAT
PEOPLE BOTH LOVE AND HATE
INTEREST.
AND WHEN IT'S NOT THERE THEY'RE
UPSET WHEN IT IS THERE TO HATE.
THE LAST SERIES OF QUESTIONS
WILL TURN TO CHAIRMAN DOT TO
POST TO THIS PANEL AND THEN WILL
INTRODUCE THE NEXT.
YEAH BECAUSE THE TIMING ON
DISCONNECT CUT WAY BACK IS THAT
THIS PANEL AS THAT CREATED MORE
QUESTIONS.
BUT I THAT WOULD BEEN WHAT
YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO HELP US --
YOUR THE LONG RUN I'M REALLY
DISAPPOINTED ABOUT THAT I GET
IT.
THIS IS A COMPLEX PROBLEM AND
THE SOLUTIONS TO IT --
ARE NOT SO SIMPLE BUT THIS
SHOULD BE AUGUSTI NO.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
COMPANY'S ABILITY.
TO TRY TO ADAPT TO INVEST I EVEN
VESTED A BILLION DOLLARS --
TO DATE THAT INCLUDES TREE
TRIMMING AND EVERYTHING YES AND
WHO AS WE LOOK AT IT NOW WE'RE
REALLY JUST GETTING STARTED I
MEAN WHEN WE LOOK HOLISTICALLY
AT THIS AFRICA AND THERE'S YOU
KNOW HAD ASKED ADDITION.
AND THE NEXT ONE IS WHAT --
WHAT PERCENTAGE THAT WOODS IS OR
WILL BE IN THE AD CHARGED TO
RATEPAYERS?
VERSUS THE INVESTORS.
THAT'S FOR IMPOSSIBLE
[inaudible]
OUR INVESTMENT.
WHAT WILL REPORT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THAT BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT TO SPEAK [inaudible]
NUMBER --
ONE OKAY THANK YOU FOR THAT I
SEE ALSO THAT THERE'S BEEN THREE
FIRES IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS.
ON ANY OF THOSE BY THOSE THREE
FIRES IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS IN
YOUR SERVICE AREA HAS THERE BEEN
A DISTRICT ATTORNEY REFERRAL --
NOT THAT I'M AWARE OF THE WORLD
REPORT BACK ON THAT AS WELL.
IT ENDED FINALLY --
FOR THE THREE OF YOU WOULD YOU
KNOW YOUR PARTNER SHIP IS I
THINK SO CRITICALLY IMPORTANT --
TO WHERE WE'RE GOING --
I DON'T KNOW YOU KNOW BASED ON
WHAT'S HAPPENED IN THESE --
I IN I THINK MISTER PRESIDENT
YOU SAID.
YEAH THESE ARE LONG HELD
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES ROME
WASN'T BE A BIT BUILT OVERNIGHT.
I THINK TO SUGGEST ANYTHING MORE
THAN WE NEED TO HELD A LOT OF
WORK IN THIS AREA.
WOULD BE A CHEAP SHOT I I JUST
THINK IT'S IT IT SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF BUT I I AM A LITTLE BIT
WORRIED ABOUT.
GIVEN SOME OF THE ANSWERS TO THE
QUESTIONS THAT WE'VE HAD TODAY
--
HOW THAT MAKES LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS FEEL ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING AT THE STATE LEVEL HOW
THAT MAKES OUR CONSTITUENTS FEEL
ABOUT?
AYE PROTECTING THE SAFETY --
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS IN MAYBE
EVEN -- YA I
DON'T KNOW.
I A WEEK WILL I'LL I'LL BE
ASKING SUBMITTING A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS OF IN THIS TYPE OF
ENVIRONMENT HOW THE HELL DO WE
EXPECT --
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES OR
I'M NOT INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
IN GENERAL.
I TO REACTED TO BE BEHAVING AND
BECAUSE THE AUDITS AND SPOT
CHECKS THAT YOU'VE BEEN DOING
[inaudible]
AGAIN. FOR NOT WORKING.
SO WE GOTTA FIGURE OUT SOME
OTHER WAY.
I'M DOING THAT WITH THAT I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR
TIME AND ATTENTION AND WE WILL
BE BACK IN TOUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER ARAFAT AND WE
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR JOINING US
I THINK IT IS VERY.
CLEAR THAT THISIS A COMPLICATED
SET OF ISSUES AND AS WE OPENED
ONE DOOR.
THAT LEADS TO MANY MORE AND SO I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
SPEND SOMETIME AMONGST
OURSELVES.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
NARROW THIS DOWN WITH ONLY BY
THE TIME WE GET BACK IN AUGUST
SIXTEEN WORKING DAYS TO TRY.
TO COME TO SOME CONCLUSION NOT
ONLY ON THIS ISSUE BLOOM
MULTITUDE OF OTHERS.
AND AND SO I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT --
WE KEEP YOUR OF ALL YOUR MEMBERS
ON SPEED SPEED DIAL AND THEN
WILL REACH BACK OUT TO YOU IF WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND
I'M SURE WE WILL.
BUT THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
TODAY.
I'LL TURN THE MEETING BACK OVER
TO TURN INTO OKAY UP BRYAN BROWN
MANAGING PRINCIPAL ANALYST FOR
RESOURCES ENVIRONMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH THE OFFICE
OF LEGISLATIVE [inaudible]
ANALYSTS --
IT'S GONNA DISCUSS RECENT FISCAL
POLICY ACTIONS ON WHILE BY
RESPONSE RECOVERY --
MISTER BROWN I DON'T KNOW HOW
LONG YOU WERE --
PRESENTATION IS BUT IT I THINK
YOU GET THE WE'RE COMING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS --
NO THIS WILL BE A VERY OF
REPRESENTATION AND SENSITIVE TO
YOUR TIME --
AGAIN BRIAN BROWN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
WE WILL JUST HAVE TO PROVIDE A
REALLY BRIEF OVERVIEW ON RECENT
SPENDING ON WILDFIRE RELATED
ACTIVITIES --
IN SO WE HAVE A HANDOUT CAN
DISTRIBUTE NOW BY THE BY THE
SERGEANT.
IT IS ALSO AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE AND BELIEVE WILL BE
POSTED ON THAT COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AS WELL --
BUT THIS IS REALLY JUST MEANT TO
GIVE YOU KIND OF THE HIGH LEVEL
CONTACT THE FISCAL CONTEXT IF
YOU CONTINUE TO DEBATE THE VERY
SIGNIFICANT COMPLEX.
POLICY QUESTION.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE ONE OF TO
HAND OUT THIS JUST SUMMARIZES.
BEASTIE RELATED COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THOSE TWO MAJOR SET THE
FIRES IN SOUTHERN AND NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND FALL OF LAST YEAR WHAT YOU
CAN SEE IS THAT IN TOTAL THE TWO
YEAR -- OVER
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND OVER TWO
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN
COST THIS IS.
THE RESPONSE AND RECOVERY
RELATED COSTS SO IT PRIMARILY
COVERS THE INITIAL RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES BY FIREFIGHTERS AS
WELL AS THE BREA REMOVAL.
AND THEN --
IN ADDITION AND THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH --
REPAIRING OR REPLACING DAMAGED
INFRASTRUCTURE.
NOW MUCH OF THAT.
COST IS ULTIMATELY GOING TO BE
REIMBURSED PRIMARILY BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT THAT
STILL LEAVES ON NET GENERAL FUND
COSTS IN THE RANGE OF THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
IS CURRENTLY ESTIMATED.
YOU CAN SEE THOSE --
THOSE COSTS --
QUESTION THE LEGISLATURE PARTLY
IN RESPONSE TO THE FIRES BUT I
THINK JUST GIVEN THE HISTORY OF
FIRE.
IN CALIFORNIA BROADLY AND AND
FOCUS IN RECENT YEARS ON FIRE
PROTECTION OF PREVENTION AND
HEALTHY FORESTS HAVE BEEN
ADDITIONAL.
INVESTMENTS MADE BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGETTHERE'S
JUST APPROVED BY YOU LAST MONTH.
AND SO WE'VE INCLUDED ON PAGE
TWO SUMMARY OF SOME OF THOSE.
SPENDING --
THIS TABLE INCLUDES --
DOES INCLUDE A FOUR CATEGORIES
THE FIRST CATEGORY IS A LITTLE
BIT MORE DETAIL ON THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN SPENDING.
A BUDGET IT RELATED TO THOSE OF
FIRE RECOVERY COSTS THAT WERE ON
THE PREVIOUS PAGE.
INTRIGUED ENOUGH ABOUT A HUNDRED
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
OF FOR MOST OF THIS DE IS GOING
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND THE
AFFECTED COMMUNITIES. TO COVER
--
AT PUBLIC ASSISTANCE RELATED
COSTS --
DAMAGE INFRASTRUCTURE SHARE AS
WELL AS THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND TO
BACKFILL LOST PROPERTY TAXES.
IN ADDITION THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED NINETY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
FORCE CARMEN PLAN THIS WAS AN
ADMINISTRATION.
DOCUMENT RELEASED THIS SPRING
THE INTENT OF THE PLAN IS.
TO IMPROVE FOREST HEALTH BROADLY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA --
BOTH TO BE ABLE TO SEQUESTER
MORE CARBON AS WELL AS TO REDUCE
THE RISK OF A WILDFIRE THAT EMIT
CARMEN.
IN DOING THAT THAT HAS --
CERTAINLY BROADER FORCED HEALTH
BENEFITS IN IN FIRE PREVENTION
IS A MAJOR COMPONENT OF OF THESE
ACTIVITIES INTO YOU CAN THROUGH
THEIR NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS TO THAT --
THESE PROGRAM WILL BE
ADMINISTERED BY CAL FIRE THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY AND AND
THIS YEAR.
CONSERVANCY IN PARTICULAR --
IN ADDITION TO PROGRAMS FUNDED
AS PART OF THE FOURTH CAR THEM
PLAN --
THERE IS ADDITIONAL FUNDING
PRIMARILY FROM THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND THIS IS THE
CAP AND TRADE AUCTION REVENUES
--
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR OTHER FOREST HEALTH AND
HEALTHY FORCE RELATED ACTIVITIES
THIS IS AN OFFICE A YEAR ONGOING
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN FUNDED IN IN
PRIOR YEARS IT.
VARIOUS ANNOUNCES THE AMOUNT
AVAILABLE FROM THE GDR F. IS
CHANGED OVER TIME BUT BUT
INCLUDES A HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS THIS YEAR FOR THOSE
ACTIVITIES.
AND THEN LASTLY THE CATEGORY OF
FIRE FIGHTING THE LEGISLATURE'S
BUDGET --
INCLUDES ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
PRIMARILY FOR CAL FIRE BUT ALSO
SOME OF THESE RESOURCES ARE FOR
LOCAL --
FIREFIGHTING AGENCIES TO IMPROVE
[inaudible]
BOND TWO WILDFIRES SO THERE WAS
SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
HELICOPTER REPLACEMENT FLEET
REPLACEMENT FOR CALIFORNIA THAT.
FOUR HUNDRED ONE MILLION DOLLARS
THIS YEAR TO REPLACE FOUR OF OUR
EIGHTEEN HELICOPTERS WITH NEW.
NEW ONE THAT'LL BE SOMETHING
THAT'S RULED OUT OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS THE FULL FLEET
REPLACEMENT --
THERE'S ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
EMERGENCY FUND TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE RESOURCES SET ASIDE FOR
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES --
YOU'LL SEE A COUPLE OF TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR --
AMOUNTS HERE THE THOSE ARE THE
AMOUNTS THAT WILL GO TO LOCAL.
FIREFIGHTING AGENCIES FOR
EQUIPMENT PURCHASES AND IN AND
THEIR FLEET --
EXPANSION.
AND IN THE LAST FEW ITEMS ON
HERE WE'RE GOING TO INDIVIDUALLY
BUT THOSE ARE ADDITIONAL --
FUNDING FOR STAFF MEAN A
CALIFORNIA TO THAT THEY HAVE
MORE STAFF AND ALSO AT THE
CONSERVATION CORPS TO THEM MORE
HAND CREWS.
AVAILABLE --
TO TO RESPOND TO FIRES AND IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THEIR
PROGRAM.
OVERALL THIS IS --
CLOSE.
TO BUDGET THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED.
AND THAT MORE THAN HALF OF IT IS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND MOST OF
THE REMAINDER IS EITHER FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
THAT I MENTIONED OR FROM S. B.
FIVE WHICH WAS A PROPOSITION
SIXTY A APPROVED BY VOTERS.
IT'S PAST JUNE AWFULLY THAT OF
COURSE WILL BE REPAID BY.
BY THE GENERAL FUND TO THE
GENERAL OBLIGATION --
BUT THAT COMPLETE THEA THE
FISCAL SUMMARY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT WE HAVE --
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
SOME OF MY WORK WHAT HER.
KNOWLEDGE THANK YOU.
IS IT POSSIBLE TO GET THE LIKE
MAYBE TEN YEARS OF WHAT WE SPENT
ON SUPPRESSION VERSES.
WHAT WE DID ON TO MITIGATE THE?
IMPACT TO DO --
PREVENTION.
YEAH AND IN FACT OF SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES JUST --
WORK ON REPORT THOSE RELEASED
EARLIER THIS SPRING AND WE HAVE
SOME DATA IN THERE I DON'T HAVE
IT.
OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD BUT FROM
MY RECOLLECTION IS THAT WE'VE
SPENT OVER THE PAST DECADE PRIOR
TO THE GDR OFF BEING UTILIZED
FOR THAT FROM THE PREVENTION
PURPOSES.
ON AVERAGE CALVET WITH SPENDING
SOMETHING LESS THAN A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS HEON PREVENTION
IF YOU'LL REDUCTION TYPE OF
ACTIVITIES YOU CAN SEE HOW
THAT'S PUMPED UP NOW UNDER THE
THE NEW BUDGET --
THIS IT WAS REPRESENTS JUST --
THE SMALL VERY SMALL SHARE OF
THE OVERALL CAL FIRE BUDGET WELL
MORE THAN 90% OF IT IS ON
FIREFIGHTING RELATED ACTIVE BUT
WE CAN PROVIDE THAT THAT DETAIL
TO IN YOUR IN YOUR THOUGHT
PROCESS OF ABOUT 90% GET SPENT
ON SUPPRESSION CURSES ABOUT 10%
ON PREVENTION.
I THINK IT EVEN HIGHER THAN 90%
BUT THE MORE PRECISE NUMBERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO MEMORY WOULD.
TAKE YOU THAT.
APPRECIATE THAT QUESTION BECAUSE
THAT WAS THAT WAS RELEASED WHERE
I WANTED TO GO I MEAN WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET.
YEAH GATHERS TO THEIRS TO EARN
SIXTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
THERE -- FOR
THE FORCE CARVE A PLAN OTHER FOR
TECHIES AND THAT'S GREAT --
BUT THERE'S ALSO THIS FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
RELATED TO FIRE SUPPRESSION AND
AND AND RECENT RESET MAPPING
THERE BUT THAT'S THAT'S WHERE
SIXTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS IS A
ONE TIME.
INVESTMENT BUT YOU'RE NOT NINE
GOING.
YEARLY PROGRAMS WERE NOT.
MUCH MY UNDERSTANDING RIGHT SO
IN FACT IT FOR ITS CARBON PLAN
--
THAT IS FUNDED PRIMARILY BY THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
WHICH THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS SO THAT ALL
THE TIME THAT WILL COME BACK TO
THIS NEXT YEAR FOR THE BUDGET
PROCESS.
AND IN THE MOOD FOR THE
REMAINDER OF FROM S. B. FIVE
WHICH AT ONE TIME FINDING
GENERAL OBLIGATION BONDS.
ON THERE IS SOME BECAUSE SOME OF
THE S. B. FIVE AUTHORITY THAT
WILL STILL BE AVAILABLE TO YOU
NEXT YEAR BUT THAT'S NOT
EXHAUSTED IN THE MAIN PART OF
CARBON PLAN BUT THAT IS NOT
UNLIMITED.
SO FISCALLY IT'S BEEN PRIORITIES
BEEN ON FIGHTING FIRES AND NOT.
NOT THE SOME OF THE ACTIVITIES
THAT WOULD BE HELPING US IN THE
LONG RUN.
HISTORICALLY AT THE ABSOLUTELY
THE PREDOMINANT SHARE OF
SPENDING HAS BEEN ON FIRE
FIGHTING ACTIVE.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
YOU'RE GONNA GET SOME ABOUT
QUESTIONS THAT SUBMITTED TO YOUR
CAT THAT'S NOTHING EVEN HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO HELP. FOR YOUR TIME.
I MEAN THAT.
DO YOU WANT TO DO CLOSE.
SO RICHARD OVER --
TO CHAIRMAN HOLDEN.
THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
THAT -- WE
GET A SENSE OF AND I'M JUST
GOING TO TAKE A WILD GUESS THAT
NOT THAT EVERYONE WHO IS
STANDING AGAINST THE WALL IS
PREPARED. TO PARTICIPATE PUBLIC
COMMENT IS THERE ANYONE WHO'S
NOT STANDING WHO WAS GOING TO
JOIN IN THAT LINE AT SOME POINT.
I JUST TRY.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT IT'S NOT LIKE YOU HAVE
TO STAND RIGHT NOW I'M JUST
TRYING TO GAUGE --
HOW MUCH TIME WILL WILL ALLOW
FOR EACH PERSON TO SPEAK?
ARMS.
SO I THINK IF WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
GOING TO WORK WITH A MINUTE TO
JUST.
GONNA GIVE EVERYONE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT ON THE RECORD
WITH THEIR THEIR QUESTION
CONCERNS ARE AND IF YOU COULD
LEAD OFF WITH YOUR YOUR NAME.
AND IF THERE'S AN ASSOCIATION
AFFILIATION THAT YOU ARE PART OF
A SHARE WITH US [inaudible]
THAT AND WILL WELCOME THE FIRST
PERSON WHO'S.
APPROACHING THE MIKE NOW.
DIANNE CONKLIN MISSY GREAT ROAD
ALLIANCE RAMONA CALIFORNIA SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND NO
LUNCH.
I AM NOT SURE WHAT IS GOING ON
HERE BUT I CANNOT UNDERSTAND
WHAT GOVERNOR BROWN IS DOING.
OR WHAT ANY OF YOU ARE DOING
EITHER [inaudible]
WE OF MAYBE WE'RE HERE BECAUSE
P. JEANNIE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
INSURANCE.
WE ALSO MIGHT BE HERE BECAUSE
SDG ANY LOST ITS WIN THE CASE
FOR THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN UNINSURED
FIRE BECAUSE FROM THEIR TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN FIRES THAT
HAPPENED LAST YEAR.
SO THERE'S NO PRECEDENT AT THE
CPUC TO REIMBURSE I USE FOR
FIRES IF THEY WERE DEEMED NOT
REASONABLE AND PRUDENT.
THE ALLIANCE HAS INTERVENED ON
WILDFIRE ISSUES AT THE
COMMISSION SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND SIX IT IS OUR ONLY ISSUE.
WE'VE INTRODUCED WE INTRODUCED
THEY FAR THREAT MAP IDEA WE
INTRODUCED LOOK THE CONTINGENCY
RULE RESULTING IN A HOT IN I'LL
USE DOING NOW ANNUAL.
FIRE PROTECTION PLANS AND WE
INTRODUCED A FIRE DATA
COLLECTION RULE YOU HAVE OUR
LETTER IT SHOULD BE DISTRIBUTED
TO YOU RIGHT NOW FROM YOUR
SECRETARY.
I ALSO SEND IT TO YOU BY MAIL
EARLIER THANK YOU AND AND IT IS
ONE MINUTE.
I WANT TO FINISH THIS PLACE I
HAVE FLOWN UP HERE AND I'M
EXHAUSTED DOCTOR JOSEPH MITCHELL
MY SPOUSE.
IS THE ALLIANCE FIRE.
AND THANK YOU HUGE.
IN PARTICLE THANK YOU MCLEAN.
ARE WE WILL REACH YOUR LETTER WE
HAVE ALL THE CORRESPONDENCE
THEORY WE HAVE ALL THE
CORRESPONDENCE THANK YOU WE HAVE
ALL THE CORRESPONDENCE AND WE
WILL ROUTE.
OF THANK YOU MY NAME'S GARY
KISHI I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMERA CHAMBER COMMERCE IN THE
BRIGHT COALITION.
ON BEHALF OF THE SIX HUNDRED
BUSINESSES THAT ARE OF MY
CHAMBER PRESENTS I'D LIKE TO
THINK GOVERNOR BROWN LEGISLATIVE
LEADERS FOR ESTABLISHING THIS
COMMITTEE.
RELIABLE INNER AFFORDABLE ENERGY
IS NECESSARY FOR OUR
CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESSES TO
SUCCEED WE CANNOT GO BACK TO THE
DAYS OF UNCERTAIN ENERGY
SUPPLIES LIKE WE DID DURING THE
DAY DEREGULATION DAYS.
OUR ENERGY COMPANY PROVIDES
STRONG MIDDLE CLASS JOBS WITH
UNCERTAIN FINANCIAL STABILITY OF
OUR UTILITIES THE DOOR TO
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS COULD BE
THREATENED.
THAT MEANS ENSURING WE INVEST IN
AGREED THAT CAN HANDLE
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES IN
ESTABLISHING CLEAR GUIDELINES
FOR UTILITIES TO MAINTAIN THEIR
FACILITIES.
WE NEED TO ENACT REFORMS OF HOLD
OUR UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE BUT
NOT TO HOLD THEM RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE DAMAGE IS DONE AS DURING A
FIRE THAT THEY HAVE.
NO CONTROL OVER THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON* LAND HOME
PRESIDENT OVER THE OXNARD --
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE --
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT SENATOR
JACKSON COULDN'T BE HERE BECAUSE
I AM FROM HER DISTRICT --
AS WE KNOW THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WILDFIRES THAT
DEVASTATED OUR COMMUNITIES WERE
A WAKEUP CALL TO ALL OF US TO
ADDRESS WHAT GOVERNOR BROWN.
CALLS THE NEW NORMAL AND TODAY'S
EXPERT SPEAKERS OF COURSE REFER
TO AS NORMAL NOW --
WE CANNOT MEET OUR ECONOMIC OR
CLIMATE GOALS WITHOUT INVESTMENT
IN A ROBUST ENERGY GRID.
THAT IS SMARTER AND MORE
RESILIENT.
AND WE NEED OUR ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE AS TOUGH AS
EXTREME WEATHER HAS BEEN ON OUR
COMMUNITIES. FOR A MORE
RESILIENT GRID WE HELP
CALIFORNIA LEAD THE OTHER
COUNTRY IN GREEN ENERGY --
PROVIDE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
JOBS AND CAN DELIVER CLEAN SAFE
AND RELIABLE ENERGY. TO EVERY
CORNER OF THE STATE.
AND WITHOUT OUR GRID WE CAN'T
BRING CLEAN ENERGY JOBS THAT
PROVIDE PATHWAY TO MIDDLE CLASS
TO HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS TAKE IT AT THE
ABSENT CHAMBER WE STAND READY TO
WORK WITH YOU AND OTHER BUSINESS
LEADERS.
ON THIS ISSUE I PERSONALLY THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TOM
GARDNER AND A PAST PRESIDENT HOW
FAR LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
ONE ALSO RETIRED CAL FIRE.
OVER FORTY YEARS EXPERIENCE.
I'M -- REAL
BRIEF BECAUSE I HAVE A LOT
SATISFIED FOR THESE COMMITTEES
FOR LAST TWENTY YEARS BOTH AS A
UNION OFFICER AND A LINE OFFICER
FOR CALIFORNIA.
ADD THAT I WOULD.
URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO GO BACK
AND REVIEW THE TWO THOUSAND
THREE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
REPORTS.
IT COVERS BOTH FAR FAR STAFFING
CAO FARMERS LACKING IN STAFFING.
WE DON'T HAVE A PEOPLE DO THOSE
INSPECTIONS WE DON'T HAVE THE
STAFF. TO DO THE FIRE BECAUSE
INVESTIGATION OF FIRE AND
IDYLLWILD.
POSSIBLE ARSONISTS THAT'S KIND
OF TIRED THREE PEOPLE FOR TWO TO
THREE MONTHS AND THEN I CAN BE
AVAILABLE TO DO THE RATHER JOB.
WE DON'T HAVE THOSE PEOPLE PUT
ON THE ENGINES WE DO YEAH.
BUT IT ALSO TALKS ABOUT PLANTING
LAND USE THINGS AT A TIME SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WE HAVE DONE A LOT
WE DEVELOP COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT DOWN THERE.
WE'VE TAKEN THE TOOLS TO GAS
ELECTRIC I WORK IN THE COMMAND
CENTER.
I USE THOSE TOOLS THOSE CAMERAS
WHETHER CENTERS DAILY SOUTH
PLEASE REVIEW THAT COMMITTEE AND
I STAND AVAILABLE THE COMMITTEE
OF NEW TIME OF YOUR THAT YOU
NEED TO OUR STAFF.
THANK YOU FOR THAT OFFER
[inaudible]
NEXT WEEK.
I GOOD AFTERNOON A DOCTOR MACK
BROWN WITH THE BRIGHT CLOSE AND
ALSO -- WITH
THAT CAL STATE SAN MARCOS --
DIRECTOR FOR WILDFIRE RESEARCH
PROGRAMS THERE AND IN MY SPARE
TIME MAYOR FOR THE CITY OF
TEMECULA --
DEEPLY UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES
THAT ARE FACING HERE TODAY --
IT IS A MULTI FACETED --
AND AS MENTIONED EARLIER TRYING
TO IDENTIFY THE SPECIFIC AREAS
FOR YOUR FOCUS ON HOW TO MAKE I
THINK THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO COMMEND YOU FOR
THE WORK YOU'RE DOING --
I JUST I LIKE TO ADD A COUPLE OF
THINGS TO YOUR A RADAR ON THIS I
ONE OF THOSE IS.
THE VALUE AND IMPORTANCE OF
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION IN THIS
--
AND ESPECIALLY A RELATED TO THE
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE --
AND FURTHER I THINK THE THE
RELATED TO THAT PROTECTION
STANDARDS AYE AND HEALTH AND
SAFETY FOR WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE FIREFIGHTERS.
OTHER DOING AN OUTSTANDING JOB
OF PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITIES
AND OUR STATE --
BUT THE DAILY --
CONTAMINATION HAZARD RISKS AND
RISKS TO THEIR LONG TERM HEALTH
IS A TREMENDOUS AND WE ARE
BARELY SCRATCHING THE SURFACE ON
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THOSE RISKS
ARE PARTICULARLY IN.
THE WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE SO
WHY WE ARE HERE TO HELP AND
PROVIDE ANY INFORMATION WE HAVE
OVER THE LAST --
TWELVE YEARS OR SO OF RESEARCH
PROGRAMS THANK YOU SO MUCH MAKES
YOU.
AND JUST AS I HAD WHO ARE WHEN I
LEAN END THAT MEANS HERE. FIVE
SECONDS AWAY.
THEY SPEAK OF VERY GOOD THANK
YOU MY NAME IS JOHN FEST AND I
REPRESENT PUBLIC ENTITIES.
I REPRESENT EIGHTEEN PUBLIC
ENTITIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING NAPA COUNTY CINEMA
COUNTY MENDOCINO COUNTY LAKE
COUNTY VENTURA COUNTY SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY AND THE CITIES
WITH AND THE COUNTIES AND THE
CITIES ARE VERY VERY CONCERNED
--
ABOUT FUTURE FIRES THEY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT OF MISTER DALI IS
HEARD MISTER WOOD IS HEARD MR
DOT IS HEARD. TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE PREVENTION AND PREVENTATIVE
MEASURES ARE THE FOCUS OF THIS
COMMITTEE MOVING FORWARD.
ARE ALL OF THE PUBLIC ENTITIES
THAT I REPRESENT STRONGLY OPPOSE
ANY SORT OF CHANGE TO THE
LIABILITY STANDARDS.
AND WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO
MISTER JUAREZ REPORT WE STRONGLY
DISAGREE WITH HIS ANALYSIS AS TO
THE CONSTITUTIONALITY OF
CHANGING INVERSE CONDEMNATION
FOR TWO REASONS.
HITS CONSTITUTIONALLY UNTENABLE
FOR PURPOSES OF PRIVATE PROPERTY
RIGHTS AND IT'S CONSTITUTIONALLY
UNTENABLE FOR PURPOSES OF JURY
TRIAL RIGHTS AND SO WE SUPPORT
PREVENTION AND OPPOSE ANY SORT
OF CHANGE IN THE LIABILITY
RULES.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PATRICK MCCALLUM REPRESENTING UP
FROM THE ASHES A COALITION OF
FIRE VICTIMS BOTH CITIES
COUNTIES VICTIMS FROM NORTHERN
FOR THE CALIFORNIA.
I'M A FIRE VICTIM BOTH LOST MY
HOME IN THE TUB FIRE AND ALMOST
MY LIFE.
SO WE WANT TO FIRST THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR FOCUSING ON
PREVENTION.
THE QUESTION THAT I THINK WE
NEED TO ASK IF P. JEANNIE HAD
FOLLOWED THE SAME STANDARDS
INVESTMENTS THE SAN DIEGO
ELECTRIC DID WILL I BE STANDING
HERE TODAY WOULD YOU BE HERE
TODAY ASKING.
THAT'S THE FOCUS THAT WE NEED TO
DO MAKE SURE THERE'S NOT
PREVENTION.
AND WE HAVE TO RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
APPROACH AROUND INVERSION
LIABILITY THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES WHETHER YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IT IF THERE'S A
DISASTER.
HAS THEIR HOME DESTROYED WHERE
THEY CAN BE REIMBURSED YOUR CITY
YOUR COUNTY WHERE ARE THE FUNDS
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
INSURANCE COMPANIES IF THEY
DON'T HAVE SEGREGATION.
DO THEY PULL OUT OF CALIFORNIA.
THE LIABILITY SYSTEM WORKS LET'S
FOCUS ON PREVENTION AND WE THINK
WE GET MOVING AND MISTER DAHLE
YOU'RE RIGHT ALL OF US NEED TO
BE INVOLVED AROUND PREVENTION
NOT JUST IOUS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DANIELLE
GUARD UP HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LOW CARBON FUEL AND ENERGY
COALITION.
C. L. CFE HAS PARTICIPATED IN
THE TREE MORTALITYTASK FORCE
THE NUMEROUS EFFORTS TO HELP
ADDRESS THE STATE'S WILDFIRE
EMERGENCY.
OUR BROAD BASED GROUP IS
CONSISTENTLY SUPPORTED EFFORTS
TO PUT ALL OUR BEST RESOURCES
TOWARD REDUCING WILDFIRE RISK IN
DAMAGE.
UTILITIES ARE FIRST RESPONDERS
AND PARTNERS IN MITIGATING THIS
RISK IN THEIR SOLVENCY MUST BE A
KEY CONSIDERATIONS THE BAR
CONTINUES TO RISE REGARDING THE
RESOURCES NEEDED. TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE AND ADAPTATION.
OUR RESOURCES HEALTHY FOREST AG
LEADS BIOENERGY BIOFUELS AND
GEOTHERMAL ENERGY ARE KEY TO
SOLVING THIS PROBLEM AND WE NEED
SOLVING UTILITIES TO HELP REACH
THE BEST SOLUTIONS THAT ARE SO
URGENTLY NEEDED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME ME THE
JENSEN I'M REPRESENTING SHAPE
PEOPLE.
FIRST OF ALL STINKY IF WE ARE
LEADERSHIP AND SUPPLY IT TO
PREVENT A FIRE AND PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES. TWO PEOPLE FEEL
STRONGLY THAT OF THE FOLLOWING
DOCUMENTATION CODE AND LET A
BUNCH YA PROPOSED GO.
AND THAT IS A LEGISLATION MOVE
THEM FORWARD FOLK DOWN UTILITY
LIABILITY AND FIRED SHOULD ALSO
INCLUDE.
THE PRINCE OPPOSED ESPECIALLY OF
THE THE WHITE A WHITE FIRE
PREVENTION PLAN.
NUMBER ONE FOXFIRE INTERVENTIONS
IN THE WIFI URBAN INTERFACE.
WHERE IS HOME TO MORE THAN
ELEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS
SECOND?
NEED TO HOLISTICALLY AND THE
STATIC OF THE MANAGER OF
EDUCATION TO MINIMIZE THE
POTENTIAL FOR YOU ALL FOR FIRE.
FOR MONIQUE DETAILED WE HAVE
SUBMITTED A LETTER FOR YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
SINGLE GAME FOR YA AND FOR IS
LEADERSHIP AND SUPPLY AND KEEP
PEOPLE YOU LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
EXCUSE.
BRIAN HAVE MEAN LOCAL TO ALL
FORTY FIVE WE JUST WANTED SURE
THAT FIRE VICTIMS ARE MADE WHOLE
ALSO ENSURE THE UTILITIES ARE
HARMED --
CONTINUE TO HARDEN ELECTRIC
CREATE TO MAKE IT MORE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MARQUARDT WAKE UP PRESIDENT CAL
CHIEFS THAT PART SHE PERCENT
REAL COUNTY IT'S INTERESTING I'M
GETTING OF OF THE CALLS RIGHT
NOW FOR MITCHELL.
EIGHT THAT SPEAKING OF RESPONSE
THAT THANK YOU FIRST AND
FOREMOST I SPOKE WITH MANY OF
YOU IN YOUR OFFICES FOR THE
SUPPORT FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SPECIFICALLY.
WHERE THE WHERE THE RUBBER MEETS
THE ROAD WERE REALLY RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE PREVENTION PREPAREDNESS
RESPONSE SUPPRESSION --
AT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL.
AND WE WANT TO AS WE CONTINUE ON
THAT PATH FOR PRE POSITIONING
AND AND MODERNIZING THE CHOICES
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
ESPECIALLY TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES HERE.
THAT THESE AS THE UTILITIES WORK
--
TO ON THE EQUIPMENT AND
OPERATIONS CENTERS AND COMMAND
VEHICLES IN WORK FORCES
ESSENTIALLY --
THAT THEY DO THAT IN IN
COORDINATION WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AT SPECIFICALLY --
AS AS YOU CAN AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
CAL CHIEF THE THREE HUNDRED
DEPARTMENTS THAT I REPRESENT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOHN DUNBAR MAYOR
OF THE TOWN YOU KNOW FILL IN
NAPA COUNTY AND THE EXECUTIVE
BOARD MEMBER OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES.
WE SHOULD REMAIN FOCUSED ON
RECOVERY FIRE SAFETY AND AS
GOVERNOR BROWN IDENTIFIED
WILDLAND ENFORCED RE MANAGEMENT.
TO LEGALIZE SUPPORT.
THE DISCUSSION ON EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS MUTUAL AID AND
INFRASTRUCTURE MAINTENANCE WE
ARE ALARMED HOWEVER THAT
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES WANT TO
SHIFT THE FOCUS TO HOW THEY
COULD SPREAD THEIR LIABILITY
WHEN THE POLICIES AND PRACTICES.
ARE FOUND TO BE THE CAUSES OF
CATASTROPHIC FIRES.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ALREADY ARE
FACED WITH SIGNIFICANT COSTS AND
ECONOMIC IMPACTS FROM THESE
WILDFIRES.
ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOODS ARE WIPED
OUT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
ACRES OF AGRICULTURAL LANDS WERE
BURNT.
LONG TERM IMPACTS ARE YET TO BE
DETERMINED.
WOULD BE INAPPROPRIATE TO CHANGE
THE RULES NOW SEEMINGLY ONLY TO
ONE OF THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
UTILITIES.
DILUTING LIABILITY FROM
UTILITIES WHEN THEY'RE FOUND
RESPONSIBLE FOR THOSE DAMAGES
ALSO REDUCES THE INCENTIVE.
THE THEY HAVE CURRENTLY TO BE
PROACTIVE WITH SAFETY
INFRASTRUCTURE MAINTENANCE
LIABILITIES LIABILITY CHANGES
SHOULD NOT COME.
AT THE EXPENSE OF CITIES THANK
YOU THANK YOU MAYOR.
AND AND CAN I REMIND ANY
EVERYONE THE IF YOU DO HAVE YOUR
COMMENTS IN WRITING PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO SUBMIT THOSE TO US AS WE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SUPERVISOR
DIANE DILLON FROM NAPA COUNTY.
ON MY COUNTY IS NOT TAKEN A
POSITION SPECIFICALLY ON THE
INVERSE CONDEMNATION ISSUE BUT
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF C. SACK.
ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
COUNTY.
CALIFORNIA ARM ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES FOR THOSE COME WHO
DOUBT NOW.
AND I'M GOING TO HAVE TO SEND
YOU MY NOTE SEPARATELY BECAUSE
I'VE AMENDED THEM SO MUCH IN
THIS HEARING SITTING HERE THIS
MORNING AND AFTERNOON I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE OF YOU --
WITH YOU KNOW THOSE OF US I'M
I'M JOINED BY SUPERVISOR BROWN
HERE FROM MENDOCINO COUNTY AND
THOSE OF US WHO WENT THROUGH THE
EXPERIENCE THAT WE DID LAST
OCTOBER COULD TALK ABOUT.
OF VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND
CINNAMIC CAMERAS AND THE BROAD
TOPIC OF NEEDING TO HAVE WORKING
GROUPS.
AND THAT CPUC ARM --
NEEDS TO HAVE STRONGER OVERSIGHT
AND FEEL SUPPRESSION AND FORMER
SUPERVISOR DOLLY AND I'VE WORKED
FOR YEARS ON WANTING FOREST
MANAGEMENT SOFTBANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THAT UP.
BUT I AM HERE TODAY TO YOU --
DELIVERY ON ONE REALLY IMPORTANT
MESSAGE AND THAT IS THAT --
WE LOST FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES BURNED LAST YEAR.
DOZENS OF LIVES.
AND FIRES ARE CONTINUING TO BURN
RIGHT NOW [inaudible]
ANY CHANGES.
THAT YOU WILL MAKE TO LOS.
NOW WILL IMPACT FUTURE FIRE
VICTIMS.
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
INVERSE CONDEMNATION ISSUE --
WE BELIEVED THAT IT IS IMPORTANT
TO CREATE OF REASONABLENESS
STANDARD UNDER OUR LIABILITY
LAWS WE CANNOT STRIPPER WAY
PROPERTY OWNERS CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTIONS BAKER WE DON'T
BELIEVE THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY TO DO
IT THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M MENDOCINO COUNTY FIRST
DISTRICT SUPERVISOR CARRY BROWN.
AND I AND HERE AS A DIRECTOR FOR
A D. C. SACCHARINE A STATION I
SERVE ON THEIR BOARD OUR COUNTY
HAS NOT TAKEN A POSITION ON THE
LIABILITY LAWS BUT I WILL BE
BRINGING IT UP BEFORE THEM --
AT OUR NEXT BOARD MEETING WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT OUR
CURRENT LAWS LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD BRINGING MULTIMILLION
DOLLAR COMPANIES TO THE TABLE
WITH VICTIMS. TO SETTLE FOR
DAMAGE WE MUST HAVE THESE LAWS
IN PLACE TO BRING PARTIES TO THE
TABLE.
RATHER THAN BATTLING IN COURT.
WE BELIEVE IT'S HIGHLY.
INAPPROPRIATE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
DO SUGGEST CHANGES TO THE
LIABILITY LAWS WITHOUT FIRST
FULLY EXAMINING SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS [inaudible]
AND STANDARDS EVEN IF CHANGES
STARLIGHT BELLY BE LAWS ARE NOT.
RETROACTIVE WE STRONGLY BELIEVE
THAT ANY CHANGES --
WILL HAVE A LASTING IMPACT ON
CURRENT AND FUTURE E. VAS AND
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT OUR
COMMUNITIES [inaudible]
CLICK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MINI SPAT WITH TURN THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S TIME TODAY WE'VE
BEEN REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS FOR FORTY FIVE YEARS
AND SOME OF THE HISTORY WE'VE
LEARNED DIDN'T SEEM TO BE --
DISCUSSED TODAY.
PJ ANY THREATENING BANKRUPTCY IS
NOTHING NEW WE'VE HEARD THAT
AGAIN AND AGAIN EVERY TIME THEY
HAVE TO FACE THE COST OF THEIR
OWN.
MISMANAGEMENT THEY THREATENED
BANKRUPTCY.
WILD FIRES ARE NOT NEW THEY MAY
BE WORSE BUT OUR STATE'S BEEN
DEALING WITH THEM AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY CUSTOMERS PAY THE
PGA ME.
EVERY MONTH. TO TAKE CARE OF
THESE PROBLEMS EVERYTIME PEACHY
ANY RAISE RATES THEY TELL US
WELL THIS IS HOW WE CAN KEEP YOU
SAFE AND THIS IS SO --
WE CAN KEEP SERVICE RELIABLE SO
THAT'S NOT NEW.
THE FIRST AND MOST IMPORTANT
THING FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IS
KNOWN BAILOUT.
WHEN CUSTOMERS CANNOT PAY THEIR
BILLS?
PGA ANY SHOT SOME OF YET HERE WE
ARE FACING A SITUATION WHERE PGE
NAME MAY NOT BE ABLE TO PAY ITS
OWN LIABILITIES.
AND WHAT DO THEY EXPECT THEY
EXPECT US TO GIVE THEM A BAILOUT
SO NO BAIL OUT ON THEM.
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SEE IT
APPEARS.
I CHAIR OF MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR A CHANCE
TO ADDRESS YOU.
MEMOREX FRAZIER PRESIDENT OF THE
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND WHILE WE DIDN'T INTEND TO
SAY.
SAFETY THERE WERE SOME REMARKS.
RELATED TO THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY SO WE FEEL COMPELLED TO
AT LEAST SAY A FEW THINGS AND
AND RESPONSE.
WE THINK THE FIRST AND FOREMOST
RESPONSIBILITY OF THIS GROUP IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE GENIE.
OF TAKES ITS CUE FROM WHAT'S
NUMBER HAS DONE.
IT WAS AN ACCIDENT WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THERE WERE NO FIRES
AND THEIR SERVICE TERRITORY IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN BUT A P. GENIE
SO FAR THERE ARE PERFECT AVERAGE
OF SIXTEEN FOR SIXTEEN WITH
TWELVE ROOM RESULTING IN
REFERRALS.
AND THEIR RESPONSE HAS BEEN TO
CALL FOR FINANCIAL RELIEF IN
ESSENCE TO ARE YOU THE CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AS PER IS SO PROFOUND THAT THEY
CANNOT PROPERLY ADAPT TO IT
MANAGE IT ON THEIR OWN.
MEANWHILE INSURANCE COMPANIES.
WE'RE STAYING IN COMMUNITIES AND
WE HAD.
WE HEARD EARLIER THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT A UNIQUE LEGAL
ENVIRONMENT.
OUR INSURANCE RULES ARE NOT ONLY
UNIQUE IN THE UNITED STATES THAT
UNIQUE IN THE WORLD THERE'S
NOTHING LIKE CALIFORNIA.
BUT YET WE STAY HERE WERE NOT
EVEN ALLOWED US MUCH AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE.
WE'RE NOT EVEN ALLOWED TO USE
CLIMATE MODELS IN OUR RATE
MAKING PROCESS.
BUT YET THE ARGUMENT IS.
P. GENIE CAN'T HANDLE THEIR
CLIMATE RISKS SO LET'S DUMP
THEIR RESTS ON OTHER FOLKS.
IT FILTERS OUT TO THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY AND WE CAN'T EVEN
INCLUDE CLIMATE RISK IN OUR
RATES.
ON THE ISSUE OF INVERSE
CONDEMNATION JUST GOT IF YOU CAN
JUST TAKE TEN SECONDS THERE ARE.
THREE THERE ARE PRESENTLY THREE
LEGAL CHALLENGES ON INVERSE
CONDEMNATION PGA ANY HOUSE TO AN
EDISON HAS.
ONE AND P. JEANNIE AWAITS
RESPONSE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT ON THE VERY ISSUE.
AND SO INSTEAD OF PURSUING SOME
CONSTITUTIONALLY SUSPECT
LEGISLATIVE CHANGE TO A JUDICIAL
INTERPRETATION.
WE ARE YOU THAT THE FOCUS SHOULD
BE ON SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS IN
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT ALLOW THE
COURTS TO CONCLUDE THEIR TASK
MAKING.
CATHERINE PETTIBONE AMERICAN
INSURANCE DISSOCIATION
REPRESENTING BOTH PERSONAL LINES
AND COMMERCIAL INSURERS --
I'D LIKE TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUE'S
COMMENTS AND CERTAINLY --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY AND WOOD
STEVE YOU MADE VERY GOOD POINTS
ABOUT WHERE WE NEED TO BE
LOOKING.
A HUNDRED TWENTY NINE MILLION
DEAD TREES WE'VE ONLY TAKEN ON A
MILLION WE'VE GOT SERIOUS ISSUES
ARE INSURERS ARE REALLY WORRIED
ABOUT THE STATE'S --
INVESTMENT IN GETTING THIS DEBT
--
AGAIN WE THINK THE INVERSE IS
PREMATURE WE DON'T HAVE THE
FINAL REPORTS AND ALSO TO THE
EXTENT WE ARE DISCUSSING
INSURANCE WE'D LIKE TO CRACK
SOME OF THE MISSTATEMENTS MADE
EARLIER BITER THAT BY THE
SPEAKER.
AND HAVE A PROPER.
A HEARING ON INSURANCE I THINK
IT.
CHAIRMAN --
DIED CHAIRMAN HOLDEN --
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
SPEAK ANDREW AND WE ON BEHALF OF
THE PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURERS.
SO SHE ATION --
WE'D LIKE THIS CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE EQUAL TIME
TO THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY.
A ECHOING THE COMMENTS JUST MADE
WE'D LIKE A POLL PANEL TO TALK
ABOUT THE IMPACTS WHAT THE
COMPOUND FOR SCOOBY TAKE A VERY
HOLISTIC VIEW.
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE LEDGER IF
YOU MAKE THIS CHANGE HOW WE
DON'T THINK IT IS NECESSARY
THREE MAY WE DON'T THINK YOU
HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION WE
DON'T THINK IN FIVE WEEKS YOU
CAN REALLY JUDGE [inaudible]
THE IMPACT --
INSURERS HAVE SKIN IN THE GAME
WE DEPLOYED OVER FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN CAPITAL SO THAT'S A
MISNOMER I WANTED TO CORRECT ON
BEHALF OF THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY.
AND IN FIVE WEEKS YOU HAVE TO
MAKE A DECISION WITHIN THE FIVE
WEEKS WAS SEVENTY TWO HOURS IN
FRANCE MAKE A DECISION AND MAKE
A VOTE.
AND IS GOING TO HAVE IMPACTS
LONG AFTER THIS.
AB YOU KNOW MEASURE TWICE CUT
ONCE MEASURE. FOURTEEN TIMES
BEFORE YOU MAKE THIS CUT.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARK
JOSEF OF BEHALF OF THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA TILDE EMPLOYEES.
WE WOULD ASK THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE TO INCLUDE THREE
THINGS IN YOUR FINAL CONFERENCE
REPORT.
FIRST WE HAVE TO BE SURELY MAKE
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN VICTIMS
HOLE. TO DO THAT WE HAVE TO KEEP
THE GENIE OUT OF BANKRUPTCY AND
MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO DO
THAT.
IS TO ENACT THE SECURITIZATION
LANGUAGE --
WHICH ALLOWS SPREADING OUT THE
COSTS OVER TIME.
THIS IS NOT A BAILOUT WEAKENED.
DECIDE LATER HOW MUCH GOES TO
RATEPAYERS HOW MUCH BECAUSE THE
SHAREHOLDERS BUT FIRST WE HAVE
TO BE SURE.
THAT P. GINNY'S IT'S ABLE TO PAY
OFF THE VICTIMS --
DOT A DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR NOT
CENTS ON A DOLLAR [inaudible]
SECOND.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT --
THE UTILITIES CAN MAKE THE
INVESTMENTS TO REDUCE THE CHANCE
OF CREATING NEW VICTIMS. TO DO
THAT THE UTILITIES HAVE TO RAISE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY YEAR.
AND NO ONE'S GOING TO INVEST IN
A COMPANY.
THAT HAS UNCONTROLLED LIABILITY.
TO DO THIS WE NEED TO CHANGE
INVERSE CONDEMNATION WE APPLAUD
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE GOVERNOR.
FOR MAKING A VERY SOUND PROPOSAL
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
ON THE ON THIS WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
AND FINALLY.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THE YEAH I
TOOK THE THE UTILITIES ACTUALLY
MAKE THE INVESTMENTS. TO REDUCE
THE CHANCE OF REPEATING.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SENATOR DODD
YOUR BILL S. B. TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
REQUIRE SAFETY PLANS TO ENSURE
THAT UTILITIES HARDEN THEIR
SYSTEMS.
AND WE HAVE TO BE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT JUST DOING THIS TO
PREVENT WILDFIRES BUT ALL KINDS
OF DISASTERS WE WILL HAVE MAJOR
EARTHQUAKES NAY ISSUE IN THIS
STATE.
WE WILL BE SUBMITTING A LETTER
DETAILING OUR THREE REQUESTS YOU
KNOW DETAILS THINK I'D
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
S. B..
GOOD AFTERNOON MR TEARS AND
MEMBERS KAREN LANG ON BEHALF OF
SEVERAL COUNTIES INCLUDING
CINEMA AND I WOULD NEED TO
START.
BY VAN EXPLAINED THEIR SINCERE
THANKS TO THEIR MEMBERS BUT ON
THE COMMITTEE AND IN THE NORTH
BAY FOR HELPING THEM RECOVER.
THEY DID WANT TO I SUPPORT THE
COMMENTS MADE BY SUPERVISORS
DILLON AND BROWN RELATED TO
INVERSE CONDEMNATION LA CHANGES
THEY BELIEVE THAT IS.
INCREDIBLY PREMATURE AND WOULD
URGE YOU TO REJECT THOSE
CHANGES.
AT FRESNO COUNTY ALSO LIABILITY
AND WHERE THE DEEP POCKETS MAYBE
IF THESE LAWS ARE CHANGED THEIR
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BECOMING FAN.
I PLACER COUNTY ALSO EXPRESSED
THAT SAME CONCERN AND ALSO
EXPRESSED CONCERNS ABOUT HOW
THIS MAY IMPACT THE FORMATION OF
CCA'S.
IN THE STATE NEVADA COUNTY ASKED
VERY SPECIFICALLY THAT IS THE
COMMITTEE TICKLE TAKES A LOOK AT
OUR PREVENTION.
THAT THE CONSIDERATION FOR MORE
ROBUST ENFORCEMENT OF LOCAL
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT ORDINANCES
DE CONSIDERED NEVADA COUNTY HAS
A VERY STRENUOUS VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT ORDINANCE.
BUT THEY CANNOT GET A STRENUOUS
PARTNERSHIP WITH CAL FIRE TO
ACTUALLY ENFORCE THAT THE FOCUS
MAINLY ON EDUCATION AND IT'S
EXPENSIVE TO GO IN AND FORCE.
A CLEAN UPPER MANAGEMENT OF THE
PROPERTY IN THE AFTER AND A PRE
A RECORDING THE LEAN.
AND IT TAKES FOREVER TO GET PAID
BY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT
WOULD LOOK TO YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION OF MORE
ENFORCEMENT AND FINALLY YUBA
COUNTY WANTED TO RAISE CONCERNS
ABOUT LIABILITY.
WHEN AFTER HURRICANE KATRINA IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED A LAW THAT
SAID BASICALLY IF YOU TAKE A
DOLLAR FROM THE STATE TO IMPROVE
THE STATE?
OF PROJECT LEVY FOREVER MORE THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR WHAT HAPPENS ON NOT LEVY SO
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE STUCK
WITH THAT KIND OF LIABILITY THEY
DON'T BELIEVE THAT PRIVATE
UTILITY SHED.
CATHOLICS HAVE ALL THAT BIG A
VERY MUCH THANK YOU [inaudible]
SPEAKER.
GOOD AFTERNOON GRACE FERGUSON
WITH THE URBAN COUNTIES THE
CALIFORNIA AND WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
SUPERVISOR DILLON IN C. SACK.
AND NOTE THAT WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THE REASON I'M IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND ALSO
OPPOSED TO ANY CHANGES IN THE
SHIFTING LIABILITY AND THANK YOU
MELISSA CORTES ROTH ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION.
AND I JUST WANNA HIGHLIGHT A
LETTER THAT WAS SENT TO
LEADERSHIP BACK IN MAY THAT WAS
SIGNED BY ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S.
MAJOR RENEWABLE ENERGY TRADE AND
ADVOCACY ASSOCIATIONS IN
ADDITION TO CAL WE ARE THAT
INCLUDED THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS.
ALL LARGE SCALE SOLAR
ASSOCIATION AMERICAN WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CAUCUS
THE GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION AND THE CENTER FOR
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND RENEWABLE
TECHNOLOGY.
THAT LETTER EMPHASIZE THE FACT
THAT WHILE BY LIABILITY IS
SIMPLY NOT A PROBLEM FOR
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES.
LEFT UNSOLVED THE POTENTIAL
INSOLVENCY OF THE I USE WILL
UNDERMINE THE EXISTING OUR PS
CONTRACTS.
THAT ARE LARGELY RESPONSIBLE FOR
ACHIEVING THE STATE'S GREENHOUSE
GAS BOTH TO DATE AND UNDERMINE
FURTHER PROGRESS SO WE APPLAUD
THE PROGRESS THAT WAS MADE TODAY
TOWARD THE DRESSING THESE
COMPLEX ISSUES.
EVERYONE URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO
MAKE CONCRETE PROGRESS TO
ADDRESS THIS BEFORE THE END OF
THE SESSION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON PAUL
MAKES NO SPECIFIC FOREST'S TRUST
I'LL BE BRIEF AND DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS LETTER THAT I
DELIVERED YESTERDAY FROM PACIFIC
FOR US TRUST ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND.
DO CONSERVATION VOTERS AND
SEVERAL OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
HIGHLIGHTING THAT BEFORE TRYING
TO COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT
WILDFIRE IN CALIFORNIA WE REALLY
NEED TO LOOK AT THE CONDITION OF
THE LANDSCAPE AND ALL LOOK TO
SOMEONE DAHLE IT.
TO HAVE REALLY SOME RIGHT MANY
OF MY COMMENTS HERE THAT PASSED
MANAGEMENT AND PASSED FIRE
SUPPRESSION HAS FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGED THE COMPOSITION OF OUR
FORESTS MANY OTHER LANDSCAPE SO
WE HAVE. TO MANY SMALL TREES NOT
ENOUGH LARGE OUT OF THIS HOLE
THAT WE'VE CREATED IS GOING TO
TAKE A SUSTAINED EFFORT.
PART OF THAT SUSTAINED EFFORT
NEEDS TO BE AN ONGOING AND
STABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING FROM
THE STATE WE'VE HAD THESE LARGE
INFLUXES OF FUNDING THROUGH THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
AND HAS BEEN FANTASTIC IN A
REALLY GOOD WAY TO JUMP START.
THINGS BUT WITHOUT
PREDICTABILITY TO ONGOING
SOURCES OF FOR DOING WORK IN
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE IS OR
IN RURAL FOREST AREAS IT'S
REALLY HARD FOR LANDOWNERS COME
THE TABLE FOR BUSINESSES TO RAMP
UP THEIR WORK FORCE. TO THAT
PREDICTABILITY IS VITAL I THINK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AN OF
A SCHISM HERE BEHALF OF HEALTH
FOR NEVER NOTICES THE ALLIANCE
AND I JUST WANNA AT TOOK
OPPOSITION ADDITION TO THE
PREVENTION AND ON THAT STATION
MANAGEMENT AND DISCUSSION THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVING IS HOWARD
PROTECTING SPECIFICALLY REPAIRS
AND SPECIFICALLY LOW INCOME
REPAIRS.
FROM THESE AND IT FROM BASICALLY
BEING IMPACTED BY THESE FIRES
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
REALLY WANT TO WORK ON IS HOW DO
WE ACTUALLY PER DAY CAN PUT
SAFEGUARDS.
IN WHATEVER PLAN COMES OUT AND
SPECIFICALLY ON TRYING TO REALLY
SAFEGUARD OUR LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS FROM E. ACTUALLY
EATING UP THE COSTS AND KNOWING
THAT THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO AFFORD
IT.
AND SPECIFICALLY HOW DO WE
PROTECT OUR UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED SPECIFICALLY IN THAT
THOMAS FIRE AND AND THE OX
NORMAN BUDDHA COUNTY THAT WE'RE
STILL TRYING TO PROVIDES EVEN.
SAFETY NETS FOR THEM GIVEN THAT
THEY DON'T QUALIFY FOR A LOT OF
FEDERAL MONIES ARE COMING AND
SPECIFICALLY THE UNINSURED WHO
ARE NOT ABLE TO ACTUALLY COLLECT
ANY --
MITTENS LIABILITIES ARE ANY
MEDICATION FOR THEM TO ACTUALLY
SURVIVE SO WHAT THOSE REASONS
AND WE'RE GONNA BE SOME BOMBS
MEDINA COMMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE
SO THEY CASH WOULD LOOK INTO
THIS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN DON
CHAIRMAN HOLDEN MEMBERS --
HO SAID NON THIS PRESENT IDEA
CALIFORNIA ALSO SERVED IN THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSIONS LOW INCOME OVERSIGHT
BOARD. FOR ABOUT TWELVE YEARS --
WHILE WE DON'T HAVE COMMENTS ON
PREVENTION WE DO AGREE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY WITH ASSEMBLYMAN
DOLLARS COMMENTS THAT THE
COMMITTEE SHOULD TAKE TIME AND
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES BUCKLEY
LOOKING AT BIOMASS AND MAYBE
ALSO UNDER GROUNDING WIRES
LOOKING AT THE COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS --
WE HEAR TO DRESS MORE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL --
JUST WANT CAN I CLARIFY THAT
THAT PROPOSALS NOT REALLY ABOUT
A BNEFITING UTILITIES IT'S
ABOUT BENEFITING RATEPAYERS.
CURRENTLY THE UTILITIES PROVIDE
SERVICE.
TO MILLION LOW INCOME RATEPAYERS
AND THEY HAVE THE PLEASURE OF
BEING SERVED BY CALIFORNIA'S
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE UNPARALLELED
IN THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
AND QUICK TO THE POINT IS THAT
FISCAL STABILITY BENEFITS ALL
THE EXISTING LOW INCOME RIGHT
THERE'S WELCOME HIGH HOW YOU
GUYS ARE TODAY.
MY NAME'S I'VE READ --
I'M -- I'M
WITH IBEW LOCAL --
TWELVE FORTY FIVE I'M GONNA GIVE
A SHORT SWEET IT WAS HARD FOR
ME.
TO SAY ALL I WANNA SAY SUCH AS
ROAD OUT.
SO WE DO WANT A HARDER GRADE AND
MAKE IT A STANDARD FOR OTHERS TO
FOLLOW AS A OF THE TOADIES ARE
WE DO WANT TO SEE THE VICTIMS OF
THE NORTH BAY FIRES TO ONCE
AGAIN FEEL WHOLE AND ENSURE THAT
THEIR SAFETY.
AND ALL SAFETY OF THE OF THE
OTHER COMMUNITIES YOU KNOW FEEL
SAFE.
WITH OUR UTILITIES OUR UTILITIES
AND WORKERS IN SURE. TO HELP
MAINTAIN THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WE NEED.
YOU KNOW THAT WE NEED TO KEEP
YOU KNOW PEOPLE FULLY SAFE.
SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T DISMANTLE THE UTILITIES
AND JUST MORE.
KEEPING OUR WORKERS IN THE
UTILITIES YOU KNOW SAFE TO
DILIGENT DILIGENTLY TO KEEP OUR
SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITIES SORRY
[inaudible]
REGINA.
CHARLOTTE STEVENS IBEW TWELVE
FORTY FIVE THAT'S WHEN I CALLED
MY BROTHER SAID HERE.
AS UTILITY WORKER WE DO YOU WANT
TO ENSURE THAT THE FIRE VICTIMS
ARMY HALL.
AS WELL WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT UTILITIES ARE THAT WAY WE
CONTINUE TO ENFORCE INITIALLY
THE HARDENING OF THE GREAT
THINKING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE BAY JOHNSON
ALSO IBEW TOLL FORTY FIVE AND
AGAIN JUST TO REITERATE AND
SUPPORT.
MY BROTHERS AND SISTERS YOU JUST
LEAVE THAT THE FIRE VICTIMS --
UNDOUBTABLY OUR FIRST PRIORITY
IN WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE WHOLE
AGAIN.
WE ALSO WANT TO SHOW THAT
UTILITIES NOT BE HARMED AS IT
WOULD CAUSE US.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE FOR THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN TO NOT ONLY THE
VICTIMS --
THAT THE RATE PAYERS ECONOMY --
INTERNET WILL BE ABLE TO THEN --
HARD ELECTRIC GRID HAD TO MAKE
MORE EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JEREMY SMITH IBEW
TWELVE FORTY FIVE IS ONE ECHO
THE FACT I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT EVERY HARD IN THE
ELECTRICAL GRID.
OUT FOR ALL SAFETY THANK YOU
HAVE A GOOD [inaudible]
IF YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN AKARI IBEW
TWELVE FORTY FIVE JUST TO TOUCH
BASES ALL MY BROTHERS AND
SISTERS SAID TO HARDEN THE
ELECTRIC GRID.
AND MAKE IT MORE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE AND ALSO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL THE VICTIMS ARE MADE
WHOLE.
THINK YOU [inaudible]
IF YOU.
RICARDO HERNANDEZ HOW WOULD I BE
W. WE DO AGREE THAT THE VICTIMS
DO NEED TO BE MADE WHOLE --
INTERNALLY WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE HARDING THE ELECTRIC
READ ON FOR THE OVERALL SAFETY
[inaudible]
WRITTEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEVIN CHROMIS
IBEW TOLL.
FORTY FIVE PERSONALLY I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF MY STEP MOM MOLLY
MURPHY OF SANTA ROSA SHE LIVED
IN THE LARKFIELD --
NEIGHBORHOOD LOST EVERYTHING SHE
LESS THAN HALF AN HOUR.
A SHE NEVER BE MADE WHOLE BUT
I'VE YOU GUYS DO THE BEST YOU
CAN APPRECIATE THAT.
ARE COLLECTIVELY I'M HERE WITH
MY IBEW TWELVE FORTY FIVE
BROTHERS AND SISTERS --
NOT ONLY TO MAKE A FASHION
STATEMENT WITH THIS TEACHER BUT
TO ENSURE THAT THEY AGREED.
CHRIS HARDEN IN THAT WE DELIVER
SAFE NOW EFFICIENT ELECTRICITY
THANK YOU.
AN AWESOME IDEA IBEW --
TWELVE FORTY FIVE JUST ECHOING
PRIOR SENTIMENTS WILL ENSURE
THAT FIRE VICTIMS ARE MADE WHOLE
AS WELL AS ENSURING THAT
UTILITIES ARE IN A POSITION.
WHERE WE CAN CONTINUE HARD IN
THE ELECTRIC GRID TO MAKE IT
MORE SAFE AND EFFECTIVE?
I AM GEORGIA KOREA WITH IBEW
TWELVE FORTY FIVE AND JUST AS MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS OF SAID.
WE WANT TO MAKES THEA FIRE
VICTIMS HOLE I WE ALSO WANT TO
CONTINUE WITH THE HARDING OF THE
GRAIL WOULD --
TO ENSURE SAFETY AND EFFICIENCY.
GOOD AFTERNOON AMBER BLIX WITH
THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS
ASSOCIATION IP HAS BEEN
MONITORING THESE ISSUES CLOSELY
AND WE JUST WANTED TO INDICATE
OUR GENERAL SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE PROPOSAL AND
LETTER THAT WAS SUBMITTED TO
THIS COMMITTEE YESTERDAY.
WE THINK IT'S A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TO DEALING WITH
MANY OF THESE COMPLICATED
ISSUES.
AND JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR EFFORTS ON
THESE VERY COMPLICATED ISSUES
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR WORK AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THE FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON UP LIKE A CASTRO
AND JUST WANTED BANK AGAIN THE A
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE. FOR
MAKING THIS A TRANSPARENT
PROCESS FOR THE PUBLIC.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT A A
RP WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO THE
UTILITY COMPANIES DEVELOPING
WIRE FIRE WHILE FIRE SAFETY
PLANS ONE TO MAKE THAT CLEAR.
BUT WHAT WE DO OPPOSE IS GIVING
UTILITY COMPANIES WHAT BASICALLY
AMOUNTS TO A BLANK CHECK.
THEIR ABSOLVING THEM FROM THEIR
FULL RESPONSIBILITY AND IT'S
ALLOWING THEM TO PASS IT ON TO
THE RATE PAYERS.
THERE ARE MORE THAN THREE
MILLION MEMBERS OF AARP IN
CALIFORNIA NEARLY ALL OF WHOM
ARE RATEPAYERS AND MANY OF WHOM
LIVED ON FIXED INCOMES.
TODAY IT'S A HUNDRED AND FIVE
DEGREES OUTSIDE.
SO YOU CAN IMAGINE AIR
CONDITIONING IS PRETTY CRITICAL
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS.
AND I JUST WANTED A REMINDER THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE THAT
MILLIONS OF OLDER CALIFORNIANS
RELY ON SOCIAL SECURITY AS THEIR
ONLY SOURCE OF INCOME.
AND THE AVERAGE BENEFIT MONTH
MET AVERAGE MONTHLY BENEFIT IS A
MERE TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
FROM WHICH THEY MUST PAY THEIR
HOUSING FOOD MEDICAL EXPENSES
AND UTILITIES.
SO AS SENATE BILL NINE A ONE IS
CURRENTLY PRISON BRITAIN WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
HELLO.
MY NAME IS COLORADO CAMERINO --
REPRESENTING AARP AND I WILL
ECHO THE OPPOSITION TO A S. B..
NINE OH ONE BECAUSE THE UTILITY
COMPANIES WOULD BE ABLE --
TO PASSED THE RATE OF THE
INCREASE THE COST --
TO RATEPAYERS.
I LIVE IN FAIRFIELD I'M YOUR
CONSTITUENTS SIR SENATOR DIED.
FINALLY NICE TO MEET YOU --
THE ATLAS FIVE WAS JUST A FEW
MILES FROM MY HOME.
AND THAT I WAS WITH A BROKEN ME
CAST ON MY LEG WONDER HOW THEY
EVACUATE.
SO I'M ALL FOR SAFETY I'M ALL
FOR ADVANCED PLANNING.
AND RELIABILITY BUT WHAT WHAT
WE'RE POSTING IS THE ABILITY OF
THE UTILITY COMPANIES THROUGH
ALMOST ARBITRARILY --
INCREASE THE RATE.
AT THE EXPENSE OF THE RATEPAYERS
THANK YOU.
THEY Q. AND JUST FOR THE RECORD
--
NINE OH ONE IS JUST THROUGH THE
VEHICLE OF HOW THIS.
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE THAT WILL
LOOK COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE [inaudible]
WE'RE DONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHOI DUFF MBAH
I'M A VOLUNTEER FOR A OUR P.
HERE IN THE CAPITAL [inaudible]
AND I AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT A
POSSIBLE BAILOUT OF PGE AN E..
CALIFORNIA HAS A VERY HIGH COST
OF LIVING WE HAVE HIGH UTILITY
RATES ALREADY THAT MAKE IT VERY
HARD FOR SENIORS --
TO EXIST LIMITED INCOMES I HAVE
FOR FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE
WITHOUT A HOME NOW BECAUSE OF
THE TYPES FIRE IN LOSING
EVERYTHING AND THAT AND SO I
EMPATHIZE WITH THOSE OF YOU WHO.
ALSO -- HAVE
THAT SITUATION.
OF THOSE WHO LOST THEIR HOMES IN
THE FIRES HAVE MANY ADDED
EXPENSES THAT INSURANCE DOESN'T
COVER.
SO PLEASE DON'T VICTIMIZE THE
VICTIMS AGAIN IN THE NAME OF A
CORPORATE BAILOUT THERE MUST BE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
CONTINUING FOR OUR UTILITIES AND
FOR THEIR SHAREHOLDERS THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS AS AUTHOR BUSCA ALSO
A VOLUNTEER WITH A A RP.
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
A A RP CONSIDER --
PIERCE [inaudible]
OF WE WE WE ARE PRESENT THE
OLDER OUR SENIOR CITIZENS IN THE
COMMUNITY AND AS YOU.
AS WE HAVE MENTIONED BEFORE LOT
OF THEM ARE NOT ON A FIXED
INCOME STILL I APPLAUD YOUR
EFFORTS FOR THIS VERY DIFFICULT
THE JOB THAT YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU
--
BUT LIKE TO ASK YOU TO TRY TO BE
A CREATIVE INNOVATIVE AND HOW TO
IMPROVEMENTS AND TRIED NOT TO
KEEP AND TRY TO KEEP THE COSTS
AWAY FROM THE THE LESS FORTUNATE
OR THE SENIOR CITIZENS OF OUR
COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VIRGINIA FIAMMA TONY AND I AM
ALSO A VOLUNTEER WITH OUR SO I
JUST WANNA SAY I DO ECHO THE
SAME THINGS THAT MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE SAID.
AND I JUST WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH.
FOR TAKING THIS TIME AND IT'S A
LOT OF ENERGY TO FOCUS AND
CONCENTRATE ON EVERYTHING THAT'S
BEING SAID.
THERE'S A LOT TO BE DONE WE
REALLY NEED TO TAKE CARE OF THIS
AND CERTAINLY IN A TIMELY
FASHION FOR EVERYBODY.
BECAUSE NOT JUST FOR ME AS THE
SENIORS WITH CITIZEN.
BUT FOR ALL OUR CITIZENS IN THIS
STATE IT IS VERY IMPORTANT SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE MICHAEL SAW
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION.
APOLOGIZE MY VOICE --
BOOK WE REPRESENT --
OR MEMBER I SHOULD SAY THE
REPAIR PROTECTION NETWORK A
COALITION OF CALIFORNIANS.
PRIORITIZING SAFETY
AFFORDABILITY ACCOUNTABILITY I'M
NOT A UTILITY --
BLANK CHECK AND I THINK TO THAT
POINT WE WOULD STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU THAT IN THE
PROCESS OF CONSIDERING.
A WHATEVER REFORM SO YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE IMPACT RATE
PAYERS [inaudible]
RESIDENTIAL AGRICULTURAL.
IN A DUST ROAD REPAIRS AS WELL
ALL OF WITH ALL THESE CLASSES
WHICH PAY WELL ABOVE THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE.
ARE CURRENTLY IN UTILITY RATES I
IN THE CASE OF INDUSTRIAL
RATEPAYERS WERE ABOUT 86% ABOVE
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE.
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND 10%
ABOVE OUR NEIGHBORING STATES.
THAT AFFECTS COMPETITIVENESS
THAT AFFECTS THE AFFORDABILITY
OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA THAT
AFFECTS OUR ABILITY TO CREATE.
A GOOD PAYING JOBS --
ALSO OCCURRED YOU --
WIN WHEN CONSIDERING OTHER
OPTIONS HERE --
REGARDING THAT TWENTY SEVENTEEN
LIABILITIES.
LOOK AT ADDITIONAL SOURCES OF
REVENUE --
OUTSIDE OF THE REPAIRS --
WE BELIEVE THAT WALT REPAIRS --
BENEFITTED OR FROM THE
INVESTMENT OR LACK OF INVESTMENT
AYE IMPROVEMENTS IN THE SYSTEM
SHAREHOLDERS BENEFITTED AS WELL
THE STATE BENEFITTED AS WELL.
SO WE NEED TO BE LOOKING BROADER
THAN JUST THE RATEPAYERS FOR
POTENTIALLY FINDING AVENUES FOR
DEALING WITH THE CURRENT
SITUATION THAT WE'RE FACING
THANK YOU.
TERM AM REDUCE CENTERS WITH THE
WESTERN SEAS PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
CMT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS ROB NASH
OF THE AMERICAN PISTACHIO
GROWERS WE REPRESENT NEARLY
SEVEN HUNDRED GROWERS AND
PROCESSORS --
AND FOR THE PURPOSES OF TODAY'S
HEARING RATEPAYERS --
WE HAD MEMBERS IN ARIZONA
CALIFORNIA AND NEW MEXICO YET
ARE CALIFORNIA MEMBERS PAY FAR
HIGHER ON ENERGY RATES --
NEVER LOT TODAY SO I JUST WANNA
Y. MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS OF
THAT YOU'VE HEARD EARLIER AND
WITH THOSE OF SENATOR HUESO AND
SENATOR DIED IN YOUR CONCERN
OVER MAKING SURE.
REPAIRS ARE TAKING CARE OF WE'RE
A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED THAT A
RATE PAYER ADVOCATE WASN'T ALL
YOUR PANELISTS TODAY BUT WE'RE
CONFIDENT THAT MOVING FORWARD.
OF THIS COMMITTEE WILL CONTINUE.
TO CONSIDER OTHER A PAIR AND
YOUR FUTURE.
COMMITTEES HEARINGS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE LARA KNOW AND
HE JUST ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL CALIFORNIA
CONGENERS ANGERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE USING EASY
FARMER SLEEK AND WESTERN ACT
PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION --
IT THANK YOU FOR THAT HEARING
TODAY I STAND BEFORE YOU A LOT
TALKING ABOUT HOW HARD IT IS FOR
AGRICULTURE IN THE FACT THAT WE
CAN'T PASS ON OUR COSTS. TO THE
CONSUMER SO AS WE'RE LOOKING AT
THIS ISSUE AND WITH RATE HERE
COSTS.
POTENTIALLY GOING UP
DRAMATICALLY LOOKING AT TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND ALSO
LOOKING FORWARD.
AND ADDS TO THE COST OF
HARDENING THE SYSTEM IN SAFETY
AND MAINTENANCE WE HAVE GREAT
CONCERNS WITH THAT.
ON AS REPAIRS WE KNOW WE BENEFIT
FROM SAFE AND RELIABLE SYSTEMS
AND WE UNDERSTAND THERE'S A COST
WITH THAT.
BUT IF THE STATE ALSO BENEFITS
FROM A SAFE AND RELIABLE SYSTEM.
SHAREHOLDERS ALSO BENEFIT FROM
IN A SAFE AND RELIABLE SYSTEM.
INSURANCE BENEFITS FOR A SAFE
AND RELIABLE SYSTEM SO I'M I WON
I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY
FOR RAISING THE ISSUE OF OUR
FORCE MANAGEMENT WE THINK THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF THIS
--
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD FOR
ASKING THE QUESTION OF WHO PAID
FOR THAT BILLION DOLLARS IN
INVESTMENT DOWN IN SAN DIEGO.
WHILE THE ANSWER WASN'T SAID
TODAY I THAT RATE PAYERS PAID A
LOT OF THAT --
SO WOULD CONTINUE I'M TO
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO ASK
THOSE QUESTIONS AND ENSURE THAT
ALL OF THOSE WHO ARE BENEFITING
FROM A SAFE AND RELIABLE SYSTEM
HAVE A STAKE IN THE GAME IN
PAYING FOR THAT.
THANK YOU.
ARTHUR HARTMAN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LARGE ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION IS OF THE
LARGE INDUSTRIAL CUSTOMERS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SINCE MOST MY COMMENTS WERE
ALREADY --
STATED FROM MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
REPAIR GROUP SIZE ONE TO SAY I
AGREE WITH MOST OF THAT WHAT
THEY SAID MAJORITY BUT THEY
SAID.
AND WOULD URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
JUST A CONSIDER ANY RATE PAYER
IMPACT ON WHATEVER YOU IF YOU DO
ON THE BILL AND I MEAN ALREADY
PAYER IMPACT.
AND BE AWARE OF ANY SHIFT IN MY
ABILITY TO THE RATE PAYERS.
ON THAT WILL BE A BIG CONCERN TO
US THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON STACEY HEAT MORAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA RC RC REPRESENTING
THIRTY FIVE RURAL COUNTIES
STATEWIDE.
AT FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK BOTH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALIAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD FOR THEIR COMMENTS
ON THE NEED TO MANAGE OUR
FORESTS AND TO PREVENT WILDFIRE
WE'VE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR THAT
FOR A LONG TIME AND THAT'S A ONE
OF OUR HUGE ISSUES AT RC RC.
AND WE WE LIKE MANY OF THE
COMPONENTS OF WHAT'S BEEN
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL REGARDING WILDFIRE
PREVENTION.
HOWEVER WE'D LIKE TO COMMIT ECHO
ARE BECAUSE THE COMMENTS OF OUR
COLLEAGUES AT C. SAKON
SUPERVISORS BROWN AND I DILLON.
REGARDING THE INVERSE
CONDEMNATION PROPOSAL WE ALSO
QUESTION THE CONSTITUTIONALITY
OF IT AND FEEL IT WOULD HAVE A
EXTREME CONSEQUENCES FOR BOTH OF
THOSE THAT SUFFER FROM THE
WILDFIRES AND FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
AND SO WHILE WE UNDERSTAND THIS
IS A VERY COMPLEX CONVERSATION
--
WE FEEL THERE'S A LOT MORE
VETTING THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
[inaudible]
AND YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
PATRICK WELL TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING PUBLIC COMMUNITY
OWNED AND UTILITIES THAT DELIVER
POWER TO ABOUT A LITTLE OVER 20%
THE STATE WATER TO ABOUT 70% OF
THE STATE.
AND I THINK IT'S BEEN NOTED THAT
THERE'S A WIDE VARIETY OF ISSUES
OF WHY WE'RE SEEING --
MORE SEVERE MORE FREQUENT
WILDFIRES AND SO WE APPRECIATE
THE COMPREHENSIVE DISCUSSION
HERE TODAY WE SUPPORT AND
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE.
AS WELL AS THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTAIN TO WORK
WITH THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE --
ANA ON A WIDE VARIETY OF THE
COMPLEX ISSUES THAT THIS
COMMITTEE IS GONNA ATTEMPTED TO
TACKLE THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CORNELIUS BURKE WITH THE BEAR
COUNCIL REPRESENT THREE HUNDRED
THE TOP EMPLOYERS IN THE NIGHT
COUNTY.
A BEAR REGION --
WE URGE YOU TO PRESERVE A
HEALTHY ENERGY SECTOR ENERGY
SECTOR IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
ECONOMY.
AND ALSO THE TRAINERS LOT OF
INVESTMENT FOR CLEAN ENERGY AND
CLIMATE CHANGE FUNDING.
ARE MOVING FOR WE LOOK FORWARD
TO ADVICE POLICIES AND
REGULATIONS ON FOREST MANAGEMENT
HAVE EDUCATION MANAGEMENT --
CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND ALSO
REVISED RULES ON LIABILITY THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
MR CHAIRS AND MEMBERS THAT MARIA
GARCIA SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
SNOW MENTAL AND TRUST IT'S A
LOCAL NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION.
AT BASED IN CINEMA VALLEY HERE
TODAY TO REALLY EXPRESS
APPRECIATION FOR THE
CONVERSATION ON VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IN FORESTRY.
AND BEST PRACTICES WE AND SO.
STATE AND COUNTY AGENCIES TO DO
JUST THAT WE EH APPRECIATE THAT
EDUCATION ENCOURAGEMENT
INCENTIVIZING LANDOWNERS TO
DEVELOP LAND MANAGEMENT
STRATEGIES THAT WILL REDUCE
FUTURE WILDFIRE RISKS IN A WAY
THAT PROTECT LIVES AND
PROPERTIES.
I'M IN SPECIFICALLY IN THOSE
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE AREAS
APPRECIATE THAT DISCUSSION AND
OVER TO COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTIONS
THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS ATTORNEY
HUGHES THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
FOOD PRODUCERS REPRESENTING THE
FOOD PROCESSING INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA AND I'D LIKE TO JUST
SAY THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
TODAY FOR TAKING THE TIME.
A TO LOOK AT THESE COMPLEX
ISSUES I CAN TELL YOU UP FROM A
RATE PAYERS PERSPECTIVE IN THE
INDUSTRIAL SECTOR WERE EXTREMELY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CONVERSATIONS.
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE A
SHARED RESPONSIBILITY WE WOULD
ARGUE AYE THAT ARE IN ANY ANY
SORT OF RATE INCREASES AS WAS
EXPRESSED BY CMT A IN OTHER
RATEPAYERS IS EXTREMELY
DETRIMENTAL TO YOU.
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
RETENTION OF JOBS WE JUST ASK
THAT YOU TAKE A RATE PAYER A
COMMENTS VERY SERIOUSLY AND THAT
YOU CONTINUE TO ATTACK OUR TAKE
OUR THOUGHTS INTO CONSIDERATION
AND APPRECIATE UP AGAIN YOU
BEING HERE TODAY THANK YOU --
MISTER CHAIRS MEMBERS MICHAEL
BOCA DORE WEST COAST ADVISERS ON
BEHALF OF THE AG ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION WHICH
REPRESENTS SOME THE LARGEST
FARMING OPERATIONS FOOD
PROCESSORS --
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY THEY
ALSO HAPPEN TO BE SOME OF THE
LARGEST EMPLOYERS IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND THAT WE TO
OUR SHARE THE CONCERNS OF THE
OTHER RATE PAYER GROUPS HAVE
EXPRESSED TODAY.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE BALANCE
THESE ISSUES AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
I'M GONNA SHARE ONE LAST POINT
WITH YOU AND THAT IS SKIN IN THE
GAME UTILITIES HAVE VERY LITTLE
SKIN IN THE GAME.
THESE INVESTMENTS TO GET MADE
AFTER THESE CRISES COME FROM
RATE PAYERS.
WE'RE PAYING FOR THOSE
INVESTMENTS AND GOING FORWARD I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE LIABILITY RISK IS
NOT JUST GETTING REDUCE FOR
RATEPAYERS IT'S ALSO GETTING
REDUCED. FOR SHAREHOLDERS AND WE
WOULD DO A LOT BETTER IF
SHAREHOLDERS HAD SOME SKIN IN
THE GAME IF THEY WERE PICKING UP
50% OF THOSE INVESTMENTS BECAUSE
THEY'RE GETTING.
THE SAME BENEFIT THE RATEPAYERS
ARE REDUCED LIABILITY RISK THAT
ALSO BE A LOT MORE PRUDENT ABOUT
THE TYPES OF INVESTMENTS THEY
MAKE.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING I WANT YOU
ALL THINK VERY HARD ABOUT GOING
FORWARD A LITTLE SKIN IN THE
GAME.
WOULD GO A LONG WAY FROM THE
SHAREHOLDERS TO TAKE SOME OF THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL OF
THOSE ALL OF YOU WHO'VE SPOKE
TODAY I THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU THIS IS AS
WHICH ARE RECOGNIZED EARLIER --
DESIGNED TO BE A TRANSPARENT
PROCESS THIS IS A SERIES OF VERY
CHALLENGING ISSUES WE RECOGNIZE
THAT -- BUT
WE REALLY DO APPRECIATE.
ALL OF YOU WHO ARE STILL HERE --
BUT ALL OF THOSE WHO WERE HERE
EARLIER AS WELL BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WE'RE VENTURING INTO NEW
TERRITORY.
AND OH ALTHOUGH AS WAS POINTED
OUT BY MANY OF THE MEMBERS ARE
PART OF THIS PANEL [inaudible]
THAT.
OF WHO REPRESENT AREAS THAT ARE
VERY PRONE --
TO WILDFIRES IN AND AS WE NOW
SEE CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES --
THERE WERE WARNING SIGNS.
BUT WE'RE HERE WE ARE NOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THIS DONE
RIGHT.
OF THERE ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
DIMENSIONS TO IT AND I THINK
THAT WAS HIGHLIGHTED AS WELL
THROUGH THE THROUGH THIS HEARING
--
AND WE KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO BE VERY --
JUDICIOUS IN TERMS OF HOW WE
FOCUS OUR OUR EFFORTS.
WINDING DOWN --
TO THE END OF THE SESSION TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN THEN.
MAKE SOMETHING --
RECOMMENDATION THAT'S PRODUCTIVE
THAT ADDRESSES.
OF THE ISSUES A REPAIR.
A PROTECTION OF STABILIZE THE
INDUSTRY.
AND MAKING SURE THAT SAFETY USE
OR PERSON FROM WEST AS WELL.
AS SO I JUST WANT TO THANK ALL
OF THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I WANNA TAKE MY CO CHAIR.
OF FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN HELPING
TO ORGANIZE HIS FIRST MEETING.
ARE WE ARE GOING TO CAUCUS AND
THEN REFLECT ON HOW WE CAN
STRUCTURE BEST THE NEXT MEETING.
ON A LOT OF IMPORTANT
INFORMATION THAT WAS SHARED HERE
TODAY BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHEN WE MEET AGAIN THAT.
AS THE COMMITTEE IT'S VERY
PRODUCTIVE.
AND FOCUSED IN THE GETS IS TO
GOAL OF SOONER THAN LATER.
AND THEN WE WILL PROBABLY MAY
NEED TO HAVE ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
TESTIMONY --
FROM OTHER WITNESSES ARE
ADDRESSING OTHER COMPONENTS OF
THE DIFFERENT RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT ARE OUT THERE SO WE CAN
HAVE THE FULLNESS OF OF OF INPUT
FROM THE PUBLIC.
AS WE MAKE OUR WAY THROUGH THE I
DO APPRECIATE --
ALL OF YOUR COMING UP HERE TODAY
THOSE WHO HAD.
FLY THOSE WHO DROVE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
COLLABORATE AND GET TO SOME.
ROUTE SOLUTIONS TO THESE VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT ARE OUT
THERE AND BEEN ADDRESS THE NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED.
SO THANK YOU AND CHAIRMAN DOT
ATTORNEY BACK OVER YOU I JUST
APPRECIATE.
DISSIPATION TODAY OBVIOUSLY
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF WORK AHEAD OF
US I THINK THAT --
AS I SAID EARLIER --
IN A LOT OF THESE AREAS THERE'S
MORE QUESTIONS THAN ANSWERS
RIGHT NOW WE GOT A LOT OF WORK
TO DO.
A POLICE --
BE CHECKING THE WEBSITE --
THE INFORMATION WILL BE POSTED
TO THE WEBSITE.
MORE WILL BE PUT UP ALSO OUR
FUTURE DATES AND TIMES WILL BE
MEETING WE'LL BE.
ON THERE AS WELL AND I
APPRECIATE THE CO CHAIR AND AND
THE MEMBERS FOR BEING HERE TODAY
THANK YOU